[Music]
Magnus Carlson gets the Armageddon
victory over over hiar Nakamura he leads
them all here at the Champions chess
tour finals but right behind him is the
man who loves the flow from Toronto
that's Wesley so but perhaps the biggest
story of all was the youngster Dennis
lavic getting his first match Victory
and speaking of youngsters Notre Becca
Dua turov gets two match victories it's
the 2023 Champions chess tour final
right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less travel
rubber meets the road I'm on the road to
nowhere that need to get up and go to
just shut up and drive to Parts Unknown
it's in our DNA but this road has an end
and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curv NES Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
we see a reaction Magnus Magnus Mouse
SLI oh my gosh look at Jan's face some
have pulled over but some what is he
doing slammed that foot to the floor and
just kept going any second nakura is the
winner not a up Maxim vaj the Frenchman
he wins the AI cup after six stops along
the way it's time for the greatest
proven ground and online chess to drop
that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
now we are back again in a city that is
quickly becoming one of the capitals of
the Chess World why is every downtown
always under construction the world may
never know but the chess has been under
construction and it will be all week
here in Toronto as the Champions chess
tour final round five today gets
underway we bring you inside the playing
Hall Once Again Danny wrench alongside
the legend James KY we're about to throw
down on a day that has Stakes higher
than ever today could be someone's last
day two of them maybe more but of course
at the same time guys this is a very
very important day Danny you could go
home I don't want to go home Danny I
want to stay here lucky you don't have
to go home but two of the players could
be going home today and I don't know
that everyone watching at home fully
appreciates that the format has been
getting a lot of compliments the
excitement the way it breaks down but
today is so big we're going to get into
it and of course preview everything but
before we do we always welcome the third
member of our crew she is here she is
standing by she is
Kaa yep hey Danny still four boards
eight chairs left here in the venue
looking great as always but we do know
six players are fighting to not be one
of those two players knocked out after
the round robin so I do think we could
see some blood splashed out on these
boards today I am also hoping a little
bit that the players have been uh
frantically last minute practicing the
newest chessable course coming out today
it's our very own James cantis course on
the Joe Bava London big day for you
James in fact it did take me like N9
months to make the course I know you had
a baby recently Ka so you know are you
comparing a chessel course to I mean
kind did you did you also throw up every
day James I mean no wait no I didn't I
didn't might be a little tougher shout
out to Baby Max by the way I didn't do
that
okay yeah basically birthing your Joe
babal London course today shout out to
all the mothers out there it's going to
be a cool day here in the finals and uh
yesterday had some action so let's go
back to day two in the CCT finals and
there it is there's that night sacrifice
it couldn't be captured and hikaro he
attacks the black queen the queen goes
all the way back to the corner keeping
an eye at the square in front of the
white king and it's blocked yeah blocks
it out again dominance on the seventh
Rank and blunder from fua here go nakam
with a big turn around about to take the
lead in his match what a tactical flurry
that was Nakamura really upping the pace
turning on the style and yeah this is a
decisive material advantage you're also
Landing potentially a checkmating attack
and we see a handshake that is resigns
by Ala hiar Nakamura relieved after his
first win all of magnus' pieces are
doing something here and now files are
opening in front of Fab's King so he
stld a pawn but he opened the file so
the f file is open the G file as well
and maybe this Knight on E7 can go Queen
be W instead that is stunning take my
queen and give me a new one please and
on the way give your as well and Fabby
panicking there doesn't make his move in
time it looks like his clock is on zero
Tanya he ran out of time but it was a
lost position anyway oh look at the
position Hikaru is losing as we tune in
as Magnus breaks that little Pawn chain
there steals The Rook Pawn so now he'll
have a pass Pawn on opposite sides of
the board that's going to be too much
for the black pieces to deal with and 4
seconds so hearu he has to make a
move whoa Magnus is playing surprisingly
slowly but Karu she look at that speed
he's trying to pre-move but he's running
out of time there's no mouse there's no
mouse and okay hiar resigns handshakes
and Magnus gson does it takes it in the
Armageddon you know if anybody could
pre-move over the board it probably is
hkar Nakamura but unfortunately it was
not enough to hold on against the top
Norwegian he is the goat for a reason
he's doing Magnus things him and Wesley
so might punch their ticket directly to
the semi-finals before the day is
through but a reminder we do have one
more round of round robin play that
kicks things off tomorrow but if the
standings stay the way they are KY
Hikaru and fuia of all people would go
home you know that's really crazy to
even think about with fuja and Hikaru
going home like at the bottom right now
I mean Dennis lavic and nck that were
not really people's picks are are if it
ended today they would go home hikaro
and Ali Resa that's crazy it's usually
magmus Wesley and hikaro or Ali Resa
they're at the bottom right now this is
a really the stakes are so high again we
may not have full clarity but we could
so you're going to want to stay here all
day no matter what again we have the
last round of the round robin tomorrow
before the survival stage kicks off I'll
remind you of the format in a little bit
but let's go back to Magnus Carlson as
we said he's doing Magnus things the guy
he just wins a lot of chess games
against everybody he plays everything
and everyone in fact right we just see
it time and time again he's a goat for
the reason greatest of all time having
the highest feay classical rating ever
in the history of the game it's crazy
it's crazy how good he is there's a
reason his peers said that maybe maybe a
50% odds to start was too low you see
him playing the most accurate brand of
Chess of anyone here in Toronto even
more accurate than the so so solid
Wesley so wle Santo in fact is what they
call him but here I mean Magnus even he
said it yesterday himself he was like
hey if I'm playing good if I'm in in
good form he's basically Unstoppable
only person that stops him is himself
and he said it Wesley said it in the
interview which is weird to say right
before you play the man we'll see what
kind of mindset Wesley's in today but
yeah usually he has to worry about his
own form one thing I loved about that
graphic is only Magnus and Notre Beck
have yet to blunder they have not
blundered and that's a move according to
our game review stats usually that
changes the eval by about a pawn or so
so they have not made a single blunder
here it's crazy you know what we think
about Magnus we're going to throw to Ka
who caught up with a lot of the players
and we'll let he we'll let her intro
what the players thought about Magnus
yeah Danny I've actually taken a seat in
Magnus Carlson's chair for the day it's
super comfortable shout out to secret
lab for providing just the most
comfortable chairs for playing chess
sitting across for Magnus here in round
five will be Wesley so so these are the
two players on top of the table right
now and Wesley so he has huge respect
for Magnus Carlson of course always has
a lot of nice things to say about Magnus
but when I did sit down with the players
a couple of days ago before the
tournament started well Wesley so he's
questioning Magnus Carlson's
motivation uh so first of all what is
your take on Magnus Carlson growing up
he was my idol because when I started
playing chess he became World Champion
2013 it's always pretty cool I play
against him and I'm happy that I managed
to be quickly in the top so I could
compete against him so he's really
exceptional player
and amazing Champion I mean he still is
the best player by far I would say uh I
don't think he is as motivated in chess
as he once used to be marus Carlson is
of course he's incredibly strong it's
very hard to play against him well
Magnus Carson um could definitely be
considered the greatest player of all
time or at least in a close battle with
uh with Gary Kasper yeah it'll be
interesting to play against him see his
form um and hopefully at least some of
us can put up a good fight and maybe
maybe beat him uh the difference between
me and Magnus was uh like 300 tour
points so it means uh it means a lot so
I think that speaks for itself uh as
people like to
say well I have to say so far it has
looked like Magnus cson is motivated to
give us his very best chess I'm going to
throw it back to to Danny before Magnus
comes and kicks me out of this chair
back to you
Danny you don't want to be in that man's
chair as he sits off against Wesley so
but we will have six other players
sitting in chairs you got Nakamura Abus
turov lazic Carana and fuja Bash the
grav all in this round KY absolutely I
mean they're going to be fight it's
going to be a lot like as Ka said it's
going to be Blood on the board I mean
because today the last day you want to
prove yourself you want to get those
points everything matters I don't want
to go home there's a lot of emotions and
then there's a lot of Chess and a lot of
you have to get it done today speaking
of needing points we know that hiar
Nakamura needs them right now probably
more than anyone I think it's been on
the other side one of the biggest
surprises and that's cuz he has so many
fans he struggled so far thoughts yeah
it's tough because seeing hikaro at the
bottom there is never a thing that you
ever see even Al Resa as well so having
nordbeck and Las especially if they get
some confidence I mean who knows what
could actually happen today they're
going to have to find the form today and
now speaking of Notre Beck we go to the
tail of the tape hikaro will be facing
off against nck today and of course that
matchup has one player who won two games
sorry two matches yesterday and Notre
Beck at 19 years of age hikaro Nakamura
we know that he comes after Magnus in
many people's eyes for a reason will he
come after Magnus and everyone else by
getting some winds strung together here
in Toronto we don't know yet we know
he's going to have to do it against one
of the hottest Rising Stars a world
rapid champion and speaking of that
world rapid Champion I had a chance to
catch up with him before everything got
underway and uh well let's let's let you
see a little bit of a snippet of that
before the full interview hits the media
that is social I caught up with Notre
Beck here it
was what's your favorite first move
E4 why I played many games it I like the
positions after E4 were you ever a D4
player yeah I Rec switched to D4 yeah
when when did that happen um this year
actually and why no I played too many E4
games so I switched to D4 and I Al
sometimes play C4 was that like a a
preparation thing cuz you broke to like
higher levels and you wanted to just be
harder to prepare for of course yeah
okay yeah
was that on coach's advice yeah that's
idea when did you learn how to play
chess and tell me tell me that story who
taught you to play chess put a family
thing and take me back into the the
young Notre Beck when he first learned
the game yeah when I was 4 years old my
father taught me how
to uh how to play chess
and Tau me uh about basics of Chess how
to move bit by bit I started to play
with him and managed to you beat
him I think more than a half year okay
yeah
so after that he he he got that I'm I'm
a I have a special talent for chess so
he brought me to to coach uh I had my
first big achievements with him as
I I got some couple of medals in Asian
championships there then after that from
2012 I I started to work with uh Grand
Master diit kayumov I became Grand
Master with with his health what what
are your goals now um you know to to
reach uh at least
2800 and uh you know to course one day
to become world
champion I know we got into a lot of
Chess there on that preview but you're
going to want to see the full interview
we talk about his family his hopes his
dreams Notre Beck shared a lot with us
and I can't wait for everyone to check
out the full thing but all right canny
we got a couple of other matches we need
to get into let's dive right into the
one with the youngster who got his first
win yesterday taken on Fabio Carana who
after winning two matches struggled big
time on day two man if I'm feeling like
d last year you know I took down NBL
yesterday that's a very big feat I'm
feeling great if I'm denst here Fabby
okay went 0 and2 yesterday not the
greatest so I'm going to have to bounce
back really strong and right now hobby
yeah I mean you've got two players maybe
going different directions which one
will will keep the momentum or turn the
momentum around we're going to find out
and again speaking of players who want
to turn their Direction around the last
matchup we haven't looked at yet is Aldi
Resa fuia versus Maxim bash the grav I
feel like both of these guys have played
better chess than the score shows so far
I really really mean that but your
thoughts on on mvl and peruja their
mindset they need to have today after
both players lost both matches yesterday
yeah especially you have to get over
that hey I lost the match today's a new
one we both lost together you know what
hey we'll just put these losses together
and try to switch them into wins right
but that's going to be difficult to do
because only one is going to win that
one nvl lost to lavic which is tough
because that's the lowest rated player
in the field so you got to get over that
one f is like okay cool made it to
sarmageddon things are are here
hopefully it goes well today it's going
to be sharp for sure though very sharp
time is running out again for fans who
might be just tuning in the stakes are
higher than ever as we've talked about
the format is an exciting one people
have been loving it two players will not
be moving on to the survival stage let's
let the video take it away and remind
you of just how things are going down
here at the 2023 Champions chess T
finals the Champions chestor finals are
here eight players who have earned their
Spot Will face off in an epic battle to
determine who will be this year's
champion of champions up for grabs will
be $500,000 in prizes with first place
taking home $200,000 for the victory the
action opens with an eight player round
robin the top two finishers Advance
directly to the the semi-finals while
the bottom two are eliminated the
remaining four players will do battle in
a double elimination survival bracket
again the top two players Advance while
the bottom two players will be
eliminated the final four Champions are
headed to a single elimination bracket
the winner will be crowned our champion
of
champions all right as the players get
set in the playing all we've made our
way over to what we're now going to be
calling the predic booth and we're going
to dive right into giving you our
predictions for round five but before we
do I have an update for you on where we
stand currently got to be in first right
got to be all right well let's let's
let's let the standings reveal who's in
first that's right me and Ka are tied I
think I get I would win on tie breaks Ka
I think if ended that way aren't you a
chess exper J I mean yeah but we they
they check I'm facing this off feelings
let me do the uh yeah y'all rechecking
it okay thanks guys hey they they
they're going to do a I think I think
it's accurate I think it's accurate and
I think you still have some time to get
back in it but I think it's accurate
we'll see where it plays out frankly it
makes me want to take it a little more
seriously I wonder how the fans would be
doing at home but speaking of the fans
before we dive in to round five
predictions I want to let everyone know
the fan zone is completely sold out we
made a call to action to you the
community to consider buying the very
few tickets that remained for Friday and
uh guess what fan Zone completely sold
out we're going to see you guys with the
chess bras on Friday and Saturday
players and others will be there it's
going to be awesome so fan Zone sold out
it's time for round five predictions
let's dive in all right we're starting
at the top Magnus Carlson versus Wesley
so J we got to go with Carlson on this
one Magnus Carlson of course he's
showing you know the signs of a goat
which is he always does so also is
playing really good but Magnus is gonna
get it so I'm no chess expert I'm basing
my predictions of like like happiness
smiles and who has the biggest smile out
here it's Wesley so so I'm going to say
Wesley so in this big what's funny is I
debated this back and forth I think
we're looking at the two players who are
both going to punch their ticket
directly to the semi-finals but I
actually changed this morning and I'm
also going with so because I feel like
in Toronto the guy just has a
specialness about him plus I'm hoping
Magnus somehow gets wind of this
prediction and it gets under her skin a
little bit and we get a fight I okay
well so if if Magnus wins this we'll be
tied all right that's right right all
right Notre Beck and Hikaru abur versus
Nakamura I mean I always pick Nakamura
in every situation he's just my guy you
know so I got to ride with my guy maybe
you're jinxing him cuz he's struggling
right now maybe you should pick the
other guy maybe I should but this time
it's a different day so you know we'll
see what happens yeah well so aboro he
was in a great mood after some good
games yesterday but I just don't see
hikaro Nakamura not making it through so
my gut feeling says hikaro Nakamura
actually yeah I'm also going with Hikaru
I think Hikaru feels confident against
Abdu saurov I think maybe similar to fua
played so many games against him when he
was young he has a little bit of that
Magnus Edge over over them I think
Hikaru has an edge over fuia I think he
also has a little bit of an edge over
Abus tur off so all right our next match
up is Fabian a Carana versus Dennis lvic
the youngest player got his first win
yesterday does he continue he feeling
good but you are going to have to know
fight Goliath now or maybe like a step
under because of Magnus but whoever that
maybe Goliath's brother in a way but of
course Fabiano I'm going to pick him in
his situation all right yeah I'm just
putting myself in Dennis's truth I would
just be so happy got my match win
yesterday I'm just going to have a good
time and I'll bother if I'm if I lose
one so Fabiano Caro all right well I'm
excited because that means I have the
hot take I think Dennis lavic gets
another win I think that Fabby is going
to struggle he goes 202 I worry Fabby
may not be feeling as fresh as so is
here in Toronto and I think lvic is
going to surprise everyone and get
another dub wow all right last match
fuja versus Maxim bash lrav two players
who really struggled yesterday your
thoughts yeah I'm actually going with
fuo on this one of course MV did have
some problem he lost to lvic I mean not
lavic is the lowest in the field here
but he's the only one to lose to him so
they definitely have to rebound from
that that's going to be tough sometimes
mentally so I'm going play for Rion this
yeah these two have had some epic
battles in the past in the pre-
interviews I did with them in the sit
down interviews they had so many kind
words about each other so I'm super
excited about this one I will say ml I
will say Mel taking this one yeah it's
not just because he was mad at me about
the predictions yesterday I do thinka
has played better chess here than his
results show he's gone to multiple
Armageddon he just feels right on the
cusp and I don't know I don't know how
he's going to do it but he is going to
turn it around and I've got Alli Resa
fuja taking this match so there you go
those are our predictions fans remember
this is your chance to get in the chat
no matter where you're chatting from let
us know how wrong we are let us know how
much you miss us doing it right in front
of the players get involved but either
way it's now for us to get out of here
to throw it across the pond to Tanya and
the boys they continue to bring the hits
it's round five of the Champions chess
tour Oslo take it
away hey guys there's a lot of fomo
watching all of you have so much fun in
Toronto right now but we are on the edge
of our seats in our studio in Oslo
because today is such a critical day for
the players some could seal their fate
in just a few moments games will be
underway three games remain in the round
robin two will happen today and for hiar
Nakamura a really really crucial match
coming up and we are off and he's facing
somebody who had the best day of all
yesterday no abdar up lost his opening
two matches and then yesterday he was
back with v also do you see that monitor
behind them I haven't noticed that this
the first day where we have move numbers
next to the players wow that's going to
give us a helping hand as well as the
players uh perhaps it's because in the
Armageddon they do get increment after
move 60 so just a nice way to keep track
of the move count without having to
write down on those clunky score sheets
yeah and uh for Hikaru Nakamura who's
currently just had one match win how
crucial is this game NC he's on two
points I think a 50% score today would
see him in a good place for the survival
stage but Hikaru he's in danger Z right
now yeah we saw he had read next to his
name because he is in a tie for last
place he and Ali Razer are in a
difficult spot but he has the
opportunity in his hands he's playing us
NC Abdus satarov and when I look at this
position out of the gates it's not
something that we see in top level play
very often this is a kind of Cy opening
from hikaro he's showing game after game
he's willing to take players into his
territory even if those openings may be
considered dubious according to the
engines yeah I must admit six moves in
and already I'm a bit clueless I haven't
seen this position before uh that often
at top level chess it looks like black
has a great position pieces out active
Hikaru has been dabbling in this opening
a bit of late so I've do Soro surprising
to see him pause this early on it must
have been preparation it was uh
definitely easy or at least possible to
predict this one and okay he brings his
Knight out white does have a slightly
better structure black has one backward
Pawn the D Pawn uh but other than that
it looks very healthy for Hikaru that's
the essential point though in these
openings from the white side you look at
your queen sitting on its starting
Square she's looking down the board and
that black pawn in front of the black
queen that one often gets stuck so
hikaro pushes that pawn is that going to
be a weakness later on that's the key to
this kind of position and uh Hikaru does
push that pawn to D6 and look at Abdu
satoro there on the camera looking away
that's not because he's distracted he's
in recall mode he's trying to remember
his opening preparation I'm expecting
whites light squ Bishop to come out
Kings to Castle and at the middle game
yeah it's just about who Maneuvers
better yeah n back AB satro got a hot
streak on day two taking down danis
lazic and Fabiano caruana uh this is a
big game and it's clear that hikaru's
opening approach is so much to do with
his tournament situation he's just had
one match Victory he needs to create his
chances uh and the position that we have
one thing's clear that it is going to be
a fun one I'm slightly surprised with
the placement of this bishop on D3
because very often in these openings
it's about the fight of that D5 square
that Central Square and I was expecting
that nbec would naturally put that
Bishop on the diagonal of C4 Bishop D3
how would you explain this decision I
think he blundered right David this
looks like a bad move from nck yeah I
think already it's getting dramatic on
this board and look at this Hikaru is
pouncing on the mistake from the
youngster and Knight to G4 there's a
massive threat on the F2 Square Hikaru
is already in charge and that's St by
Hikaru he plays Knight G4 and he looks
up he can't believe it either I'm
stunned I mean n played amazing chess a
day ago he swept Fabiano Carana the
number two player in the world according
to classical ratings and Hikaru he
bounces from his chair and he's about to
pounce on the white king that F2 Pawn
that's Square it's extremely vulnerable
and I don't think white can successfully
defend it wow what a boss move there not
just Knight G4 on the last turn but to
get up to stand up and I think rightly
so suddenly White's in huge trouble
remember in chess the most vulnerable
points in any opening are always the F2
square and the F7 square and here nbec I
was expecting him just on the last turn
if we rewind to play a move such as
Bishop to E2 just to cover this Square
not to allow a knight to jump in but
after Bishop to D3 the Knight comes in
and wow Bishop to E3 Robert what is this
I mean he realizes that he can't Castle
kingside ideally you Castle defend that
F2 Pawn you see that off in the fried
liver but the black queen would hop out
to the H4 square and it's the H2 Pawn
with Checkmate if you push that pawn up
to H3 that Knight on G3 loses it cover
Knight takes F2 The Rook takes and then
the queen successfully gobbles on G3
there's a pin along the diagonal black
Scoops up material and wins the game
easily yeah this was a uh real pitf to
avoid he did avoid it nbec but the move
he played instead was a sad one Bishop
to E3 this is essentially throwing away
a pawn a pawn sacrifice out of necessity
and I mean the speed with which he
played it he's trying to Bluff he's
trying to keep a poker face but simply
black can whip off this bishop take it
you win a porn in the process and look
at this white canot keep Castle on
either side anyway wow this is disaster
for white this looks like a belated
birthday gift for Hikaru Nakamura NC
Abdu satro blund ing on move seven with
that developing move and you can see it
on the players Hikaru getting up looking
at nbec and now it's all about whether
Hikaru will be able to convert this
extra Pawn that we're expecting him to
take on E3 we will check back in on this
but let's head over to our tournament
leaders both players who won all their
matches they are on their hot streak
clearly the best performers so far
Magnus Carlson with the white pieces
taking on Wesley so and Magnus with that
last move looking at expanding on the
queen side to hit that Bishop on B6 and
I see that Robert David you guys are
still thinking about what we just saw on
the Hikaru board but what's going on on
this one very different type of position
Robert very very different yeah this one
is more positional in nature but it kind
of reminds me of game one between Magnus
Carlson and Fabiano Carana from a day
ago where Fabby said objectively I
should be fine I'm sure the engines
don't see a problem but Magnus gets in
his comfort zone and that's where
players get scared you look at this
position right now it's a symetrical
Pawn structure there's one open file and
only the white Rook sits on E1 looking
down the entire line and for black that
KN on G6 not going anywhere White's not
scared on the other hand might white
might thrust his a pawn forward he just
went to A4 perhaps he'll go one square
further to kick the bishop out of B6
then give himself the C5 Square for his
Knight and look at that juicy hole in
the black position on E6 the B7 Pawn's
also a little bit tender thankfully the
Knight on D6 is covering it but this is
getting a little worrisome for Wesley
even though the engine says that he's
AOK yeah it is symmetrical it is uh one
square that you have to keep an eye on
but ultimately Wesley should be fine
here he could for example Sid step but
it's certainly much uh kind of easier to
play with white it's uh easier to find
plans for example and Magnus Carson I'm
expecting him to push this Pawn forward
um just one thing that he loves to do he
loves to take risk out of the position
he looks so calm so cool collected this
whole tournament and he's just basically
playing risk fre chess and probing away
that's how he beat Fabiano uh eventually
that's how he beat Hikaru yesterday in
the Armageddon and I was about to say
one thing up his alley is to push his
Rooks pawns he pushed A4 last move now
he pushes his Pawn to H4 and uh it's all
about these pieces which are actually uh
severely misplaced he is going for those
pieces he's gaining space in the process
and just a slightly annoying move for
Wesley to have to deal with I love the
decision because Magnus is illustrating
for all of us full board awareness play
on both sides don't get overly
concentrated Tunnel Vision on one flank
that move A4 to A5 maybe the R is
stronger than the execution he can throw
that in later he can also push that pawn
up to H5 in the near future and as long
as he keeps control of this open E file
which he has a rook on now Wesley put
one there as well I think that Magnus
has a slight pull but Wesley we know how
good he is at defense look at Magnus on
the camera there is he napping what's
happening there but he has a healthy
position and Wesley with head in hands
but it don't to feels as if black does
have a solid position uh no apparent
weaknesses the fight on the e file we
can visualize the piece is getting
traded off here and I see Magnus pushing
the a pawn pushing the H Pawn but I have
to say I black should be fine in these
positions as well you've got your Bishop
falling back to C7 you've got the trades
on the E Line the Knight on D6 is a nice
little square eyeing the E4 and the C4
Outpost uh and it just feels like the
kind of position that will most probably
fizzle out into a draw to me yeah
especially knowing that it's Wesley so
sitting behind the black pieces Rock
Solid he's got got what he wants
symmetry almost but these moves they are
slightly frustrating uh Pawn to H5 now
the Black Knight is forced back a choice
of three different squares nothing too
comfortable next move the white Bishop
might come out with Tempo attacking the
Black Knight on D6 which is undefended
everything starting to kind of pick up
uh momentum for white I mean it's yeah
should be level objectively but it's
Magnus having all the fun and the body
language there is uh quite telling right
now Magnus is feeling comfortable with
the opening outcome and and though
without weakness there is a little
pressure on a Wesley's position Wesley
in his interview yesterday it just felt
like I mean of course there's a lot of
respect for Magnus but he just felt like
too much respect for Magnus and he
mentioned that it's going to be about
whether the best version of Magnus gson
shows up today or not does Magnus end up
living rentree in his opponent's heads
all the time well there's definitely
some difference from Wesley so and while
you could say it's respectful it may be
a little over the top and I think when
you give Magnus that psychological Edge
he doesn't let go of it but Wesley has
been known to be a little bit of a troll
play some tricks we've seen him on
social media recently I saw those cat
photos they look very cute Wesley but I
think that Wesley sometimes he maybe
acts a little bit less confident than he
really is and we know when Wesley is at
his best he can beat Magnus Carlson
flashback 2019 Fisher random World
Championship who became the world
champion there it wasn't Magnus Carlson
Wesley so took him down and it was
one-sided at that so the bishop did come
out like David suggested the Knight on
D6 is loose and I think that Magnus he
can poke and PR with either pawn and
he's just biting his time yeah the 2019
Fisher random World Championship Wesley
was just all over Magnus outplaying him
all types of positions left right and
Center uh Wesley as well in the first
season of the Champions chess tour two
years ago beat Magnus in two consecutive
finals he's capable he knows he's
capable and uh I think if he survives
this game with black he'll gain so much
more in confidence um but in the
meantime he does have a threat to deal
with Black's Knight is hit it most
likely will move uh it could be defended
as well by Black's Bishop but then
magnus's Rook will slide to the center
the a the H pawns are going to play a
bit of tickle um this is very
reminiscent of alpha zero um these
neural network engines they love pushing
Rooks pawns forward it's always
mysterious but longterm it seems to pay
off somehow so this is Magnus channeling
his inner AI
monster it's Alpha zero and Alpha Magnus
at player right now Bishop f4 on the
board decisions for Wesley does he
Retreat or does he defend it with his
own Bishop falling back meanwhile that H
Pawn that has gone up the board is also
under attack so that's going to be
something that Magnus will have to deal
with is that Magus with a smile what
just happened there a smile or a Grimace
or something I mean he's got a threat so
he should be pretty happy but uh it
doesn't look like he's kind of as Zen as
he was yesterday well his hair is
getting in his eyes I mean he keeps
pushing his hair back but he's also
forcing Wesley to make a decision he
pushed that Knight back to f8 will this
Knight hop forward or will it also
Venture into a more defensive territory
now the thing I like about White's
position overall is that it feels like
the white Knights have a great future
that this Knight on B3 we've already
talked about how he'll go into the C5
square and for Wesley I think right now
he determined to play Knight C4 as you
highlighted Dave that goes after the B2
Pawn but that Rook goes to E1 and things
start to get a little bit complicated
here uh maybe I guess Rook E1 was too
soon perhaps you throw in a move like A5
first but the point is that you that e
file control will be whes for the take
because a queen loses St down with a
rook yeah actually this is a bit
annoying you mentioned this A5 move
Robert this is nice uh to include
because Black's Bishop forced back the
only safe Square now is a bit of a
passive one and now the white Rook can
slide in the White Knight maybe jumps in
as well and at some point you do get the
opportunity potentially to evict this
night this one requires some calculation
because there are some captures some
direct forcing moves uh for the first
real time in this game um so this is why
Wesley sensing a critical moment has
paused uh he can of course go passive go
defensive uh with a the move maybe one
that I would play Just KN back um just
to keep things solid but yeah he has a
bunch of options so we'll check back in
a moment
later we will keep an eye out on
Wesley's decision meanwhile two players
who have to make big decisions uh as
they have everything to prove Maxim V
lra against Ali razza fuja both of them
in the tournament situation um uh quite
desperate for a win they're currently on
one point they play against each other
so a crucial crucial match here and it
is an end game uh I'm doing the math
here the material is equal but I do like
White's position you see the bishop bear
an open position a potential lining up
of the Rooks on the B line once the king
moves to D2 the other Rook doubles up on
the B file yes I see the doubled pawns
on the sea line but it feels like the
black weakness on B7 is more vulnerable
and easier to attack can I just say Viv
France because these are the two top
French players and this started from the
French defense so they are playing to
their flag's true colors and in this
position it looks very good for maxim
Vash grav he just slid his Bishop back
to G1 that Bishop still it eyes across
the board protecting that what could
otherwise be a vulnerable Pawn he moved
that Bishop out of the rook's site which
means that Rook stares down a semi-open
file and that Knight on A4 it's a pesky
piece that black knight there it is
attacking that white Pawn but it's also
almost tra so you have to be very very
careful if your Oliva fua not to lose
the piece on that side of the board and
T as you said the pair it looks very
nice for white it's your favorite
opening Robert the French defense and I
just want to go back and show Black's
biggest mistake so far of the game it
was here on move one after white plays
E4 black did play Pawn to E6 which is
the French defense I'm joking of course
it's a great opening I've played it
myself but uh it does have uh loyal
followers but also players who aren't
such big fans because it does allow
after the moves we saw in the game for
white to build a big Pawn Center black
is somewhat cramped here and we see
white SE in the space advantage in the
center and um this is the French defense
this is a very recognizable Pawn
structure and if we do catch up with the
game yes the center's exploded but black
is still left with backward pawns no
control over the darkart squares and
Tanya I'm loving your plan uh if white
gets time out king to D2 followed by
Rook over to B1 weakness on B7 massive
problem for black I just don't see any
activity um you just have so many weak
holes this is a nice Outpost for later
you don't want to trade Knights but if
you can land a KN in there and keep it
safe what does do in the meantime fuja I
think not enjoying his position it's not
up his alley this type of passive end
game the reason you say that is because
both these players love the initiative
love to be the one on the dynamic side
and it's clear here that White's the one
who's got all the combative chances
without that E5 Central break available
to Black the light Squad Bishop also
having such limited activity this one's
going to be an uphill task for Ali Resa
uh to try to secure that half point
right now Maxim V gra in driver seat and
again a reminder that both these players
this is such a crucial Point currently
they're at the bottom of the table
they've just got one point each so
desperate for a win and coming into this
match Ka did catch up with Maxim vasher
lra and Ali RAR fuja to find out how
they're feeling about their chances
today yeah hey Tanya first of all so
good to see you guys loving your
commentary from Oslo and I I just wanted
to come in and give you guys a little
bit of gossip from Toronto so yesterday
you mentioned it Tanya these two they
lost both their matched just had a
horrible day they're stuck on one point
they are fighting for their life to not
be knocked out after the round robin and
who do I see when I go to the local
Mexican restaurant it is these two the
two Frenchmen they were having dinner
together they were enjoying their tacos
just talking to each other having a good
time so I went over to them and asked
them like why are you guys having dinner
together tonight before that crucial
matchup that you guys have against each
other and they reveal that they were not
talking about Chess at all they were
talking about tacos they were talking
about everything else just trying to get
into a good mood and I can also reveal
Maxim vajra he doesn't like cheese
imagine that a Frenchman that does not
like cheese that's just crazy to me
haven't heard of uh that one before uh
but Ka that's so cool that these two are
facing each other and what could be the
game of the round robin stage for both
of them and enjoying each other's
company we did speak to Maxim ear before
the tournament started and we asked him
about how it is uh his own personal
rivalry with the French number one now
Aliva fuja and he only had good things
to say they're good friends and uh it's
awesome to see that they're feeling good
there what about when they were coming
into the game today Kaaya how was that
did they did were they walking in
together or could you feel that now the
Friendship has been forgotten and it's
all about fors over the
board they actually yeah they didn't
arrive together actually that's another
fun thing here Tanya because most of the
players are staying in the same hotel as
the venue and arriving the venue most of
them will take the elevator and I was
thinking about that imagine if you sort
of are in the elevator together with the
player that you are facing next like the
awkward small talk that will be in that
elevator what are you talking about are
you talking about the weather are you
talking about Chess that would just be
so awkward to
me all right well thanks I we keep
checking in with you and keep us updated
with all the action in the drama coming
in from Sera as uh James KY put it and
right now there is drama happening on
this board as well as we know that both
players are looking for a decisive
result in their favor and right now A a
dramatic decision a committed decision
pawn moves the moves that can't be taken
back and there are consequences to it in
this case has he lost the pawn he's
trying to trade it for the C5 Pawn but
it just seems like white has has the
advantage and Maxim knows it look at how
quickly he's playing he's not doing that
just to put Ali RZ in time trouble who
he is down to near three and a half
minutes he just knows how good his
position is Black's pawns are very
fragile it looks like a great chance for
maxim V gra to take game
one all right well Maxim in driver's
seat looking good after this opening and
we will check in with this later on if
Ali RZA can keep his chances alive uh
let's move on to Fabiano Karana who
started with a great day one he won both
his matches and then yesterday again a
back-to-back loss for him uh definitely
looking to get back into Spirits here
he's playing against Dennis lazovic
perhaps a pairing that is what exactly
he needed in this tournament situation
yeah it feels like he needs to win this
match of course but he needs to win this
game Fabiano because Dennis lazovic is
unbeaten so far in this event with white
Dennis is a bit vulnerable with black
he's taken a few hits there and Fabiano
just judging by this position it's still
very kg of course roughly level but
maybe slightly preferable for him um
it's the clock times as well he's a few
minutes up there he needs to pounce here
and now if this game is a draw I do fear
for Fabiano's chances momentum of the
tournament will really have switched and
okay he opens up the center uh very
logical move it's a slightly odd Pawn
structure here Robert yeah it's not
something we typically see but I have to
really agree with you David that white
is better here because the side that
controls the pawn breaks is off the side
with the advantage and here Fabiano he
made his first Pawn break he now has
these two healthy Pawns in the center he
can aim at that A5 Pawn as well his
Bishop on D2 is nicely placed aiming
towards that black Rook Pawn on A5 so
this could be something that Dennis has
to keep an eye on the Knight on F3 that
could be a hoppy piece it could jump
forward into the position and already
you know that Dennis he's looking do I
have to play in the center as well is
Faby going to push those pawns it's
unclear who's pushing what yeah really
unclear and uh one thing I will mention
especially in Blitz and Rapid chess this
PA structure for white it might look
like you've got doubled pawns it might
look like okay black has the majority on
the other side of the board but this is
the dream uh I will call it a castle a
palace a mansion for this white king
look at the white king it's going to be
safe forever for black it's going to be
uh maybe some questions to answer long
term for the king uh in the meantime
though Fabiano he's just solidifying his
Pawn Center this is glorious right now
and it's really unclear what Dennis
should be doing no clear plan while
white meanwhile can start improving
maybe you start improving the Queen just
to support these pawns at the right
moment decide which one to push and uh
just because you do have three you might
even push those pawns a bit later on uh
maybe especially the hbor learning from
Magnus in his game uh so roughly level
but uh Fabiano perhaps enjoying life
slightly more right
now for danis lovic he's also got to
keep an eye out on the clock when things
get chaotic on the board the one advice
that can be given is you got to listen
to some Ali music there uh and we' got a
surprise for all of you as uh we are
giving away a chess comom signed of
vinyl the LOI playlist and it's all the
great music that you've been listening
to at the start of the stream at the end
of the stream and it's a great playlist
to actually play some chess on so do you
think during breaks the players have
also been listening to some of the LOI
uh tracks it's funny because I've talked
to some of the players and I myself
listen to Loi well before this
partnership happened so everyone was
like oh that's a cool partnership
because I'm already listening I'm coming
myself down I'm just maybe studying
chess with a little bit of that music
but I think these players they're fully
focused on the task at hand because for
Fabby bad day yesterday for Dennis now
he's got his chance oh wow all right
well this is your chance to get your
hands on some great music that we've
been hearing on the stream as well and
some great music to play some chess too
when you're back home so check out the
chess comom Loi girl track and we're
going to check into this position a bit
more as I see fabby's Queen has jumped
all the way to B5 eyeing that A5 Pawn so
really locking in the Black Knight and
the bishop to defend it which creates
all these threats of the D Pawn moving
forward to get rid of one of the
Defenders and it's been stopped yeah
it's been stopped and I think Dennis
needed to play a move such as this one
as you said Tanya the last thing you
want to do especially now with only
three minutes on the clock is to
calculate all of White's Pawn pushes E5
D5 attacking stuff you don't want to be
reacting you don't want to have that on
your mind so fixing the structure at
least takes a burden off uh at least
then you know exactly how to place your
pieces and he's also doing a good job of
trying to hem in White's dark Square
Bishop White's Bishop does a good job of
pointing at the A5 Pawn but it might be
stuck behind its own Central pawns and
uh I like what Dennis is doing I just
think he needs to speed up and Fabby
needs to keep the tension as long as
possible and uh try to maybe uh change
the pace of the game a bit later I don't
think he should be fixing it right now
Fabiano I think maybe just oh as I say
it commentator's curse of course he
fixes the center maybe he could have
just defended that pawn with one of his
Rooks uh but now we I mean it looks like
a French defense Robert but your point
from earlier definitely Rings true that
white has the double G pawns that
typically sounds bad in end games but in
a position like this maybe those ponel
are pushing up the board trying to crack
open the black king and Dennis while he
moves his Queen back at some moment I am
looking at G4 G5 ideas and I just don't
see an easy plan for black and that
doesn't mean that black is worse but
what is the actual next few moves going
to be because that well I was say A5
Pawn is loose now it's not but that
Queen is about to venture on over to the
king side if that Queen lands on G6 not
anymore it could have been Danger
all right this looks like Fabiano Karana
has got a lot of positional Advantage
he's got the space going he's up on the
clock so Dennis lazic going to be an
uphill task for him uh let's move on to
uh two other players for whom also today
this match itself is so important and
especially the one playing with the
black pieces who's currently at just one
match Victory Hikaru Nakamura he got a
bit of an early gift in this one as nbec
Abdus satro blunder back on move 7th but
just looking at what we have in front of
us right now that white Pawn all the way
to F6 all of Black's pieces on the other
side of the board a lonely lonely black
king it looks like nbec has managed to
Mud The Waters he's done a great job
ever since that early opening blunder uh
Abdus Abdus satoro that being said there
are threats against the white king too
there was uh the hint of an idea of Rook
takes Knight Black's Rook taking on C3
breaking open the white uh structure in
front of the white king uh so he defends
against that I think a very good
practical move but like you say Tanya
longterm as well not even just right now
that black king is feeling uncomfortable
there's always ideas of throwing in a
knight towards it uh back rank
checkmates Galore it's really really
tense right now and I think Nakamura
still perhaps favorite but he won't be
happy by the fact that he's lost some
control and pawn to
B5 feels a bit loose for black somehow
he is making his intentions very clear
he is trying to break down White's
defensive resources in front of his own
King whe whether that works is a
different story but you see the Rooks
are lined up the queen and now this Pawn
if that pawn pushes one square further
suddenly white is going to have to
concede something and that would either
open the a file or the C file so that is
a very smart move for all you watching
at home when your king is Castle Queen
side you want to get further away from
the middle of the board so he hides his
King on B1 that protects the a file it
means that anything on the cile won't
happen with Czech really smart move
there from nybeck who looks confident
honestly I kind of like his position
because that black king is not getting
out of any of these checkm nets and
that's going to be a long-term pressure
against it yes but black has a direct
idea right now that last move clearly
hinted on B4 whether you sidestep your
king from the C file or not and my
question is that how are you reacting to
that because if you trade on B4 you open
an additional attacking file for what
for black the B Line opens up and this
looks like Black's going to be the one
first to the race to the king so after
B4 is nck planning to just simp simply
step away with the Knight give up the C2
Pawn but in exchange pick up the B4 pawn
it looks like that must be his plan
Tanya and I just want to point out if
black doesn't go for this there might be
a threat in the position uh it's a very
typical idea for example if black plays
a move like H5 white might be able to
throw the Knight out the way and this
tension of with the Queens because
Black's Queen is undefended means after
a queen trade uh White can actually have
time now due to the fact that King's
nicely tucked away on B1 to Flo uh to
throw in a zishan Zug uh an in between
move it's a check as well and it's a
family Fork once the king moves you take
back the queen and you win material so I
think Tanya your move is almost
guaranteed to happen hikaro just
checking the details here as the clock
levels out but B4 maybe the idea of
Knight to A2 this is what he's
calculating right now okay he goes away
from this Hikaru because this line you
mentioned actually white is doing okay
uh just due to the fact that the D Pawn
is vulnerable the a pawn might be
vulnerable uh Hikaru sidesteps this idea
the tension too much with the queens and
he's hinting at B4 a bit later maybe uh
perhaps even prefaced by A5 first porn
storm incoming nbec has to be quick as
well but very good decision there from
marara because a queen trade I think
that trajectory of the game is in
White's favor now not Beck he's
combining defense with offense watch out
Rook takes Knight is actually a big
threat because the White Knight Will
leap into the center and then deliver a
check with a fork of multiple pieces so
this is something that hiar can not
afford to allow he also might just get
checkmated with that Knight landing on
E7 so hikaro understands why ner r
played his move maybe he'll sacrifice
his own Rook for White's Knight but that
back rank is a long-term issue for
hikaro so even if he takes this Knight
away from the the board here it doesn't
solve all his problems at all yeah
actually I think it's easier to play for
white this position if anything any of
course three result game but uh chaos
now on this board W what a turnaround
from what how this whole thing started
on move seven nck making a big blunder
but the guy just never never gives up
and he's managed to create his own
chances and meanwhile The Bard between
uh these two who have just been
Unstoppable and I mean I'm trying to
take all of this in the first thing I
see is there's an H Pawn that's missing
Magnus Carlson I'm doing the math really
quickly he's down upon Pawn but he's got
a pawn all the way on A6 how are we
evaluating this crazy crazy Rook bwn end
game I always say instead of just
focusing on the quantity look at the
Quality white has the single best Pawn
on the board that pawn on A6 so that
Rook could have captured black Central
Pawn he says I don't want it what is
trying to do is freeze Black's pieces
that Rook has to stay on the a file for
black and has limited space just one
square in front of it the white Rook is
a bit more active but what Wesley is
counting on now that he's protected his
Pawn that was under attack he's saying
you can't actually make any progress
here there's no infiltration with the
Rook because if you take one of my pawns
then you lose sight of that pass Pawn on
A7 yeah luckily for Wesley he has so
many pawns with black that he can start
pushing them Black's Rook of course
immobilized the black king stuck right
now but uh which Pawn do you push this
is the big question you can never allow
the white king in uh if the white king
ever gets into the position essentially
white is going to win white has an
active Rook black has a passive one but
yeah these points are going to act as a
distraction uh really anyone's game
still uh very hard to evaluate this end
game upon is upon is upon right I agree
with you black drooks stuck on it but
the majority on the king side and David
the plan that you were hinting at start
advancing those G pawns get that H Pawn
rolling and create your own passer I
would expect this to mean that white
would end up picking up one of the pawns
on the right side of the board
eventually Wesley picks up the A7 pawn
and we will perhaps have the draw that
uh seemed like the outly the outcome
that we were expecting out of the
opening yeah a draw is still the
favorite just because I don't think
either side uh has any clear-cut plan of
breaking through but uh yeah it feels
like Magnus may be able to test his
opponent somehow if Wesley pushes at the
wrong time really instructive move here
Robert I really like that move from
Magnus because what he's showing to
Wesley is that there may C4 check on the
agenda I may give up that pawn at the
right moment to win some of the other
pawns but Wesley's also doing the right
thing he's trying to create a pass Pawn
as quickly as possible because he cannot
sit and do nothing he needs to distract
the white forces before mag Magus can
execute his play with they say Rook to
A6 hitting that B6 pawn and maybe
throwing in C4 so I do like what Wes is
doing he's holding on yeah both players
just playing extremely well it feels
like a really high quality probably
quite a high accuracy game as well uh
this one uh Magnus down to 1 minute it
feels like he's looking for winning
chances that might not exist I'm
expecting him just to move his Rook up
the board I'm not sure exactly where
maybe Rook to A6 but ultimately
eventually all the pawns should start
disappearing and black Rook will finally
uh kind of get out of paity I don't know
what magnus's next move is but I think
Wesley's next move is going to be the G
Pawn moving one step forward the H Pawn
moving one step forward and it just
feels like it's also very easy to be
black here uh visually a lot of pressure
with white having a Pawn on the seventh
rank uh but black got enough resources
to distract and neutralize that pressure
and meanwhile we see the evalar is going
crazy on some of the other boards yeah
kowana now has a winning position
against lazovic we loved his position
earlier and uh he has uh maneuvered that
one quite nicely I think he's changed
his advantage and he's now material up
abdusattorov in charge against Nakamura
but that one still tense this Rook end
game however um I think we're racing
down those variations we mentioned now
the white king at some point is likely
to want to go towards those black pawns
before it's too late but uh once the
white king moves away white will lose a
bit of control over the center he does
go for this idea you mentioned Robert
yeah he's trying to give up a pawn to
get a pawn but it looks like this one
Still Remains even I'm just I'm
captivated by what's happening in the
other games I see the eval bar swinging
back and forth while this one remains
level on The Rook end game absolutely
Robert and uh I think we have to move
over to uh nck versus Hikaru Nakamura
both players playing under 30 seconds
there's a white B on G7 which is acting
like a shield to Black's King this is a
crazy crazy position and a Time scramble
I'm expecting a decisive result who's
closer to a victory here I would take
white just because you're material up
and the black king not entirely safe but
look black does have counterplay this is
far from oneway traffic Nakamura his
Knight is actually just as strong as
some of the white Rooks uh as any of the
white Rooks it holds everything together
and this ewn was marching very very
quickly sprinting down the board and
that A6 Pawn that probably was
meaningless because you can't bring your
queen back into the game by taking the
pawn next to it because then you'll face
a pin so he goes Queen B6 not taking the
pawn he's desperately trying to get his
Queen back but look at Hikaru he's
keeping pace and now not down to his
final seconds he might lose on time oh
one second he made that move with and it
was a mistake now Black's just coming in
Black's Queen can take a Pawn on C3
black can push a pawn to E2 Black's
Knight is coming to F4 everything
Nakamura he's too quick Andor again he
made that move with one second left look
at that white Rook suddenly on H2 it's
loose it's going to drop off NAA class
is shining through here is not a be
about to get flagged point2 E2 is
winning just push the pawn Hikaru knows
it he has plenty of time to execute it
and there it is winning position forar
Nakamura with the black pieces and he
looks away and it's handshakes and nck
resigns hiar Nakamura gets the much much
needed win to start off his day what a
game this was and that is a face of
relief right
there yeah and let's jump straight into
another game that's still ongoing we
mentioned Fabiano is winning this
position he's currently up two pawns
with white but still some work to be
done and uh first that white Bishop was
hit the white Pawn in the center on D4
was also hit nice controlling move there
from Fabiano he should be able to bank
this one now control pass Pawn in the
center two extra pawns here so he is
just making sure that all of his pieces
are in defended squares and proving them
and Black's pawns are all loose so he's
going to pick them off yeah this is a
really classy maneuver the Knight drops
back to F4 talking of loose Pawns that
black D5 Pawn is doomed now simply no
way to hold it together Dennis lavic
desperately trying to trade off pieces
if the white Bishop disappears if it
gets traded off maybe white Pawn's
vulnerable too but Fabiano spoiled for
Choice he does indeed trade Bishops and
now maybe just a pin there we go the
white Rook slides across Black's pieces
are stuck no hope anymore this one's
almost over about to be up three Pawn is
Fabby he takes it and that Knight
remains pinned any sort of trade will be
lost so he does resign so Fabiano Carana
takes game one of his match a much
needed victory for a player who lost
both of his matches a day ago fanis laik
he has to win their second battle to
take it into Armageddon uh Fabby takes
the first game and we've still got
action on between Magnus Carlson and
Wesley so as well as Maxim V lra and Ali
RZA fighting out their games for Dennis
so much about getting that experience in
but he needs to strike in the next one
let's head over to Maxim with the white
pieces also an end game an extra Pawn
for the Frenchmen but it doesn't matter
if I say Frenchmen because both of them
are so for maxim that is an extra Pawn
with the white pieces and they're
connected that gives him some serious
winning chances yeah rook and Bishop
tend to work really well against rook
and Knight when the board is this open
and yeah the fact that both of your pass
pawns are connected means that this
should be quite Elementary but White's
Bishop was pinned temporarily uh so some
counterplay black going behind with some
checks now I've seen Maxi Vash win so
many these types of positions it's hard
to imagine him letting it slip blacks
rook and Knight simply don't combine and
fuja nearly blundered his Rook there he
nearly put the white the black Rook on
F1 where the white Bishop could have
taken it but indecision and it will cost
him White's King now advancing wh's
porn's advancing he even just removes
Black's final hope and uh okay two pawns
clear two pawns up this one is in its
final stages and Black's only hope is to
keep that Knight on the board don't
trade it off you're trying to get some
tricks in you're trying to get those
checks in and Al Al are now relying
purely on tricks to save this one he's
yeah he's doing well he's fighting yeah
and he knows that he needs to sacrifice
his Knight for both of the pawns if he
can do that we get into a theoretically
drawn position of rook and Bishop versus
Rook however those two pawns are not
going to be sacrificed for that Knight
there's no way that Maxim will allow
that instead he chases the Knight and
only after putting Black's pieces on
uncomfortable squares will he start
pushing his pawns yeah just incredible
calculation actually here from Maxi Vash
gra because he's actually up one of his
pawns if the Black Knight had gone back
to E6 White's king would have advanced
and the tactics were working in White's
favor he's still in control look at the
clock times fuja just barely making
moves uh within the a lotted time there
and white king is being forced back it's
still far from over yes but the dream
here for whiters to start pushing the F
Pawn he needs to first get the bishop
out of the way and now the bishop
actually controls Black's knight uh the
knight from f8 moves anywhere that would
mean a winning Rook Pawn end game I like
that square on F5 for the bishop but it
also makes makes it difficult to push
the pawns forward now yeah it's just
about when to push maybe first he'll
give a check there we go drive the black
king away and that night you mentioned
it t it's trapped No Way Out o and
that's it alira fuja resigns Maxim VRA
with the white pieces takes the win this
match is so important for these two
Frenchmen uh and this one with the
tournament leaders fighting it out and
that's Magnus with an extra Pawn
theoretically this should be a draw and
look at the defense that Wesley so just
demonstrated the game is over it's a
draw that is stalemate on the board
Wesley so he wipes that beat of sweat
off of his head and he goes I survived
next game on and Magnus there shaking
his head Magnus is doing everything he
could with the white pieces getting that
slight pull out of the opening pushing
for maximum but Wesley so showing why he
has the reputation that he does of being
the hardest player to
beat Fair results in the end but Magnus
again testing his opponent pushing his
opponents to the Limit and getting close
uh beautiful stalemate tactic there to
hold to draw the game for Wesley and uh
these two they've been I think the most
impressive warriors uh the most
impressive fighters of the event so far
and let's take a look at the results
after game one of round five Magnus
Wesley finished with the draw Hikaru
nagamura then St battle takes down nbec
Abdu satro Maxim Vash lra Victorious
against al fuja Dennis lavic goes down
to Fabiano karwana lazovic the underdog
in that match but we all remember their
battle in the Julius bear generation cup
where Fabby really had to work hard to
get that win so of course comebacks are
still possible quite a decisive round
there David what stood out to you yeah a
really decisive round there with three
decided games and we're spoiled for
choice in terms of highlights but I want
to pick out maybe the move of the round
and it was in that French derby that
French clash between maxi Vash lra and
Alara fua we mentioned earlier in the
game that white had a long-term
advantage and here he cashed it in he
turned it into something bigger there's
pressure against the E6 Pawn but first
he tricked his opponent he slid his Rook
across trying to put some pressure on
this Black Knight and when it moved it
retreated this tactic is just beautiful
and decisive Rook takes E6 overwhelming
uh the black defenses simply these two
black Rooks can do nothing this bishop
is suddenly Unleashed if you take this
Rook you're landed in nasty pin and uh
White would shortly win material instead
he had to take the other Rook fuja but
after a simple capture he found himself
a couple of Pawns up and he went on to
convert this in nice style Maxim
VRA awesome and game technique there by
Maxim and we've got some awesome news
for you guys an awesome way to celebrate
and decorate your homes in the holiday
season and check this out these light WI
great metal displates you can put them
up on your wall they're easy to hang
they look so cool I love the duck chess
one Robert's got his own favorite uh
displayed right here it's Bob the monkey
Robert yeah Bob loves bananas so I mean
why not get your favorite displayed I
took one from here no one caught me so
I'm going to keep it Tak it home with me
and hope you all get yours the ones you
enjoy and the best part there's a 33%
discount right now so go get your
favorite display and Ruma has it David
that there's a special grind like a
grandmas one as well yeah there's one
for my book as well my chessable of
course I'm definitely mounting that up
on my wall I must admit they are really
slick really nice and uh yeah great
investment I think check them out and uh
right now we are going to be going into
a break just before these two take it on
in their game too there is a lot of
Chess coming in from Toronto and
subscribers stay with us because we've
also got some cool behind the scenes
just for
[Music]
you so next one what's your take on
hikaro Nakamura I really like his
fighting spirit and he's really great
player and we have this rivalry that we
play since 10 years since I am since I
remember I started playing CH I think he
his biggest strength is his defense def
ensive skills sometimes looking like
number two in the world sometimes even
you know looking just as good as as
Magnus but I think he just a little bit
faster than me so that makes him a very
annoying opponent for me to play yeah he
managed to beat Magnus car in his P
Championship last season so one of the
best players of all time I think I don't
think he's done like amazing this season
still one of the one of the main
contenders
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
n
this is the 1hour chess lesson you could
take to make sure that you have all the
starting tips strategies and basic
understanding to really be
ready by owning the defile white can do
anything that he or she
wants if you don't understand what to do
here you might move the queen to safety
on C6 and immediately lose the first
lady to Bishop to
B5 King on the six Pawn on the 5th is a
winning King and pawn ending where no
matter what black does we are going to
be able to bring a new Queen to the
[Music]
[Applause]
board you can also skip the parts that
maybe you already know how to move the
pieces or the language uh and jump in at
a level that's appropriate to
[Applause]
[Music]
you
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
we're really celebrating KingSize this
finals as we've got a big big merch to
open and we've got gifts really cool
ones for all your loved ones we got a
really uh fun plushy right there mittens
plush
but the ogs know that mittens is
anything but cute can be extremely BR
brutal but this holiday season pick your
favorite favorite gifts from our mud
store on chess.com
sshop and uh we are going back to
Toronto our playing Arena where all the
hot chess action is coming up and we've
got Kaa with Hikaru after his first game
win I am here with thear Nakamura wow
that was an intense finish to that game
take go through uh the ending there
Hikaru yeah I mean this is pretty much
uh symbolizes the entire event for me um
you know not Notre backck tried to play
a unusual opening and I think he just
blundered when he played this bishop D3
move but then after Knight G4 Bishop E3
I I spent a lot of time calculating and
I took with the wrong piece um and I
think it was still still maybe slightly
better for me nothing special but Notre
Beck decided to go all in by sacrificing
the pawn in the center and pushing
everything on the King side um I think
if I have half an hour I probably should
win this very cleanly but it it got very
complicated very messy um I mean I think
for me really the the difference was
that towards the end once um once Notre
backck took this Pawn G7 I sacked Rook
all my moves were easier than his moves
were even if objectively I think he was
probably fine but because all the moves
were easy and we're low on time um he
got too low he couldn't couldn't sort of
deal with all the threats and and I won
the game so it's nice to win but as with
pretty much every other match I'm not
very happy with the quality of my play
all right so when you're not happy with
the quality of the play what does it
mean to win those games uh which is
crucial here in only uh two game matches
well I think the main thing is it's very
clear that when I'm getting in these
time scrambles or low on time in general
I'm completely panicking um maybe the
match against Magnus a little bit
different but certainly against mvl in
the Armageddon game I it was just insane
what I did um Wesley same kind of thing
um even oi Reza actually yesterday when
we started getting low I allowed this
Rook up four and got into a lot of
trouble so I mean the thing is it's nice
to win uh but knowing exactly what I'm
doing wrong I mean I try to focus on
that I think at least in this game when
I when I was able to just sack the rook
and just play like play for for tactical
plans um is sort of in the style of what
you need in Rapid and Blitz so I'll try
to do more of the same where I have
easier moves than my opponent when we
get low on time you say panicking what
does panicking mean what what is
happening on the inside when you are
panicking there well I mean I haven't
played over the board uh Rapid or Blitz
pretty much since Norwich has which was
about six six and a half months ago um
so the thing is I'm just not used to not
having a lot of time on the clock and
when you play classical you have a lot
of time to think on every single move um
but I think the main thing is like the
reason that I know that I'm not playing
well is because uh the time management
generally it's a byproduct of either
over calculating or missing a lot of
your opponent's moves and I think for me
I'm missing a lot of the moves that my
opponents are coming up with um like in
this last game I missed rookie 3 I
missed rookie4 and so I'm getting low on
time and then you're just like what are
you doing as it as as the clock sticking
down and it's more like just not even
calculating but I mean at least I kept
my wits together so just yeah have to
find a way to uh I guess play play
better chess and and honestly just to
sort of uh calculate better and just to
analyze better moves because I think my
opponents are finding better moves than
I'm seeing which is is never a good sign
well so with your experience do you have
any tricks how will you sort of fix what
you're not happy about with your play
well I mean the only good thing here is
the top six top six make it through um
instead of the top four so I mean I
still have a chance I guess to play well
I think a lot of tournaments that I've
played normally I start off quite slowly
and then I get better as they go along
so keeping that in mind you're just
trying to remain optimistic and know
that if I win this match I mean I I
should qualify it's uh it's important so
just doing my best so game two here will
it just be about being solid then I mean
if I can if I can play a good game of
chess I'll be happy because I don't
think I've played a complete game of
chess in this event yet so if I can play
a complete game I'll be happy good luck
Kar thanks for your thoughts here he car
nakam getting ready for game
two and insight into the mind of a
genius there how cool is it that these
guys they're just like really speaking
what they're feeling I mean I always
felt that earlier chess players would be
so guarded in their interviews not
giving us really the true picture but
iaru there he just summarized his whole
thought process you know brilliant where
yeah well don't call it a comeback he's
been doing it for years I me he's
streaming he's always letting you know
his thoughts but I felt like he was
actually revealing his inner thoughts in
this case because he's admitting that he
panics he's admitting that he's missing
his opponent's moves and that Insight is
something that we historically have not
received from these top players and I
think he is a bit nervous he should be
right he's had one win he knows he's not
been in his best shape so far he got the
much needed win David in game one but
that was thanks to an early blunder by
nbak yeah that being said it did get
messy and he navigated things better
when the clock ticked down Hikaru was
back in the flow I mean that's a real
skill it's not just chess it's any sport
it's learning or figuring out how to win
when you're not at your best sometimes
you have to kind of knuckle down really
dig deep and uh you have to hustle your
opponent you have to play for the clock
play for tricks and Hikaru he's
combining everything and if he can
survive as he mentioned this kind of
Rocky start of the tournament he'll
start to gain a confidence he'll think
he's unbeatable and uh he'll be back to
his best in no time so he's really
really showing all his resilience and
there's no doubt that the chess wall
will be disappointed to see an early
exit from Hikaru Nakamura in this finals
but he started the day just like like he
wanted to with that win and we also see
behind him uh Maxim VRA and Ali Rea fua
also ready to go for nbec who's yet to
take his place how does he create his
chances with black to try and make a
comeback in this one it's super
difficult because hikara can play
something very solid and he can say I'm
not going to take any risk you're going
to have to pretty much throw all your
pieces at me and often times players
lose like that so for nck I don't know
what to recommend when you have the
black piece against a car and you have
to win but the good news is Abdu satarov
he's the ultimate fighter and another
player in a must-win situation is Alara
fua on the plus side he has the white
pieces uh so he's guaranteed to at least
be able to pick an opening that he feels
will suit the match situation to suit
his style giving a yawn he doesn't he's
not faced he's uh unbothered unded he
can't be feeling too sleepy right now he
needs to be completely alert especially
when he's playing against a player like
Maxim Vash gra sure do have fireworks
there and we've got Fabiano Carana who
took the lead in his match against
Dennis lazovic Fabby needs only a draw
in this one to wrap up this match and
that we've got the world number one
Magnus Carlson the match is even between
these two and we are off it's always
been interesting to me that Wesley takes
his glasses off just at the start of the
game this is something I've noticed over
the years it's like he doesn't need to
see the board because he's got that Beth
Harmon skill
it's all in his mind and we see that it
is uh is that going to be a nimzo Indian
or will we see D5 on the board by Magnus
going into perhaps the Queen's Gambit
decline Magnus pausing he's really
thinking what his opening approach will
be right now look at that expression and
he chooses D5 yeah he uh he just uh
deciding there just kind of what type of
position he wants maybe trying to dodge
any specific uh targeted preparation
there it's the Queen's G declined and
one of the main lines here black
bringing his Bishop out not the exchange
V variation yet Wesley keeping the
tension in the center but very classical
stuff I think that's what Magnus was
really considering should I just allow
Wesley to make a quick draw because when
I think about what the players are going
through how can I win this match for
Wesley he has the white pieces that's
the first move ADV V sure but he
probably feels like the armageddon's
more of a tossup that gives him a better
chance so I will not be surprised if
Wesley when given the opportunity forces
a draw
and uh we'll see magnus's approach he
happily captures a Pawn on C4 so a mix
between the Queen's Gambit declined but
later accepted trading off pawns here
this is known to be Rock Solid for black
and I don't think Magnus is averse to a
draw either here Robert very solid play
for both sides so far and Wesley did win
both his games on day two in the
armagedon if this was to go down to the
wire if this was taken to the armag who
do you think that would favor I always
say it Magnus Carlson is favored
whenever he plays now I'm going to be
curious what bid that he makes cuz I
don't think he'll go the full 15 minutes
once again and Wesley was criticizing
his own bids but we're looking at this
game and if we're giving that honest
Grandmaster takeover here it looks like
they've traded Queens the their body
language is kind of like okay we'll make
this draw let's head to the Armageddon
which is great fun for everybody uh but
for Wesley I think that you know you
have to calculate your odds your
expected value in both this game then
this position and then the Armageddon
Magnus Carlson showed utter dominance uh
on day two when he took down world
number two and world number three two of
his biggest Rivals Fabby and Hikaru how
does Wesley not let that get into his
head David it's hard chess players we
heard it in hikaru's interview they're
all perfectionists sometimes we're
overthinkers and uh yeah it's going to
be tough not to kind of get psyched out
in this type of situation but Wesley has
to uh block out all the noise he has to
just play this position and if he wants
to be ambitious then uh he is
temporarily Pawn up he should try to
defend his extra C Pawn or maybe even
push it Forward throw it away on his own
terms but I think we'll learn a lot
about Wesley's intentions just on this
next move or two all right well so far
it looks like both players would be okay
taking this to to the armagan but one
player who needs to play energetic chest
and create his chances is aliraza fuja
he's currently had one match win this
tournament he is trailing Maxim VRA in
their mini match and my first my gut
feeling looking at the board in front of
us is that he should be very happy with
what he's got out of the opening what on
Earth is that bang night sacrifice but
you cannot take this piece it is
poisoned uh the black king should not be
feeling brave about uh taking that
Knight right now wow what a boss move
forua gets up from the board as well and
Maxim Vash de gra he spent barely any
time up to this point he's either
blundered or he's in deep preparation
and uh fua it looks like he's feeling
extremely confident let's just show this
trick uh on the board Knight takes Pawn
Let's do an action replay taking on E7
here and if the king advances this is a
nasty Royal Fork hitting the king
hitting the queen winning one of them
because Black's Knight is pinned and
cannot recapture I think he gets even
juicier if we keep analyzing instead of
this King takes Knight because that's
clearly that Knight C5 is a counter shot
against the White Queen I'm thr and take
your queen with check and if this queen
slides up to D4 to put more pressure on
this Knight on F6 I think that in this
position you'd be tempted as black play
Knight E6 let me keep chasing your queen
around is there Queen taking F6 here
like I was wondering are this one of
those positions where you sack your
queen and then bring your knight back to
D5 and the engine actually approves
Knight E7 to D5 here hitting the queen
on C7 hitting that Bishop on F6 uh
things are getting really well maybe
Knight C3 I don't know I don't have the
answer I just saw Queen sacrifice is
that simple huh I wanted to do a four I
love it Robert though I mean yes you've
given up a queen but you have a
beautiful Bishop this might be the MVP
the most uh visually appealing piece
right now and uh Knight back to D or one
of the knights as you mentioned into D5
and Black's King is stuck in the center
forever wow this this is beautiful
compensation for white I think fua will
win if he gets to drop this on the board
stunning stunning move by Ala fuja and
while those Knights are nighting it
looks like Maxim allowed this move
Knight takes Pawn David I want us to
just back down a little bit and see how
this actually happened because we're on
move number 11 how did Maxim actually
let all of this uh befall him Knight
takes pawn and suddenly big trouble and
maximan a think so did he miss this
opportunity we're still early in the
game Tanya so maybe we do have the
luxury of time to just backtrack and I
must say not a practical decision very
impractical from Max inas gra first
let's go all the way back to the start
it was a Sicilian Defense it was his pet
line an open Sicilian and the nidol uh
so with A6 but this is a must-win
situation look at this move Queen D3
already a rare one and Maxim playing
some very provocative moves firstly
combining the Sicilian nid off with the
Sicilian Dragon something we call we
mesh together we call the dragod off
this is very risky where he only needs a
draw this feels strange but now Pawn to
B5 allowed this trick the Knight into C6
it's a weak square and uh it looks like
he was bluffing he didn't calculate Maxi
V the gra he allowed this trick to land
and rather than enter that uh I think
Robert your your queen stack idea was
probably just winning in Practical terms
for white instead he's gone Bishop to B7
so accepting that he might be a pawn
down but relying on activity of pieces
wh's E4 Pawn is slightly vulnerable as
well it's wild though that black just
lost a pawn in front of his own King
simply develops the bishop and the
engines kind of like why is barely
better so whether Maxim was shocked or
this was in his preparation it seems
like it wasn't because you would react
much more quickly after a knight takes
Pawn in front of your king but he finds
the best response and how much better is
this for Ali Rea that's the essential
question here I'm a maxim fan and a big
fan especially of his uh opening prep
and ideas but the amount of time that
he's burnt on the the clock I think it's
giving too much credit to imagine that
this would be part of the big plan part
of the prep yeah no I I did state that I
think that it's clear we respond
immediately after Knight takes pawn and
just continue the game but he has missed
it but then he finds the best response
and the eval bar is saying White's not
that much better so how bad is it for
maxim yeah luckily Maxim okay he gets up
he's showing confidence as well uh
luckily for him he is now threatening to
take this white knight um White's Knight
on E7 actually does a great job of
stopping Black's King from castling but
it will get kicked out and maybe it has
to retreat now maybe we have to show uh
the likely outcome of this tactical
sequence and King takes Knight
threatened therefore maybe the most
logical move would be either to retreat
or first to trade off on F6 I'm not sure
which one is better um for example A
variation like this would be very
forcing dropping the White Knight back
now saving it and if everything comes
off everything gets traded at the very
end white is still a pawn up but it is
opposite color Bishops black Dart Square
Bishop on this diagonal very strong
White's King not entirely safe The Rook
is hit in the corner so if it moves
still some questions to answer for white
uh maybe you push a pawn to C3 and you
argue okay I'm a pawn up but a position
like this who knows maybe you've got
enough to hold this one as black White's
King not entirely safe either vulnerable
on the dark squares so uh yeah this is
what I'm expecting it it's funny because
when you overlook a tactic like that and
you get this position like it's kind of
Ideal like I wish I pre this line
because getting to this point with the
opposite color Bishops clearly gives
black some serious chances to hold this
game and so ala he's deep in the think
tank he's the one who Uncorked this
vicious night sacrifice and now it's him
on the clock thinking well what do I do
where do I go from here because Maxim
actually his position doesn't seem so
bad wow so despite losing a key keep on
in this position Maxim Vash lrav is
fighting for compensation against
White's Uncle King and that Central E4
Pawn Al are still has to lose a few
tempos bringing that night back but it
is a dream outcome when you have to win
on on demand to force an Armageddon for
Ali Resa we'll see if he manages to make
the most of this one definitely
something that he was hoping for but we
are going to head over to Hikaru versus
uh nbec as well
another very very critical game for nck
he needs to win to take it to Armageddon
a very different position and I have to
say I think you guys are the profits for
today because when we always set up this
board in front of us on our studio and
we were discussing what openings to
bring on you said let's go for the
London and my feeling is this is coming
out of a D4 early Bishop F4 but the
Knight decides to develop another way
not just that Tanya guess what type of
London this is a shout out to James
kanty it was the Jaa London and uh we'll
go back and show how we got this opening
actually we did predict it we have a
board here in the studio just in front
of me a physical board and we set up
this opening before today but uh this is
the current position we'll break it down
in a moment let's backtrack all the way
to move one we saw Pawn to D4 from
hikara Nakamura and uh first choosing
the London system a pure London with the
bishop coming out to this beautiful
diagonal on F4 but now bring the Knight
out to C3 maybe a testament to our good
friend James out there KY for the win
and the whole idea is there are ideas
bringing uh kind of your knight forward
to B5 and okay the game went on of
course let's catch up with the current
position Bishops have come been traded
off a set of other minor pieces as well
Hikaru does have an ugly kind of
backward weak Pawn here on East but not
easy to attack and because it's so
closed because it's so blocked in the
center actually Black's Knights might
Thrive long term so uh in the balance
for now Robert yeah and for ner Beck who
has the black pieces here he just jumped
his Knight into E4 he's trying to hop
into the center and that pawn structure
is a bit compromised from white but the
position remains so closed Knights they
typically do well in closed positions I
just don't see the life at least not yet
I like his little Rook lift Black's Rook
on F6 maybe that can cause some
distraction some danger towards the
white king and I will not be surprised
if nck goes all in and plays G5 at some
moment going for the attack he said if I
draw this game I lose the match so I
might as well lose the game at least go
down in style yeah I must say he's done
a great job in this opening of just
keeping enough pieces on the board
keeping as much life left as possible
still relatively imbalance with White's
slightly odd Pawn structure here but uh
I'm expecting Hikaru to be able to
maneuver this one and he still
relatively solid for white so um yeah
just solid uh start to this game
sensible start for both sides and it's
just about when Abdu sator presses that
button pulls the trigger and tries to
unleash chaos Rook lift The Rook slide
uh it's ongoing I like what he's doing
because Hikaru is down a little bit on
the clock and I think that's where not's
trying to punish him we heard from
Hikaru himself when I've been getting in
time trouble I've actually been making
mistakes in game one it was nck who
couldn't handle the heat when both
players were down under a minute but
right now hearu down a minute plus n
backck not clear exactly what he's
threatening but that's kind of idea with
the rook in front of the white king it
can be scary absolutely it's also
psychological right it's uh you're just
building up the pressure you're kind of
hinting at tactics and attack on the
king side which is exactly what you need
maybe someday a G5 break will arrive
maybe your F4 Pawn will be hanging in
situations so nbak with the black pieces
really doing what needs to be done to
try to take down the world number three
hkar Nakamura we will come back to this
but another player who needs to take
down the world number two is Dennis
lawick he's playing with the white
pieces he's got the isolated Queen's
Pawn in compensation for that he's got
pce activity in the center the queen is
out the bishop lined up in the center
targeting that C6 Knight potential
threats against the F7 Pawn for Fabiano
karwana to me it feels like it's the
kind of position that does give white
chances yeah White's pieces look Lazer
vicious in this position uh nicely
centralized that white deepor will motor
up the board later on it's imbalanced as
well um this is yeah Dennis lazic if it
feels like he's really leveled up yes he
took a hit in the first game of the day
but yesterday um the way he played with
white against vasra I with white he's
just so so dangerous and not easy for
kowana to neutralize this one if he can
get the Queens off I think black will
breathe a sigh of relief um so maybe a
move like Queen to F6 but yeah still
early days and uh Full of Life full of
uh Rich possibilities here and Dennis is
proving that he's quite versatile as a
player often times we pigeon hole
someone saying they're a positional
player they're a tactical player Magnus
describes himself as quite Universal and
Dennis showing that not only can he
handle those closed catle in positions
when things open up he can destroy he
did that yesterday in the Armageddon
against Maxim Vash lra and right now he
may have an isolated Pawn that could be
seen as a weakness but he's got this
beautiful e file of minor pieces three
in a row and he's just trying to create
some threats but Fabby he is somebody
who has been in a must draw situation
before he is not defeated very easily
despite his day yesterday he won game
one in style here in game two I think he
is has everything under control yeah
this last move might be quite an
important one uh not just attacking
White's light squared Bishop in the
centr of the board Black's Queen doing a
good job there but Black's light squar
Bishop of his own threatening to come
out to G4 uh a couple of threats
actually not so easy to deal with for
lazic I think he might have a forced
move or two right now uh because of this
double attack hitting the bishop of
course and just as importantly Bishop to
G4 uh in the air some real Targets on
that diagonal so Bishop to D5 as he
plays looked the most logical trying to
cash in on seven as Tanya mentioned but
a Trader Bishops and things are holding
together for Carana he's trying to
alleviate alleviate the pressure by
trading off pieces and he just needs to
hold it together Fabiano Carana needs
only a draw to take this match Victory
uh we will move on to our top Mary
matchup here Magnus Carlton against
Wesley saw some tactics on the board I
see both David and Robert leaning
forward on their seats with this last
move the Knight has landed on E8 The
Rook is hanging well I think what I was
so intrigued by is like that Knight
didn't actually capture anything I was
counting black has all four minor pieces
and both Rooks so that's just a funny
move from Wesley no matter where his
Knight moved the bishop on G3 would hit
that Rook over there on B8 so he says
I'll go to E8 that's a funny square and
I think we're about to see a repetition
the Knight goes back and forth The Rook
slides a one square and this is going to
be a draw but he's going to come back to
C7 though he chooses the B5 Square for
now once Magnus moves to it Knight C7
Wesley is taking this to the Armageddon
yeah we'll see a handshake any moment
I'm not sure why Magnus is hesitating
it's all forced and after the position
repeats three times it's a draw we're
definitely heading to Armageddon now
yeah you can run but you can't hide we
will have a decisive result between
these two players as the match goes into
Armageddon after a quick draw by uh
Wesley so in this last position and of
course the action continues on other
boards NC Abdu satro really trying to
create a kingside attack that there he
managed to get the Rook to 86 now the
Knight is jumping there is pressure on
the F4 Pawn not very clear how Hikaru
plans to defend it how do you explain
the evalar in White's favor here well
we're a pawn up temporarily Hikaru has
just pocketed a pawn um I'm slightly
surprised how this is evolved Abdu satov
giving up a pawn in the center yes he's
got active pieces but even if Hikaru
just closes things down pushes a pawns
E5 it's hard to imagine things going too
wrong for white uh maybe there's more
maybe you push the FP there options
right now um Hikaru he's down uh
significantly on the clock but still
under control I was going to say that I
think ner Beck at this stage he's not
even playing the board he's playing to
put hikaro in time trouble there is 3
second increment in the match part of uh
these two games here and so for hikaro
he can gain some more time but look at
the clock nck still at 10 plus minutes
hikaro down under six but hiar is up a
pawn he plays Davis with F5 white is
clearly better and hikaro he's he's one
of the best even with 5 Seconds on his
clock give him 5 plus minutes I don't
think he's in any danger at the moment
yeah I'm going to admit I didn't do the
math when we move to this position that
pawn definitely count for something but
there is initiative there are ideas of
now with the move F5 not a back's Queen
from C7 can jump into enemy territory
here on that square G3 some dark Square
weaknesses the dream is Queen G3 Knight
F4 get that mate on to G2 ideas on the
board so still things to fight for and
the clock situation that you pointed out
he Karu will need to make some precise
moves yeah this is where okay he plays
Knight F4 first but this is where the
kind of match situation really plays
into hikaru's hands because at the very
minimum Hikaru can offer a trade of
Queens Queen to F3 Queen to G4 even if
he gives back a pawn uh then he's likely
to be able to guide this towards a safe
end game and a draw which would win him
the match so nck does not play the move
that maybe he wanted to play I Believe
quein G3 was potentially stronger
objectively instead now he is really
kind of banking on a trick Knight takes
one of these pawns uh for for example if
white is careless and takes on E6 for
example Knight takes H3 would be a
deadly check blowing open the cover of
White's king and the black queen now
would pounce and this would be decisive
the other Rook now could join the attack
with Checkmate on the board of course
Hikaru won't fall into anything as basic
as this uh but a check a threat and he
has to be slightly careful at least um
how to fend this one how to fend it off
Robert yeah he'll likely bring his Queen
out just to make sure that his King side
is feeling as safe as possible but the
attack does not stop there the black
Rook can slide over The Rook on A8 comes
to the king side so it's clear that
white is better white should win this
game with best play but AAR by his own
admission has been shaky is now down
under five minutes perhaps time will be
the Savior for nck Abdus satarov all
right well the clock is n Beck's best
friend right now and he's got to play on
the clock as well as try and put tricks
on the board the other player looking
for tricks has to be Ali Resa fuja but I
believe he's doing a lot better than
nybeck right now with the white pieces
that's another Pawn so uh an extra Pawn
we see opposite color Bishops remove the
heavy pieces remove the queen and the
Rook it ends in a draw but with King
safety being a key factor in these
middle games of different color complex
Bishops it has to be white with a big
Advantage yeah White's King tucked away
nicely there it's looking all cozy in
the corner but Black's King meanwhile
it's going to come under heavy fire and
probably within the next few moves
opposite color Bishops as you mentioned
Tanya it means that black can never
guard can never fight for the light
squares so if you can somehow launch a
light squar uh kind of continuation this
is going to be decisive I'm not sure
immediately moves such as Bishop
retreating to C4 Pawn to E5 maybe uh on
the cards if you can break through
quickly you might win but any end game
as you mentioned very drawish so now is
the moment I love Pawn E5 because it is
the moment if as Tanya said the Queens
come off the board drawing chances they
grow exponentially but if white is able
to thrust in the center right now black
can't take that twice it looks like a
defended square but if you think about
taking this Pawn E5 with first the pawn
and then the Bishop you have to watch
out there's a check on A7 that you have
to look out for there pins on the E file
there's
Bishop the black queen from the defense
on side and E5 has been played Ali Raza
may be down just above 3 minutes but he
has found his initiative yeah this is
ala firea on the board and uh yeah he's
this is up his street as well we talked
about what type of position he wants
it's attacking and uh this one is brutal
if you cannot take this Pawn I mean you
really have to be creative to survive
here I mean I think I would take it just
because I see no Alternatives but what
else could black try you could defend it
with a rook potentially but this looks
really flimsy dropping back with the
queen this would allow a capture and
maybe some checks on the E file Black's
King is really coming under heavy fire
from all angles right now and uh he
needs a miracle to survive Maxim now is
the moment to invest all of his eight
minutes and try to cling on by any means
necessary it's funny cuz I was going to
say the opposite I thought that Maxim
you know yes he needs to spend time to
survive but he needs to use clock as a
weapon because because even if he plays
his best at this stage ala might already
be almost winning so that Rook move that
you mentioned Rook up to B6 I think that
may be able to cause just enough
confusion with the King slithering back
to f8 and up to G7 you found yourself a
shield over there and maybe ala can't
find the knockout punch actually yeah
important right now he has to find this
Maxim so spend a bit of time but then
hustle on the clock enterprising play by
Ali Raza he is getting rewarded for that
creating creating big attack against
Maxim Vash lra's King for maxim is just
about surviving for a few moves but
doing it quick enough so that Ali resa's
clock he doesn't have enough time alira
look at him it's clear that he wants to
think in his opponent's time right now
he's got to do that the move that you
guys were pointing out the Rook moving
up the board attacking the queen that's
definitely also one that perhaps alira
is calculating where does the Queen
actually move after that step up to
B6 not obvious it does start to get
complicated which is uh what Maxim Vash
gra has to hope for he doesn't want it
to be kind of calculated a little bit
and then Alara knocks him out he wants
to at least make the path to Victory
tricky that's what you have to do when
you have a losing position when you know
you're struggling just make it
nonobvious for the opponent in the
meantime look at that evaluation bar in
the clash between nbec not NOC Nakamura
sorry against Abdu satov has Nakamura
blundered something's gone wrong there
because Abdu satov has a winning blow uh
here we see coming drama all over the
place we are going to go quickly over to
that board as uh we just saw D alar go
completely crazy last move by Hikaru
King to H2 nbak is on the tank what did
he miss he's missed the tactic Knight
takes one of the pawns now I think is
winning Knight takes G2 perhaps I'm just
shocked that black is no longer down a
pawn and all of the pieces are on
perfect squares right like even if there
wasn't a knockout blow here hiar was up
upon his King look safe no he misses six
he's playing on the wrong side of the
board but he's still up 5 minutes on the
clock yeah he plays a quiet move Abdu
satoro he needs to slow down he's been
playing very quickly and impressively
quickly but uh Missing the key moment
there we have to jump in and show the
decisive blow it would have been a
hammer blow to nakamura's Chances in
this match uh if we just backtrack he
played the move King H2 a bit careless
uh walking actually into the firing line
and Knight takes G2 would have been
lights out on the spot if you take this
KN with your Rook then Black's Rook
comes in and catastrophe on the H3
Square Black's Queen also joining the F
on F4 if you took with a king then uh a
simple uh follow follow up of cck and
and now Rook takes Pawn the black queen
is coming in decisively to some of these
squ not so easy but definitely findable
is it possible again hiar did Retreat
his Knight back to D2 so I'm wondering
that idea that you mentioned does Knight
D2 actually stop Knight takes G2 over
here or is that Knight covering the F3
Square so everything is fine good
question should we try it out Knight
takes Pawn got to take a look will the
eval bar move that's my big question it
doesn't it's possible it's strong for
black big moment for nck David for the
second time he can't afford to miss it
yeah he didn't find it the first time
though in a much better situation where
the white knight was not defending at
all now it's much uh kind of improved
for white so finding it on the second
time is going to be even harder I don't
think he will but he's investing time
right now before maybe he was playing a
little quickly you see him calculate he
grabbed a piece over there and he may
grab that pawn on G2 because Knight
takes G2 if we just look at the
variation after Rook takes Knight that
seems to be the safer way that black
Rook can slide to H5 double up those
Rooks against that little Pawn over
there I don't see a way to defend it
yeah this one looks terminal if you try
to defend with the White Queen I think
you can take any way Robert this is your
idea not take the queen yet don't be
greedy it's not running away first a
check and White's King will either be
forced away from the defense of its
queen or you have to block with a white
Rook but now you can Feast on every
single piece and this is over and you
can sense the nervous energy right now
from Abdus satov he's just moving around
he's a little fidgety he knows that this
is the moment give white one move one
opport opportunity in the knight from D2
comes on to defend from that F3 Square
so if nck has to strike it has to be
right now he has to find that killer
blow Knight takes spawn or the moment is
gone that
rhymed should we predict should we guess
will he find it I think so just by how
he's determined right now how he's
locked into the position I think he's
going to find Knight tg2 Tanya I'm going
to put you on the spot this time David
I'm going to go with Robert here just
because he is again just thinking like
said and you can sense it that he's
looking for these sacrifices he's
calculating and the good news is he's
got the time I'm predicting night take
spawn okay just to be argumentative just
to be different I'll say no uh but the
fact that he has paused for the first
real time in this game no more Instinct
Suddenly It's calculation mode he
switched that mindset it does hint that
he most likely will find it if there's
something to find the top players
normally do uh they do find those
opportunities so what you're saying is
no but yes yeah
I yeah I thought what he was saying was
calculation over everything and nck he's
been known to do a puzzle rush or two in
his day so he's working on those tactics
and right now he has a critical shot
Knight takes G2 that would blow open the
white king side I do believe that he
senses something there but he's just
triple checking because it could also
lose the game if it's incorrect yeah I I
completely agree with that and I think
nbec isn't the only one who's thinking
about it look at Hikaru Nakamura with
head and hands for both these players
this is the Line This is the part that
they're calculating right now will NC
find his comeback move oh moment of TR
he reaches out oh he doesn't make it he
doesn't his his Spidey senses must have
been tingling he must have known there
was something there just unable to
calculate to the very end and trading
off pieces is counterintuitive Robert
yeah he wants to remove a defensive
piece but I looked where the engine bar
was going to land because at first I
thought it would still be in Black's
favor it looks a little bit in Black's
favor but that path to equality may be
narrow so as commentator I like oh it's
equal it's probably not that easy cuz
black still so much Firepower in front
of the white king yeah white uh black
there did have four attacking pieces
against pretty much one Defender so a
tactical blow would have been logical
but now he's trying to trade off to make
it zero Defenders of the white King
still three attacking pieces if these
sets of Rooks get exchanged which they
do Rooks have disappeared and he's
trying to trade Queens off as well
seeking solace in an end game uh great
defense there from Nakamura Narrow Path
as you mentioned Robert but in the end
it was findable and sometimes that's uh
kind of what you have to do even if you
don't approve of the end game you have
to get rid of the opponent's attackers
at least he'll survive Beyond this
checkmating attack now K Nakamura looks
like he will survive but he needed that
help from nck nck not finding that
killer blow that we were looking at
earlier and against the very best in the
world it's only once or twice that you
get these opportunity in this game he
got it twice and missed it yeah the
first time he had seven eight minutes on
his clock and he just didn't pause for
long enough and only after Knight tod2
suddenly he realized that that was the
moment but um yeah unfortunately not
pulling the trigger in time and qu to G4
actually end gamees white is very quick
white does have extra space as well if
the Queens come off I think it's
relatively straightforward for Nakamura
to hold this one I think he needs to
keep the Queens on slide his Queen back
one square in the diagonal line it up
with The Rook maybe he'll push his own
pawns you need to go for it if you're
not your back and he goes Queen A6 the
Queens remain remain on the board watch
out that Knight is loose across the
diagonal there will be tactics here and
Hikaru is down to 1 minute and 4 5
Seconds that's not a lot of time in a
position that remains this chaotic and
speaking of not a lot of time there's
one player who's playing under 10
seconds and he has to win his game
blackking is out in the open still a lot
of attack attacking possibilities we see
the opposite color Bishops can fuja make
something out of Maxim's King on
86 it's going to be difficult the
problem is White's Rook is stuck on the
first rank cannot lift up the board uh
the white Rook cannot swing across to
give checks because there's uh yeah some
vulnerab ility on the first Rank and
suddenly retreating like this is not a
good sign black king can even slide back
to G7 at the right moment he did
actually miss a win a bit earlier fuja
and now with no time as well opposite
color Bishops this should be safe he
looks like he knows it you see fuja
grabbing his head and Maxim vasilla grav
with a dark Square Bishop has been a
holy Beast he beat Wesley so in that
game with a dark Square Bishop Landing a
Checkmate right now that Bishop is
defending his King so I don't see an
attack anymore black has both the
seventh ring and all the important
squares covered it looks to me like it
should be holdable for maxim there no
more threats yeah if anyone's better it
might even be black because of the
superiority of his bishop and okay now
the white king is vulnerable in uh
multiple ways if the Queen's ever come
off this is over Maxi Vash a massive
favorite now clock board everything
under control yeah he was already
threatening a check on the long diagonal
that last move by Ala sliding The Rook
to the dile hints at blocking it on the
D5 Square but it is Ali razar's king
that's feeling the heat now yeah it's
White's King simply less protection
white has two points in front of his
King black has three pawns it's simple
uh it's a simple count there and I think
he's going to try and actually trade
pieces off first he o near got a heart
attack there Robert yeah because that
Queen was Square was covered and it
almost happened but no he was just
tricking us here in the studio this is
everything under control but maybe there
will be a tactic that ala can find just
to distract Maxim but three plus minutes
I think Maxim is he's really doing
everything perfectly yeah if Maxim was
down at around the same amount of time
as fuja maybe a chance but wow did you
see how calm he was there he made that
move with one second but just
lethargically just calmly uh maybe not
believing in his chances I mean that's a
move that I would take 45 minutes to
make with my queen and the Rook lined up
and the H Pawn has arrived on H4 ala
gets The Rook on the open file but there
are all these discovered ideas on the E
Line targeting the white Queen yep and
uh for now Black's Rook is undefended so
maybe uh not uh kind of nothing decisive
right now but he's lining up now he
defends his Rook Tanana your idea on the
cards Black's Queen Rook Bishop they're
all P placed so perfectly such good
Harmony yes amazing geometry because the
queen and the bishop are also eyeing
that pawn on G3 in front of the white
king and now they're eyeing it directly
so fuja forced to defend it with the
queen he couldn't have really traded off
given the matte situation can he take
the pawn because a and he do play it
he's just try to trade que I think he
could haveen that pawn because there
were tactics Avail to him but this game
it's Max te it's his match all right we
will uh update you with the score but
this one is getting close to some big
territory for n back AB the look at the
queen and the knight in hikaru's Camp
Hikaru on the defense and look at the
clock Hikaru under 10 seconds playing
against over two minutes yeah that white
BN got snapped up it disappeared and now
any end game is winning for black and
very straightforwardly as well Black's
just going to push the B Pawn create a
past a pawn and Nakamura is going for
some tricks going for an attack against
the black king White Queen threatening
to come up to F6 with a check but first
black is the one giving checks wow
Nakamura is so strong at fighting here
but why is n back he's making his move
so quickly it's a good thing that he's
paused right now he's got an extra two
minutes on the clock he needs to use
those judiciously he has to try to wrap
up this as quickly as possible nck stops
any infiltration of the on the file now
he has it under control but what's so
difficult as a player is balancing when
to play quickly and when to pause I
think at moments Nock has moved too
quickly then he's paused and spent a lot
of time and you think why didn't he
actually punish Hikaru on the clock
right now hikaru's clock has been his
worst enemy and look at this knight3
there is a checkm net that has been
weaved around the white king it's uh
unfortunately for Hikaru not going to be
his game we will see armag again yeah 8
seconds for Hikaru nakam and he was a
pawn up in this game he's down three
pawns now how did that even happen it
was just the clock situation it was Abdu
soro's clear strategy from an early
stage he put pressure pressure pressure
eventually Nakamura cracked and uh yeah
right now he can give a couple of
checks but it's just that a couple of
checks and the checks dry up surely
there's a knockout blow now White's King
has been abandoned White's Queen is off
on a limb Nakamura knows that this is
decisive if Black's Queen can somehow
land on G2 it's over Knight D1 beautiful
some uh black queen coming in Nakamura
even apologized there for knocking a
piece and this check another check and
this one is over now black H porn will
become a new Queen and that says his
handshakes and nck with a smile he makes
a comeback and takes it to Armageddon he
can't believe it himself yeah that is a
smile of disbelief but that's a smile of
one of the future stars of this game
heck he's one of the current stars of
this game he's going to be around for a
long time and he just proved why
everyone has such complimentary things
to say because he just beat hkar
Nakamura in a must-win game with the
black pieces what a performance one not
back meanwhile Ali rzad does go down in
his match against Maxim VRA who got his
second win in their mini match and this
one is still on uh lazic down upon in
this end game it looks hopeless looks
close to hopeless but he's banking
everything all of his chances on White's
H Pawn it's not that easy to stop and it
does promote on a dark Square the same
color a matching Square as white Bishop
so still some questions to answer for
Fabiano no time on the clock he's just
uh trying to annoy white right now he's
trying to discombobulate White's Pieces
by checking pinning yeah no stability
here I think for Dennis lazic so this
one should be a draw even if black has
to give up the night for White H Pawn
that one is relatively safe but it's not
over yet that would not be ideal for
Fabiano because defending that rook and
Bishop versus Rook it can be quite
tricky so Knight G5 check you can't take
that Knight it was pinned he can go back
and forth he just needs to keep giving
these checks and stop that a PA but is
there actually a way for Dennis to even
continue the game with the knights and
the Rooks targeting that Bishop check's
coming in Well for now it's stopped so
black needs to be careful about the H
Pawn moving forward uh do you give a
check on
A4 yeah it would make sense to give a
check from the black Rook maybe get the
black Rook behind White's Pawn there we
go but Fabiano feels like he's not
exactly sure how to set up does he go
passive okay he brings his his Rook
behind now yeah going passive is never a
good idea in these end games but it is
hanging by threat suddenly for black and
that Bishop on E3 it's covering that
pawn there's no way to dislodge it from
its defense Knight C5 is a really smart
move if the bishop takes a knight
immediately the game is a draw so
Fabiano he is resilient he's putting all
his pieces in the right squares and
Dennis is King it's in enemy territory
can't do anything that's just a draw
takes the Knight but yeah that's an
admission of defeat he could have given
a check he could have kept the game
going but it is a draw kowana takes it
Fabby takes it but for dnis he managed
to draw another game with the world
number two so what a performance there
though he goes down in the match he's
got reasons to be proud Fabiano Carana
victorious in this one a much needed win
after his performance in day two where
he lost two games back to back have to
be proud of Dennis Laz he continues to
show that he belongs on this stage but
Fabiano he doesn't care that he let a
draw in that game he just wants to win
his match he's now three match victories
to his name it is clearly a different
Fabby today than it was yesterday and
this is the where we are after round
five the action for round five is not
over because we have not one but two
Armageddon coming up Magnus still was
always headed there but not a back Abdu
sov with a fantastic comeback against
harkar Nakamura with the black pieces
takes it into sudden death David what
was the highlight for you well it has to
be that dramatic encounter between
Nakamura and Abdu satoro where Hikaru
was on the Edge from an early stage he
was given a second life but Abdu satov
in the end did take it the pressure was
too much and it was around here that
things started to turn we thought
Nakamura was safe he was out of the
woods he'd survived the worst but after
the Rooks came off the board he let
things slip White had to be really
careful here and not allow the black
queen to get active as soon as the black
queen infiltrates enters the white Camp
it is over here he allowed this with
Knight to F3 allowing a check first of
all and now the black queen comes in and
a pawn did drop he had to be super
creative to hold the balance instead he
had to play a move such as Queen to E2
attacking the Knight stopping the black
queen coming in and if the Black Knight
does take a pawn now he had to find
Queen to A6 coming in behind and
actually the activity here the thought
of a Perpetual check would have saved
the game but extremely difficult and
congratulations to Abdu sator for
putting on that pressure in the end
hicaro has got to be quite frustrated
and angry with the outcome of uh this
game and there we see the players are
writing in their bids he's shaking his
head right now and uh we will be
revealing the bids soon they've already
placed their bids he is not a happy man
no of course he's unhappy all he need
was a draw with the white pieces you
don't expect to lose with white but to
be fair to him at that moment finding
that Queen E2 Queen A6 that dve just
showed that Perpetual check is so far in
the distance I think he was already
emotionally gone in that game and so I
think he's just frustrated they can't
put together a complete game from start
to finish we did get hints of that and
hiar was early interview with Ka as well
that he could feel that his performance
and the quality of Chess not happy with
it he had the extra Pawn he had the
match in his hands but now it goes into
Armageddon and we will be back with all
the action that's coming up and the
player bids and subscribers stay where
you are because you've got special
special content coming your
[Music]
way
and then the youngest one here an
underdog in the tournament Dennis lock
give us your take on him Dennis is uh I
didn't know so much about him until 6
months ago I actually met him first time
in the championship stour then he played
really good against me and I checked his
games and he's really talented I can't
like give a good read on him exactly I
I've only played him in one match in the
Champions chest tour and besides I have
never played him over the board he has
an uphill battle playing against more
experienced players but I I hope he'll
do well I mean I think for him he
probably just wants to try and make it
to the top four I don't think he's he's
one of the favorites to win the event
but if we underestimate um his abilities
he could pull off a big surprise I think
for him it's a great achievement to to
be here and he's shown this season that
he can that he can fight with most
people his results in online just were
you know were
incredibly uh impressive so yeah what
can I say you know in general I found
him a very solid player and very good
with armagedon probably the outsider but
uh it will not go down without a fight
against
anyone all right next one OB this a t
what's your take on him he show that
always a fighter when he's uh when he's
done I would say fighter that's that's a
word I would I would give for Notre back
always goes for uncompromising stuff and
he's not afraid of anyone I think Notre
backck is probably the player who runs
sort of the hottest and cold he'll
either play really well or really badly
I don't think there's any in between and
um if he's hot he see someone to watch
he's just like always fighting and
putting up resistance and he's really
tough to beat so that's that's the word
I use for him Al sator will do well cuz
he has such great sporting qualities um
I don't think he can win the tournament
he will be a difficult opponent for
everybody it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
back
[Music]
to
and while fans across the world are
enjoying the action coming in from
Toronto we've got the young chess fans
in Toronto in the playing Arena making
moves on the same board that the world's
very very best are playing on and look
at those
heartwarming Clips coming in how
inspiring is this to watch to to play on
the same chess Boo as Magnus Carson hiar
nak that was amazing that was precious
I'm seeing the smiles on their faces it
was just pure joy you love to see it
these players their role models they're
Idols to many people and the the fans
these kids they're just starting their
chess careers speaking of Joy there's
more joy in store for us because we've
got not one but two Armageddon coming up
it is a format so deadly that it's
called the Armageddon and this is how it
works welcome to the most exciting
format in chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match point white
starts with 15 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black and those coveted
draw odds let the Armageddon
commence and we've got two big ones
coming up and uh we've got Ka on the
ground with Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
and they're about to reveal their
Armageddon beds it's time for those very
exciting armagon bids you guys go ahead
turn your boards and let's see it I see
Magnus looking at wesle which says
932 853 that's going low Magnus you
wanted the black pieces
here yeah I thought sometimes you might
have to go lower but since i' bit High a
few times I thought maybe I could get to
bid with a slightly higher time you
surprised Wesley yeah Magnus strick me I
was going to bid 1459 but I had no
chance to win today so this what is good
feeling for you then Magus no I mean
it's still a very very tough game so uh
uh but um you know I'm um happy to to
get the black pieces now I've won a
couple of times as white but playing
back is always a bit easy here it's
going to be an exciting armag get on
Match go ahead you guys thank you for
joining back to you guys in the
studio wow Magnus Carlson bidding 853
really wants the black pieces we've seen
him bid at 10 and higher does that have
something to do with him playing against
Wesley so draw a very likely outcome I
feel like Magnus was not threatened at
all in the two games that we just saw so
for Magnus Carlson if he feels like
someone had a chance to beat him maybe
he will play on the safer side side bid
a little bit more time and maybe even
take the white pieces like he did
against AAR Nakamura but Wesley he's
very solid and by Wesley's own admission
he's like I don't know I I haven't had a
chance to beat him yeah and definitely
feels like Magnus adapting his strategy
according to the opponent we've seen
various different bids from him now
throughout the event but I want to pick
up that comment by Wesley I had no
chance to win was he talking about the
games was he talking about this upcoming
Armageddon he didn't seem kind of
positive with his body language yeah
very very surprising take there by
Wesley right before the start of their
armagon uh and we hope that's Mind Games
by Wesley because we've seen him make
very different decisions on the board
but remember that's not the only
Armageddon and we've got Kaa with NC and
Hikaru revealing their
beds here we go we have turned the
boards both players winning with the
black pieces so let's see how low you
wanted to go to 905 for Hikaru 11 23 is
it 29 all right that means hear uh you
haven't circled but you will yeah well
whatever Kar will play with the black
pieces 905 on his board just wants to go
and prepare your reaction to that bid
order
backck yeah I think it's a little bit
low but yeah we'll see yeah I mean first
of all I'm I'm happy to to win the game
I mean it was incredibly tough game you
know I I got big Advantage afterwards
opening but uh I mean usually as usual I
I messed up things and um yeah he got a
chance but yeah at the end I I was I was
luy that I I won the game yeah so must
win with the white pieces now but do you
feel you have momentum now after a game
two yeah I feel like playing with white
is less stressful and you know it's more
easier thank you good luck re oh this
will be such an exciting Armageddon
coming up back to you Hikaru is a scary
guy right now he is super mad what do
you make of what just happened you have
to feel for him he just lost a really
important game because if he loses his
match he may not even get to the
survival stage and hikara he bid pretty
low 9 minutes and 5 Seconds he was
constantly in time trouble against nbec
Abdus satar the one bit of good news
hikara beat him with black now he gets
the black pieces again maybe he's
feeling confidence with the second move
yeah we've all been there we've all lost
hard games when we thought we were in
control when we were so close to
achieving our goal um so we can't blame
Hikaru for feeling a bit down wanting to
get off and prepare there but yeah it
definitely feels like one player is in a
better mindset than the other right now
it is so much to do with momentum and
for nbec he did win that second game the
first one that he lost it was out of an
opening blunder clear that Hikaru
Nakamura he's out for blood in this one
it's not going to be easy for nbec to
sit across him probably hoping that I
wish this was an online game yeah but NC
is afraid of nobody I think that
everyone needs to understand this he may
just be 19 years old but we've seen him
staring at Magnus Carls and daggers in
his eyes for years he fears nobody he
definitely doesn't fear hkar Nakamura he
just proved that he can beat him on
demand so why not with the white pieces
with a six-minute Time Advantage when
he's been punishing a car on the clock
he really doesn't let a player get into
his head nck is that part of his talent
part of his genius uh David yeah it's
rare it's a very rare skill it seems to
come naturally to him as well just a
great mentality always up for the
challenge always fighting never backing
down uh especially against the top
players in the world that's the only way
to beat them um that being said Nakamura
doesn't really tilt too often normally
once the play starts once the clock
starts he's back at his best here we see
Magnus Carlson just chilling in the
green and another player that noted back
doesn't let get into his head was mag is
Magnus Carlson and now he's taken his
seat he starts with the white pieces n
Abdu satov has to win this game for
Hikaru Nakamura he starts with black
needs a draw he's not at the table and
narbeck is a speed demon I he has used
the clock to his advantage in pretty
much every match that he's played and he
did it against Fabiana Carana he did it
in that game against Hikaru Hikaru the
way he was acting it feels like he
doesn't even want to show up at the
board right now absolutely Robert and
their second game I'm still thinking
about their rapid game nck with black he
really created his chances The Rook lift
trying to create attack out of nowhere
and it worked he got Hikaru in a
position he's got to be feeling good
about the quality of his chest today
yeah he's been playing great actually
throughout the tournament it's always
interesting game always really really
double-edged stuff from nbec and uh the
confidence with such a high bid with
white he's kind of backing himself to
win again on demand um great to see it
from the youngster and it's nice to get
a tour of that venue out there in
Toronto I've been there before that's
where the chest.com global Championship
was held is where this year's Champions
chess tour finals are in Wesley so he's
a familiar guest maybe he's really the
host at this stage he won that big prize
last year it was his best tournament
ever that's what he called it and we're
waiting for Wesley to walk into the
playing Hall I think we saw him walking
around there but no dearbeck he's
somebody he's situated I think he feels
good about his chances he's got to be
feeling good about his chances after
winning the first game second game and
even the first one that he lost after
giving up that pawn he really put up
quite the fight meanwhile Hikaru
Nakamura extremely candid about how his
play has been so far and that interview
with Kaa of revealing the bids even
though Hikaru said very little a lot was
said and uh here we see the handshake
how quickly can Nakamura shake off the
memory of that previous game he looks
focused again Nakamura adjusting his
pieces now ready to start looks a lot
more Cal than he did uh during the bids
right there when he walked off but now
he's just taken his place it's fully
focused and Robert what do you think
about the opening approach here I will
be very curious to see what no debeck
plays because he's shown over the years
that he has Novelties up his sleeve and
just because he's young doesn't mean
that he doesn't have experience in these
critical moments but fre CaRu he knows
this is make or break time if he loses
this match oh he might not get to the
survival stage for nck he has much more
wiggle room because he won both of his
matches yesterday you're absolutely
right and let's remind everyone that
eight players playing after the round
robin only six will make it to the next
stage two will be eliminated while nbec
has had two two match victories hik
Nakamura currently at the bottom of the
table with just one match win so
extremely extremely crucial and losing
this one will really jeopardize his
chances to make it to the semi-finals
yeah Stakes are high Armageddon chess is
always dramatic but that will be a bug
in the back of his mind for Nakamura he
has black though and a draw being enough
means he can revert to being solid it's
just about whether 9 minutes will be
enough to fight against the might of
Abdu satoro
nbe head in hands he is ready to go
Hikaru Nakamura as well ready to start
this critical encounter between these
two what a miracle comeback it was by
nck and it is go time first move by nck
it is the Kings Pawn opening and the
Sicilian Sicilian not reverting back to
his favored E5 Nakamura really trusting
the opening remember he was winning by
move eight last time uh we had this uh
this variation and okay nbec surely is
going to be the first to improve Bishop
to D3 a mix up in move order from
Nakamura yeah because Hikaru castled
first and that's where nock's mistake
was he was anticipating hiard a castle
Bishop B3 seems to be the correct choice
and now in this game there was no Knight
G4 that square was not defended by the
bishop but AAR quickly strikes with D5
he clearly was expecting this opening
once again it's narbeck who's first in
the clock yeah but Hikaru is a smart
smart guy I think he figured that out
that nbec had actually make mixed up the
move order to fall into the Trap that he
did in game one and I think he was
expecting this to work out this way and
that's why we're seeing the speed that
we are from him yeah and this is where
it's really important to have a trusted
second a trusted team around you I have
no doubt that Nakamura had a little chat
in the break there with Chris Little
John his longtime second and uh he was
advised to play this variation a pawn
sacrifice temporarily there was a trick
on the board you could not take the
white Pawn on D5 Twice The Black Queen
would have been vulnerable there uh but
now he's going for the bishop pair
playing for activity blacks ahead in
development looks very healthy to me I'm
surprised nbec has repeated this
experiment for a second time and the
fact that not repeated and doesn't seem
to know what to do that is shocking and
maybe when you're flying high you think
that everything's going your way but
suddenly it feels like momentum back to
Hikaru momentum Hikaru this one's
heating up and this one is about to heat
up as Magnus Carlson and Wesley so are
ready to start their armag and we are on
the way Wesley also starts with the King
spawn opening and it is sicil for the
kill for the second time wow Magnus
playing the Sicilian in a situation
where a draw suits him that uh makes
Wesley so paus and Knight to C3 no open
Sicilians here will he play for the
Grand Prix attack this is a really
flexible move here for white um wow
forcing Magnus Carlson to think you know
it's Armageddon right Magnus and Knight
out to C6 really odd start to this game
Robert no increment until move 60 then
they get 1 second bonus time per move so
for Magnus to invest so much time for a
second move in a well-known position
it's surprising to me Magnus you can't
afford to burn 5 six seconds on these
early moves maybe you can if you're
Magnus Carlson but this is shocking wow
and Magnus reverts to a uh variation a
branch of this kind of close Sicilian
that he's employed on numerous occasions
with a lot of success but very strange
to play him to see him play so calmly
here and a lot of pawn moves here for
black he's just trying to control
squares trying to keep the game as close
as possible eventually black will
develop black will get the dark squ B
fet to it get castled it's a very
healthy position but very slow start to
this game but I like that for Magnus
actually because when they're tactics
flying and you don't have time to
calculate that's when you have to spend
a lot of time just to survive here
there's now threats in the position so
it's a calm approach from Magnus and
from Wesley Wesley may want to prolong
the game but for Magnus that means he
gets closer and closer to move 60 with a
bunch of easier moves but Knight H2
clearly Wesley wants to strike with F4
and open up the fine wow w Really spicy
really ambitious move there and white
again is ah head in development in this
game uh so opening the lines getting
castled throwing pawns towards the
opponent opponent makes a lot of sense
uh Magnus I actually do fear for him if
Wesley is in preparation uh if Wesley is
able to whip up an attack I'm expecting
Wesley to Castle first here we go the
king gets to safety and F4 for the score
on the board almost guaranteed next move
we'd love to see that happen but that's
such a double-edged move because you
open up the F line but you're also
potentially allowing black to open up uh
that Bishop on G7 which can be quite a
nasty piece also in return giving up the
E5 Square it has been played everything
has been done F line open Bishop open
Knight potentially jumping onto E5 the
queen from D1 can line up with a bishop
from F4 start targeting the E6 Pawn this
is already a game for all three results
and that favors one player in the
Armageddon white it does favor white
black in the meantime castles this is a
brave move for Magnus Maybe had to be
done uh but yeah Wesley now has the
chance to muddy the waters I mean it
feels like there's something in the air
out there in Toronto is just such crazy
games every single round and there we
see the air quality and uh I wonder what
how the players deal with that Magnus
likes a very warm room we've seen that
throughout the entire Champions chest
tour it's looking very humid out there
uh maybe due to how hot the games have
been I was going to say you might like
you the room to be warm but humidity
that's another story I'm from New York I
know how those Summers get and in this
position it feels like things are about
to get quite hot on the board because
that black king that just castled it
could be in the line of fire it just
goes out to protect that pawn in front
of it now but the F7 square is a bit
vulnerable there are going to be some
attacking chances for Wesley doubling
Rooks in the file seems to be a likely
possibility for him and I'm really
liking the start maybe he'll even push
his G Pawn forward throw it at Black's
King yeah Magnus meanwhile also doing a
good job of trying to neutralize the
pressure the more pieces that disappear
the safer he becomes so uh offering this
trade light squ Bishops and again we'll
learn a lot about Wesley's mindset on
this next couple of moves if he just
trades the Bishops off kind of starts
stepping back retreating maneuvering
then Magnus I think is in great shape
but uh maybe there's something more
ambitious maybe you just leave the
Bishops and uh POS questions to Magnus
say I'm going to trade on my own terms
he still has a 5 minute time Advantage
so he needs to maintain the tension he
needs to ask some big questions of
Magnus Carlson I like the point of white
just keeping the bishop there because
yes if Magnus was to trade on C4 it
gives white the double Pawn but it
creates a big glaring weakness for
Magnus with that D6 Pawn so just leaving
the bishop on C4 to allow tension and
what a move by Wesley so jumps in with a
knight check and that Knight is on pre
Wesley playing for the win Knight
sacrifice the Knight has to be captured
this is a check I'm not sure why Magnus
is pausing maybe trying to look into the
future uh the black light Square Bishop
on E6 as well vulnerable so this is a
poison Knight potentially but you have
to take it you have to call the bluff
there we go the idea is that this is an
almost unbreakable pin White's Dart
Square Bishop attacking a black knight
attacking the black queen indirectly
behind it and Black's King out in the
open now wow is this inspiration is this
A Rush of Blood to the Head Wesley took
us back to the romantic era of Chess
before the engines were't invented and
killed some of the creativity
unfortunately for him it looks like
Magnus might kill his creativity because
while there is maximum pressure down the
fine the engine and Magnus Carlson both
say black should be okay that Knight
that went to E5 sure it was putting
pressure on the bishop uh for white on
C4 but it can also drop back to D7 to
defend this Knight things are getting
spicy here though as the White Queen is
trying to slide to the H4 Square as
Magnus Retreats back to D7 he seems to
have everything under control I hear you
but I just love what Wesley's done an
intuitive sacrifice based on this pin
there are these ideas of getting the
queen in with a check the king moves
back David and now all you're looking
for is one more piece to join the attack
to actually attack that pinned Knight on
F6 and you can think about doubling up
The Rook but another plan comes to mind
is throw that E Pawn down the board I
want to Wate the E4 Square for my Knight
Knight jumping into E4 there are some
real threats to counter here yeah I love
it t you have to I mean you've said a
you have to keep throwing fuel on the
fire you have to invest more material
you have to say B you have to just go
all out for the attack now and this is
pretty much the only way if black gets
one more move if black gets to trade off
these Bishops and move the queen out of
the way out of this pin then the attack
Fizzles out it dies game over you're a
piece down so uh an idea an energetic
idea like that one is pretty much forced
it is necessary uh maybe he's just
checking the move order here looking for
options but giving a check throwing the
pawn out the way adding a another piece
uh to the attack and still Anything
Could Happen is the point that if black
plays Bishop F5 just to intercept The
Rook on F1 that's trying to barrel down
are you going to take that Bishop like
are you really just going to continue
sacrificing all your pieces the engine
didn't actually change it still is
better for black but this is scary with
that Knight trying to backtrack into F5
oo happening but it is a different move
order he doesn't give a check first but
we might see this line being played out
once the f file is blocked I don't see
another way to fight the pin you have to
go Bishop F5 I think he's trying to hide
the idea if he played Bishop F5 or if
he'd given a check first White's Rook
would obviously at least have the option
of going to take that Bishop he's saying
please play Bishop F5 and then I'll get
out the way with a check with gain of
time and then I'll take you and uh I
mean you mentioned the romantic era of
Chess Robert I grew up reading about all
these games morphe gam sack sack sack
mate and uh it looks like at least the
start of one of those examples from the
19th century I mean this looks like a
Timeless Love Story talking about a
romantic era this is a fantastic game so
far but the big question is can Wesley
take it to the net right now he is
putting maximum pressure on that F6 KN
Magnus Carlson in a bit of a trouble
he's feeling the heat he's feeling it on
the board and on the clock his bid was
quite low and while Wesley seemed a bit
dejected perhaps he shouldn't have been
because Magnus down to 5 minutes 40
seconds the start of this game was calm
but it was the Cal before the storm and
Wesley so has been storming in this
tournament four match wins in four
matches and he is looking at number five
unless Magnus can find all the correct
moves and do so quickly because to get
to move 60 at this stage under this
pressure it will take the top rated
player in chess history yeah he's got 43
moves before he gets any increments so
it's literally a fight to the death at
the this point and I mean surviving the
next 510 moves is going to take a lot of
accuracy don't see it and that's a
minute and a half worth of think there
by Magnus Carlson with no increment and
the troubles just starting the
calculation just required uh it's only
going to get more difficult right now I
mean we're setting ourselves up
potentially for the first time Magna is
getting flagged this is Wesley so just
in Top Gear in top form I mean all I can
think is what could have been he if he
plays like this uh so ambitiously in
every single game uh I mean he would be
I think one of the best players out
there he already is but Queen B6 this
looks risky this looks a bit uh
counterintuitive Robert putting a queen
on the other side from your king I'm
kind of into that move though because if
trades happen on F6 so many pieces come
off the board that black gets to make a
series of moves instantly and then
there's not much in the way of an attack
for white so this is a good decision I
would say from Magnus he invested a lot
of time under 5 minutes remaining but I
think it was a great Choice by him he's
just trying to control things that
variation we showed with even more
sacrifices for white it just looked too
scary I don't think black's defenses
would have held up in a practical game
and uh yeah because it is pretty much
Blitz at this point especially for
Magnus Carson he just wants to trade
pieces as you say and maybe we
investigate we show that line you
mentioned uh if white were to regain the
piece that was sacrificed earlier just
take everything off the board then we
would eventually see a bishop exchange
and white can drop back uh with a check
avoid the queen trade but for example A
variation like this we do a quick count
we see actually it's a level Magnus has
survived and Magnus would guide this
game towards safety so Wesley first
gives a check and now the question is to
drop back or to block two
options neither obvious neither that
tempting but you have to choose one of
them wow this attack is still brewing
and uh Magnus Burns even more time
before blocking with his Knight this was
an option not available to him earlier
um if White had given a check first but
wow he's going for it now Wesley so and
what to play do you simply take this
bishop back the evaluation bar jumps up
maybe you take the Knight oh my goodness
the black king side it's just being
shattered and there are not many pieces
in defending it and that queen that
Bishop that Knight on e4 all of them are
hunting that king and you see the eval
bar saying white is significantly better
this type of position where Magnus
Carlson doesn't matter who you are you
collapse under that Firepower Wesley so
is in on fire right now at this very
moment crazy position we're going to do
a quick check in on this game Hikaru
Nakamura needs only a draw and to my
eyes it looks like he's well on on his
way to securing that draw and the match
victory yeah a draw here by far the most
likely result also look at the clock
time it's almost level only 30 seconds
in it so Nakamura has done everything
right here white Bishop maybe slightly
better than the Black Knight because
there are pawns on both sides of the
board but it should not be enough to win
there's too little material all right
even material even pawns it does look
like this is headed to a draw we will
jump straight back to where the action
is and Wesley still in I think in the
same position that we left it the Knight
on H5 Pinn the bishop on C4 is hanging
what are Wesley's candidate moves right
now that he's thinking about you take
that Knight if you're me I'm taking that
Knight in front of the king and I'm
trying to exploit the fact that Magnus
is under duress on the clock as well in
terms of his King safety so G takes H5
David you're the one who pointed it out
I really like it you're just going
direct path towards that King yeah just
one track mind here tunnel vision you
need to just focus in zone in on that
black king uh if you okay he does it he
takes the Black Knight he's going for
checkmate if the white if the light
Square Bishop now saves itself if it
drops back for example then a check a
double check actually forces the black
king forward out into the open and now
is the need for the killer blow I'm
struggling to find it it feels like it
must be there the black king out in the
open in no man's land maybe you play a
move like Bishop to F6 and uh this looks
deadly for example if the Knight takes
this bishop you give a check you capture
on F the with the no you should show the
end of that because that's an easy trap
to fall you take with the Knight it
looks like you're winning the black
queen because you're also threatning
Checkmate on H6 but there Rook G8 and
move that saves the day here and black
would actually have the upper hand yeah
so the idea would be to actually same
idea with just with an inverted move
order you flip the move order and the
tactic works this time the black king
two out in the open and this would be a
deadly combination the queen and Knight
the best duo when it comes to attacking
and wow Magnus is actually walking down
this variation he's allowing it all to
unfold on the board Wesley needs to find
it he has to calculate this true and
make the correct move and over the next
five moves this could be all over for
Magnus Carlson Wesley on the brink of
delivering the first blow but he does
change it up he starts with the check
does mixing this move order impact the
outcome maybe just a much more rational
way of doing it uh he doesn't want that
mess that melee of tactics where it's
easy to blunder as I did in that
variation in instead he wants to Simply
trade everything off maybe he wants to
take with a rook now and cash in on the
dark squares for example A variation
like this one I think white will be
successful in a king chase the black
king now would be doomed in all of these
variations the black king is suffering
walking a tight RPP and Moment of Truth
Wesley takes back with the rook and this
looks decisive Wesley so has many fans
out there and they've all been clamoring
for him to play just like this the
inspiration we're seeing in a must-win
game is bringing out the best in so who
took down Magnus Carlson for the 2019
Fisher random world championship title
and this game right now with Black's
pieces not saving that King on H7 we
could see him win in fine style
especially as Magnus his clock is dipped
below three minutes at the stage how do
you defend this position with no time
morphe the queen they'd all be so proud
of this effort I mean this is
desperation for Magnus Carson you saw
the shake of the head on the camera
there I mean it's just shock Magnus is
reeling with Shu this is a free porn I
think you can just take this you can
drop the White Queen back if you need to
but uh this is just going to end in
Checkmate Magnus is down a queen as well
just for rook and Bishop I've never seen
Wesley play this kind of chest look at
that he puts the F Pawn forward wins
more material and now the Rook will join
into the attack Rook F1 Rook F5 Rook H5
uh and once that happens it will be game
over he's just trying to take everything
with Czech Wesley so he's just cashing
in on the material he had that deadly
attack Magnus panicked understandably it
was so difficult to defend and this is a
masterpiece from start to finish I think
Magnus is actually impressed with Wesley
right now sometimes when you lose you're
really upset we saw Hikaru with that
reaction before but you have to just tip
your cap to Wesley so the way he's
playing I think he's your king F2 get
your king out of the check's way that
way you can slide your Rook on over to
G1 to help deliver a Checkmate I mean
Wesley he is just doing everything
perfectly there's something about
Toronto something about Canada that is
amazing for Wesley so chess yeah wow
he's just played I mean every move
perfectly look at him Wesley so he's
even got time to admire the ceiling
admire the uh artwork on the walls he
got six minutes on the clock and it's
over I mean Rook G1 check and queen H7
check you win a rook yeah he should look
at the ceiling this game is like the
suine chapel it's beautiful artwork and
it's over he just won this game it finds
everything he's played this to
Perfection he gives a check Magnus
blitzing it out even Magnus knows this
is all over he's down everything on the
board he will fight this out till the
end but it's not going to be enough not
against a Wes Leo as he shown up today
yeah sometimes if you have a rook and
Bishop you can hold a fortress against a
queen but this is the loosest for
Fortress I've ever seen blacks Pawn's
all isolated Black's King two week out
in the open still almost checkmated this
black king um this one is over white can
simply just collect all the pawns much
the queenside pawns on the board yeah
Masterpiece I'm just thinking about the
Wesley during the uh during the armag
getting bids he was so disappointed and
he looked so unsure and that confidence
and the comment he made that he's never
going to win I mean what was that about
then he comes on this board with brutal
force I think it plays to his favor
because he's playing into this narrative
like oh I can't do this I'm in this nice
guy who maybe doesn't always believe in
himself but look at what he's done here
if this does not make Wesley believe in
himself I don't know what will but this
is an absolute Gem of a game from Wesley
he's just ins snaring this King The King
has no moves if he gets to deliver one
check it's over he's also up a couple
pawns what a beautiful beautiful game a
tactical Skirmish that has gone his way
yeah a tip for everyone at home play
chess with a smile on your face it leads
to good results take risks attack enjoy
it and uh yeah just don't look back
Wesley so he's just closing out this one
finishing touches it's so smooth even
Pawn to A4 that's just sadistic he's
just saying to Magnus you barely have
any moves left black is stuck white is
going to win white is going to win it's
under two minutes from Magnus doesn't
even matter Magnus could have two hours
on the clock right now he's not going to
save this one he needs more than a
miracle to survive this I mean let's
play Devil's Advocate just for a moment
is there anything that Magnus can do to
try and create a fortress in this one no
and he also doesn't believe in
fortresses right that was one of his
famous quotes and he said it you know in
a with a smile on his face but he is
trying to drum up some counterplay if he
can win that c t on the base of White's
chain maybe he have some chances but I
think White's the one who's going to
steal a bunch of Pawns here the A5 Pawn
the C5 Pawn all on dark squares and
don't be surprised if Wesley gets
another queen later yeah the only thing
to avoid is getting all of your pawns
traded off uh you need to maintain at
least one ideally two connected pass
pawns longterm uh but he still has a
three-minute Time Advantage he captures
now o a really nice check just throwing
Black's coordination off there uh black
is forced to block with the bishop and
Black's King is going to get chased
around things are going to fall with
check and we're all peering in we're all
looking oh there were tactics Galore
Black's Bishop was loose the black king
had to go back and defend it
everything's just working so perfectly
he hasn't put a single foot wrong Wesley
so just out played Magnus Carlson how do
you do that he played every move with
purpose in this game but throwing in a
little Pawn push with Czech when it
think it looks like he's going to make
the obvious capture I mean look at
Magnus right Magnus is like I'm playing
I'm trying my best but after this game I
promise you Magnus like wow that Wesley
when he's at his best and honestly
there's little even I could do about it
we have to see where it all went wrong
once this is all over because it just
felt like a Wesley so show start to
finish how did things turn out so bad
for Magnus and he's still fighting it
out still trying to find a defense here
can white just keep getting greedy and
pick up the last remaining Pawn on the
queen side I think the answer is yes
this feels like a chess boxing match
where just straight from the off
westley's been punching punching
punching Magnus has been just reeling
around in shock trying to block from
here and there but uh ultimately
shouldn't be enough okay now two
connected pass points they're about to
March up uh the board and okay only one
check there for black Wesley so still in
control I do have to give Magnus some
credit for surviving this long we've
been writing him off for a long time
we've been saying it's a forone
conclusion but still alive for now I
mean Wesley was playing against Maxim in
the armag garden Maxim was fighting with
a knight against the queen here Magnus
has got a rook and Bishop yeah and oh
Che one be careful black Rook is
threatening to go behind the white king
to G2 the white King's actually caught
in a mating net good thing is you can
run away with the white king you can
give it a few checks first with the the
queen hey counter play for the first
time in a long time yeah this was Wesley
perhaps not keeping an eye on his King
and now the King has gone to F5 Rook G2
Checkmate is a threat you can't push the
pawn to create a square you still get
checkmated so he's going to give a few
checks suddenly Magnus has a chance I
can't believe we're actually saying that
right now after the game that we just
saw scene Magnus Carlson uh creating a
threat Wesley so slowing down under two
three minutes he had to go up with the
King to AO m in one he does it Magnus
gives a check the king moves forward
yeah he's running with the King to
safety that white hbor valuable in
blocking any potential checks and I
think that was the only key moment the
one trick to avoid and now Magnus still
hitting thin air the white king is
entirely safe nothing to be done there
while the pawns marched uh inevitably up
the board yeah the thing is when you're
playing Magnus Carlson you can have a
winning position but you have to beat
him in every move and Wesley saw has
done it Magnus gson resigns Wesley so
takes the armagen against the world
number one there are no words and you
see those players they didn't share any
but Wesley he deserves a world of credit
this game is still going on I almost
forgot about it considering how
interesting Wesley so's Domin domination
demolition whatever you want to call it
of Magnus was but here we are in an end
game where it looks like like hiar
Nakamura should hold with the black
pieces he should hold but look at the
clock situation both players down on
time we're around move 50 now so they
will get increment shortly that being
said there's still two pawns left and
white king is about to run in oh oh and
the bar's going up Suddenly n Beck's
King is infiltrated going after the G5
pawn bishop holds everything together
White's Bishop is so good with pawns on
both flanks Black's Knight is a
short-range piece cannot control both
flanks Nakamura has lost control 20
seconds he's got to make eight more
moves and he's lost control on his
nerves as well as we can see he is
panicking right now the Knight defending
the G5 Pawn for now but the bishop can
start hitting that Knight on E6 but then
the Knight hops around to attack the
bishop you could tell that nck is also
nervous at this stage he makes a quiet
bishop move they're nearing move 60 they
get a second added per move when they
hit move 60 there's a tablet next to
them telling them what move they're on
Wow and noed backck the pressure is on
him to make progress the position is
almost repeating itself right now he's
struggling he's got around 11 seconds
and okay he made the correct move yeah
he almost stopped on the wrong Square he
goes Bishop E8 and now the bishop
protects that A4 Pawn if the knight move
G5 drops Hikaru he has no time left he's
got to move make a move 4 seconds Hikaru
he panics and puts the Knight and loses
upon but now it should be a relatively
straightforward win that being said the
evaluation bar moves another check wow
this is crazy they've only got one
second increment each move he needs to
move he needs to speed up and both
players are so nervous they're living on
that increment right now the pawn A4 is
defended the white king is going towards
the queen side A5 is going to drop yeah
white is winning white will win that a
pawn it's an Pawn that promotes on a
light Square as well White's Bishop
holding everything this is simple oh and
It Go Nakamura he gets up he
resigns NC Abdu satov he reacts he knows
he's done it he takes down the worldall
number three in the armagedon he was
playing comeback in this match he lost
the first game wins the second one wins
the Armageddon he's the comeback kid
that is what he just did you watched no
dearbeck Abdus satarov the former World
rapid Champion take down hikaro Nakamura
not just once in a must-win game but
twice in a row he gets the job done what
an unbelievable performance from him
this has been an insane day of Chess
already David to dramatic dramatic
Armageddon What stood out for you oh my
god wow that end game wasn't Ive and I'm
definitely going to go back and play
over it later that game between Abdus
stov and Nakamura but I just want to
highlight the critical moment where
Wesley so pounced threw a tactic in
against Magnus Carson and took the game
to Victory here we were talking about
Bishop exchanges playing slowly
strategically he said no it's all about
tactics romantic chess Knight to G5
check a sacrifice and as we saw later on
throwing all the fuel on the fire Pawn
to E5 blowing things open a queen check
to come and a deadly attack one of the
most beautiful games I've ever seen SC
stunning stunning chess uh by Wesley so
and we are going to a break but we'll be
back with all the action from our
playing Arenas Danny is getting set up
there there is a very crucial round six
coming up hiar Nakamura staring at
elimination we will be back with more
from
[Music]
Toronto
if I can ask you um to write uh how you
think the top five overall standings in
Champions Chester will look like this
season is Ali rasa playing or or is into
fashion now should I put myself yeah
okay okay I'll go with Magnus okay first
one is a long name my mother is watching
us I have to be
careful you know what I can be confident
no I can put my name of course
you know I just beaten Magnus here in my
Kan I'm returning my favor there
returning a favor to good old friend so
you have knam on top why is that yeah
he's just been like winning all events
whenever I see him play he wins so he's
probably going to take this one as well
um ding has bad internet so he he he is
left
out I just put myself in the
middle we need confidence so
CaRu prag ala and Wesley Soul your
handwriting is very
nice to
see that's all that's your only bet yeah
that's my only bet all
right your top three goals that you hope
to achieve in
2023 let's see the first one would be to
qualify to the candidates I've only
played the candidates once and it didn't
go very well in
2018 so I'm very excited to see what
2023 holds uh there still be some over
theboard tournaments here and there but
almost half of the tournaments are held
online and they're very important they
got a lot of stake uh I'm very place to
win last year's the global chess
tournament I'm excited to be part of the
new Champions chess T and chess.com it's
interesting to see what this new
partnership will will hold for them when
big online tournaments that would be
very nice for me as a player I'm trying
to balance myself between being very
good at classical while also doing not
bad at online and speeches because
they're two very different things and so
this year is going to be exciting as
well as a challenge and my my calendar
is actually getting very full at the
moment I also need time to spend between
resting recovering and also preparing
and number three would be uh too
ambitious but i' say uh reach the top
three in the
world and then ala for RIA at this point
that you got to say that ala is a
complete wild card cuz you don't know
what to to expect at all I still think
that his ceiling is very very high
whether he'll he'll hit
it seems unlikely but um I I mean I hope
for his sake that he can find some form
here cuz he certainly has the potential
to do well he is uh he has been a leader
of our you know of Our Generation people
tend to forget how young he is because
he's been now established at the top so
I'm looking forward to some Mo here in
Toronto has is The Prodigy and he's
definitely the first name that comes to
mind among many other proing players of
course but he's the he's always been the
front runner of his generation I I think
certainly for him it's a chance to try
and redeem himself here at the end of
the year obviously his rating his fall
and he's not going to qualify for the
candidates so I think he has a chance at
Redemption A lot's going to depend on
also like you know his openings how he
plays and everything but again very
dangerous and he could win the
[Music]
event
a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive disc discount
on all metal posters shop now with the
code Chess at displate.com
[Music]
we are in Toronto with what maybe was
just the craziest round in the 2023
Champions chess tour final Danny wrench
alongside James KY and I don't even know
where to start about what just happened
Wesley so ronto this is his place he is
here he showed up today it's amazing to
see the results before you because okay
I I did pick Wesley and again I I meant
what I said I I think he plays well in
Toronto but I guess I guess I just
didn't expect it to go down that way
what a game we just saw the game of the
tournament the the commentators throwing
it back it was romantic it was full of
sacrifices it was a game out of the OG
books he sacrificed a piece and ends up
just destroying Magnus Carlson in a
kingside attack I know we've got other
games to get into including Notre Becka
doov beating hiar Nakamura putting him
on the brink but let's go back to this
Wesley so performance I mean when you're
watching this game in real fashion like
you see the sacrifice of the pece then
you see the sacrifice of the you're like
okay but really it's Magnus you can't do
this right I saw Knight D7 I saw Queen
B6 I'm like oh yeah Magnus is getting
out of this I was checking I'm like oh
yeah okay she should be okay and then
Wesley found all these moves and
resources then the queen sacrifice and
then Magnus was done for I mean you can
just tell you can see the frustration on
magnus's face Wesley stayed calm and
collected he looked up a little bit all
right cool I got this and game over
Wesley Santo so with the dub you could
tell that everybody was suffering from
Magnus bias itis including Wesley
everybody even toward the very end of
the game was like Magnus going to pull
this off maybe there's a mating net but
Wesley holds it together calm cool and
collected he does seem to like it in
Toronto he caught up with Kaa just after
the victory and uh Well here here's what
he had to
say Wesley so just played an incredible
armagon came against the world number
one Wesley how are you feeling right now
yeah very good praise uh Jesus for the
win for all wins come from him but uh
yeah it was it was very crazy I just
it's kind of miracle that I won uh but I
mean it's been it's been a fun game
like when I sacrificed the peace I knew
that my probably my only chance is to go
all out for an attack with Magnus uh I I
don't think the sacrifice the peace
sacrifice works but sometimes you have
to take a Le of f i I can't even begin
to tell you the praise you have been
getting from the experts in the studio
on this game I mean will you even where
will you even rate this game in your
career just such a fantastic game yeah
it's crazy uh the thing is I wasn't very
happy at all with how the opening turned
out and if I played slowly I thought I
would get absolutely nothing like it's
starting to play D5 next move or Knight
H5 so I figur I have to go for it if I
lose I was going to lose anyway so I
didn't have anything to lose and it
looks kind of interesting I was sure
that black has a
defense
uh but uh yeah it was a fun game I mean
it looks like a very strong very good
game but then when you check in engine
probably full of blunders uh also in the
end like I think Magnus blundered at
some point when after played Knight E4
thought he should have take on C4 first
I wasn't sure but also instead of Queen
takes F6 okay Bishop takes F6 is better
and he's still worse like take take
Queen H sh and5 Brook F1 but at least
he's not down in material so I was
really surprised why he played Queen F6
yeah we should take with the with the
bishop and I think black survives at
least unless I'm missing something crazy
I wouldn't be able to tell you Wesley
but this win takes you to the sole lead
in the tournament it's now looking very
very very likely that you will make it
straight through to the semi-finals what
do you think about that who they play
next you play up to four of oh my boy
yeah yeah also coming from a win so what
should we expect from that one with my
boy well there's still a lot
of things at stake yeah because he could
win the rest of his matches so so uh I
was uh roting for hikaro
but but it didn't work uh so again one
one match at the time uh it's a miracle
that I won against Magnus so praise God
for that amazing play Wesley
congratulations and good luck in the
next one yeah thank you so much that is
the amazing Wesley so for you back to
you
guys you can tell that Wesley himself
hardly believes it right he's going over
the variations sure that there must have
been a better defense for Magnus you see
it was a very well played game by both
not a perfect game but I don't think he
realizes just how hard that position was
for Magnus to hold absolutely 100% I
mean he even said it with Bishop takes
F6 and then he missed that and even
looking at the eval bar on the event
page I'm like oh Bishop FES was better
but it was crazy because his King ends
up on G6 and like all this wild stuff
happens so Magnus made a practical
decision to take with the queen there
but Wes is like yeah he's just still
worse crazy game I thought Magnus made
the right decision too cuz I thought he
was probably going to get mated if he
didn't remember he also didn't have very
much time on the clock which is exactly
what you have to do when you're white in
Armageddon Wesley wasn't confident going
in but he did exactly what you're
supposed to do he held nothing back he
played quickly he brought the house and
if more people played like Magnus
Carlson you might have more victories
against Magnus Carlson that's the truth
and so I think that from a practical
perspective he did exactly what he was
supposed to do and if that is a sign of
things to come and these two guys meet
again later in this event yeah sign me
up that's what I'm saying sign me up all
right a guy who was also uh signed up
according to my predictions before the
match for a loss was notc of duat turov
but he proved me and anyone else who had
Hikaru Nakamura winning this one wrong
let's see what Notre Beck had to say
when he caught up with Ka wow what a
game from notbe Abdu saturo to beat tar
Nakamura in that match how are you
feeling right now no I feel relieved you
know I have to uh recover as soon as
possible you know because I'm playing
Wesley so yeah it's it's going to be
very tough match of course what was the
key in this Armageddon to get the win to
beat tar Nakamura um just to keep the
pressure just to keep the game going
because
I mean he clearly
prepared uh for armagedon and you know
played uh very quickly in the
opening but I got some some little bit
advant Edge I mean you can't say it's
Advantage but little bit Edge so uh yeah
I was I was trying to to keep the keep
the pressure and um yeah at some point I
was okay I was of course um I I wasn't
build like I didn't believ that I I'm
going to win this game but uh um things
turned out well for me so yeah it's it's
very I'm very happy and you're now on
three points how do you see your chances
now with two matches left in the round
robin to make it through to the next
stage
um yeah it's it's it's looking good
first of all and um yeah I don't want to
you know um be relieved um
too soon so I'm I'm I'm just taking it
as as usual so yeah we'll see and now
Magnus Carlson even Magnus Carlson
losing to Wesley so who's just on fire
so what could be a possible way to beat
Wesley so in your next match yeah I mean
he lost in arm right so it's it's kind
of a tricky tricky um tricky part of the
game so yeah I mean playing games w is
always always tough he's a hyper solid
player and um yeah we'll see how how how
he'll approach will you use the
confidence you're now having the the
momentum you're having into the match
with Wesley I would say um I need to
recover from these emotions yeah it's
it's been so so tough you know I always
I I can't stop you know uh my my smile
during the game against I can see that
yeah playing against sari is like
something special for me you know he's
so emotional and he's making so
many um emotional
um emotional things that I can't stop um
you
know smiling during the game yeah what
does it mean to beat I bet someone has
been a role model for you hiar Nakamura
in in a match yeah of course he was he
has been a model for me you know I I've
played against him when I was literally
kid like in
2014 2015 or something like that so yeah
it's he's clearly has been my model uh
in speed chess of course and um yeah
it's very pleasant and this is my first
big win against him in a match so yeah
it's really uh really big achievement
for me so you're saying you need to
somehow remove a little bit of emotion
right now to get ready how will you do
that what can you do to to get ready and
focused for Wesley um first of all you
know just just forget about the game
against Hikaru and
just um like take it like I'm playing uh
like first first uh game of the day yeah
so fresh Toronto air maybe before it all
starts sure yeah congratulations again
nordbeck and good luck in the next one
thank you wow what an amazing
performance by nordbeck here getting
some fresh air now maybe before the next
one starts back to you
guys you see it right there it was not
the best game either of these guys have
played 85 versus 83% accuracy but it was
enough to get the job done Notre Beck
abusa turov shocks the world beats one
of his childhood Heroes you heard him
talk about that he says just how hard it
is to play Hikaru when you grow up
against a Legend Online to really just
keep your wits about you in that moment
you can see how much it meant to know
not Beck you saw him smile right after
the game K you just caught up with him
you could just feel the energy in that
interview how relieved and how awesome
that felt for him he was so emotional so
happy it's so cool to see these
youngsters actually beat you know people
they've looked up to their whole life
yeah such a cool moment for him 100%
Wesley so's not so young but I think he
does look up to Magnus so you have just
two guys doing something that maybe they
didn't think they could do and so and
Abdu such tur off but all right we're
going to dive right into the next rounds
pairings and do a preview you've got
lavic and fuia there BOS lra and Carlson
will Magnus bounce back Wesley so and
abduc aov uh now a match that could
decide who's leading and getting a
direct ticket to the semis and then the
Battle of The Americans Nakamura and
Carana oh my gosh do we have more in
store and you know what we're going to
do what are we going to do we're going
to Dive Right In we're going to Dive
Right In we're going to predict it right
now I I think maybe I'm in the lead
right now I think after that round you
might we're going to have to check that
for tomorrow morning that's not checked
but before before we do we're going to
start where all things due even though
he did just lose Magnus Carlson versus
Maxim bash the grao KY yeah one thing I
remember Carlson said in the interview
he was like yeah you know what I have to
immediately win after I have a loss so
I'm taking Carlson he's probably very
pissed right now okay I've stocked
Magnus Carlson around the world for nine
years now as a reporter I you know you
rarely see him lose two in a row it's
going to be Magnus Carlson yeah I feel
bad for maxim right now because like you
wanted to a different type of Carlson
maybe a Carlson who could let his guard
down cuz he just beat the co- tournament
leader but no now you've got a hungry
Magnus Carlson looking for Revenge so
all right but speaking of that
tournament leader Wesley so is now
clearly in first but he takes on a guy
who is literally streaking through the
gymnasium you've got Notre Beck winning
three matches in a row who you got in
this one he kind of is but you do have
to go with flex Ley so after he just put
down Flex Serrano his whole name just
changed here as he's he just took down
Magnus you can't even sounds like a
mafia name
like a guy that you you call when
someone owes you money but okay all
right so Flex Le Sano for him I think
he's going to have a perfect round Rin
Wesley so for me I I'm I'm going with
Wesley so as well again although right
now I feel like I got to stop picking
against Notre back apparently I'm the
one pissing him off I think I picked
against him four matches in a row now
everybody you can blame me for that but
all right then we move on to the game
the match excuse me that could decide
which top American besides Wesley so is
staying here you have Fabi Carana hiar
Nakamura I don't know the tie breaks in
front of me but this is absolutely
massive who do you have here I
definitely take hikaro again I mean he's
just down it's tough you know he has to
fight back I always rock with hikaro
even ups and downs so I'm RO with hikaro
I'm gonna disagree with you I think
Fabiano Carana will take this one Yar
Nakamura is very emotional right now so
yeah he's having a tough time you're
right I mean honestly that means you're
predicting we're not going to have a car
Nakamura in the survival stage which is
which is mindblowing I don't know that
it's over if he loses to fa but I'm I'm
I'm with with KY I do think Hikari was
going to win this one I thought he was
going to win the last one but uh you're
right that at this point feel like
things are being thrown in the air we'll
see if hikaro can can pull it together
all right the last matchup we haven't
talked about ali Resa fua taken on
Dennis lavic yeah your thoughts phro fua
I mean he's still doing his thing right
of course um fua is just stronger than
lavic I think on paper so we'll go over
FR yeah well I did meet him yesterday
having that Mexican food that was some
really nice tacos I think that's going
to give him some fire I'm rooting for
I'm not rooting for but I'm betting on
uh frine that's why all right I also am
taking all res of fuia in this one here
and it's not just because he called me
out about predictions yet I know I've
already said that but again I'm taking
fuia again I do think he's going to beat
the youngest player in the field Dennis
lvic here speaking of the youngest
player in the field similar to having
caught up with Notre Beck I also had a
chance to catch up with Dennis the
Menace as the nickname is now becoming
more known throughout the land and his
mom the full interview as we said will
be hitting our our YouTube and all the
other channels where you find the good
stuff probably tonight or tomorrow but
right now check out a quick snippet of
this conversation we had before things
got underway like any chess player I
feel like I have to adjust the pieces
before the start of any big game I'm
Danny by the way Marina nice to meet you
your mom yes yeah are you are you super
proud of him for for making it here he
is a ordinary guy but uh he has a talent
he can play chess and I brought out my
son yeah take us back to when you were a
kid when did you first learn to play
chess what was the first thing about
Chess that got you excited and maybe
take us through that that experience my
father taught me to play chess and I
played with him a lot you know he he
Lear me to E4 Queen H5 Bishop C4 and I
the scholars made yeah yeah yeah this
queen age five first right and you beat
all the kids with this yeah I almost one
every game but it doesn't work
anymore yeah is it easier for you at
times to play online than it is over the
board cuz you probably played thousands
of games more online than you have over
the board yeah of course it's it's very
important for me to have this
opportunity to to play against strong
players the main thing that when I play
online I I'm nervous less I think it it
helps me a lot yeah I to play at home
yeah what else do you have any you have
any pets at home yeah I have a pet you
have a cat M what's the cat's name
bushka buka I love that name Babushka
buka I love
it I cannot wait to meet bushka someday
I don't know why I just have a feeling
I'm going to meet bushka one of these
days if uh you want more from Dennis LC
you're going to want to check out the
full interview we got into some stuff
including the fact that he's been
playing on chess.com since he was a
little kid winning title Tuesday since
he was in FM getting accused of cheating
around the world we got into all of it
and he was honest it got real that's
what I'm going to tell you you're going
to want to check out that interview but
right now it's time for us to check in
across the sea with the studio in Oslo
uh I gotta ask you guys like what are
you making of Wesley so's last game
there Robert David anyone who wants to
answer that was one of the most
brilliant chess games I've ever seen
Wesley so
play I feel like there are no words I
mean the game that Wesley just played is
the type of style everyone who's a fan
of his has been clamoring for for a long
time I said it when it was happening it
was romantic it was beautiful it was a
demolition Wesley deserves a mountain a
world of credit yeah and for Hikaru as
well I think we are still reeling from
everything that we just saw Danny uh I
mean Hikaru going down in that
Armageddon see how is he doing and is he
someone that you'd want to be around
right now he looked very angry off of
that
game I don't I don't know how he's doing
I mean I'm sure he's not I'm sure he's
not too thrilled it's been it's been
hard to watch he's lost two Armageddon
battles well he no he had lost two
armagedon battles going into today so
now he loses a third after having
already gone down to mvl and Magnus so
it's just regardless of the fact that
hikaro is struggling which none of the
fans really want I think losing in
Armageddon is not something you expected
from a guy who wins a lot of Armageddon
100% especially as as good as hearo is I
mean sometimes just doesn't work for you
I me maybe it's just not the right
element not the right timing the chess
guys just aren't with him today it's not
working especially after taking that
first game win in that match and like
you said I think there the whole chess
Community they really want to see Hikaru
make it uh into survival stage right now
at the start of this event would anyone
have predicted that hikaro would be
fighting for his life
here never never and although I I said
before the round and I don't know what
you guys are discussing there in Oslo
but when people were asking me and
legitimately putting me on the spot I
wasn't evading the question I literally
didn't know how to answer it you look at
the pairings you look at the eight
players and somebody has to go home two
players in fact right and so whether
it's exactly what you expected or not uh
and of course we still don't know what's
going to happen can't wait for this
round it's uh it's definitely been a
thriller wow it's been a thriller in
Toronto and I have to ask you guys that
what are the turnarounds that you're
expecting being in the playing Arena you
can see the players their mood their
mind set there are Hikaru Ali RZA Dennis
at the bottom of the table right now
what kind of turnarounds can we
expect I think it's going to be I think
it's going to be very aggressive here at
this point now I mean at the bottom it's
tough it's tough to see it's tough to
know who's going to go home today
somebody's going home I think two of
them actually are going home today which
is going to be really tough I'm not sure
who that's going to be because he still
got a mats left today so let's say
somebody wins I mean things mix up but
not backck is going crazy he actually
jumped and Lea frogged never thought
actually I didn't put nordbeck as one of
my favorites going into uh today but now
I have to change everything that I
thought about nor everything is changing
here everything's changing T mentioned
the player was coming in so I did the
quick look around we only had the the
Frenchman with three names sitting there
although it looks like young Dennis
lavic did just enter so they will be
filling in here last question I want to
throw to David David we don't see Magnus
lose very often you're a friend of his
your thoughts on the mindset Magnus will
have after losing to Wesley so well uh
firstly it's the manner of the defeat
Magnus first of all respects great chess
um I've been there when he's had tough
defeats setbacks and he's like okay
actually my opponent played pretty well
of course he's frustrated but I don't
think he'll take it personally I don't
think he'll let it get him down too much
yeah as we saw Danny saided the players
are walking in right now getting ready
for this very very critical round tick
we've got one more round robin uh game
coming up tomorrow but uh this one so
much depends on it yeah it does and I
think that means the players will
trickle into the uh scene behind the
commentators in Toronto so bye guys miss
you wish we were there but we're having
a lot of fun covering the
action see you guys later bye have a
great time we'll see you on the other
side yet
again bye Ley bye
Levy dannie James and Levy somewhere
there in spirit right now but gosh the
the players have to uh have to just show
up for this game I mean especially the
ones who are really struggling on pretty
much their last uh last game if uh the
ones with just one match Victory one
more loss and it wouldn't even matter
what happens tomorrow the problem though
is that the matches don't really get
easier right Kara loses to no dear beaar
his reward Fabiano Carana so there are
no off matches for anyone Dennis lzic
proved that even he can beat some of
these Superstars he beat Maxim V lrav
earlier so getting him that's not a walk
in the park no not at all and uh Fabby
is in formed he did beat Dead lavic in a
convincing way and for Hikaru of course
we all saw what just happened but one
guy I mean Wesley so T and Magnus
Carlson he'll be playing against nbec
also feeling really great with his win
against taru how how do we assess that
match I'm just I'm not going to even
attempt to predict the results I'm just
going to say it's going to be fun games
fun positions feels like both players
are just at the top of their game
enjoying it more than ever before um I
expect notet to throw some stuff at
Wesley maybe Wesley will throw some
stuff back judging on that last game and
uh yeah it's just about who kind of
plays quicker spots those tactics faster
and here we see Abdu stov ready ready to
commence action and NC's got to be
feeling good about his chances going uh
forward into the next stage of the
Champions Chester final as do Wesley who
are the players for whom this round is a
makeup break Robert well of course aaru
and any player who only has one match
win Ali Raza and for Dennis but I think
Maxim vasher lrav he's somebody that we
haven't spoken about all that much but
he did just beat Ali Rea and he has a
chance to continue that winning streak
and secure his placement through to at
minimum the survival stage and there
we've got the Frenchman with three names
Maxim Vash lra hard to tell what that
expression is probably thinking about
his opening approach just don't feel
sleepy right now you need to bring up
all the energy that you can on the board
uh and Maxim vrab will be playing
against Magnus Carlson who is also ready
to go are we expecting a kingspawn
opening a sicilian in this one uh I
don't think it was a ya T I think it was
a raw I think he's woken up and he's
ready to play a sicilian is very likely
that's Maxim's bread and butter we've
seen him kind of semi blundering the
opening but understand positions so well
uh in those Dynamic uh kind of messes
that he navigates it uh to Perfection I
think the players now you can sense the
tension itching to get going um Magnus
Carson of course wanting to bounce back
back but this Clash is essential uh
forja against uh lazic both players need
to win to have any chance now of staying
alive in this tournament and uh Stakes
are getting higher the good news is they
play each other the two tail Enders you
beat a direct rival if you get the match
win and uh look at lazic just making
those last minute preparations and on
paper fuja has got to be the favorite in
this matchup what does Dennis need to do
to recreate that magic from his game
against Maxim he needs to survive with
black David mentioned this earlier in
the show the Dennis with the white
pieces super solid he's very difficult
to beat but with the black pieces he's
been a bit shaky he lost to Fabiano with
black earlier today so if he can keep
his time management under check and play
well with the black pieces he gives
himself a shot at minimum to go to
Armageddon where we saw him beat Maxim v
l why are all the players yawning what
is going on what's up with the Toronto
air well I was trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt but it did look
like a you on that one as we see hikaro
Nakamura enter the fry and essential for
him uh this next match the All American
Clash he needs to win he will play lesic
in the last round tomorrow but um yeah
no guarantees there either yeah one guy
who won't be yawning but will be roaring
is Hikaru Nakamura right now it really
does come down to this and it's not an
easy matchup for him it's not an easy
pairing as he does Take On The World
number two and the Very in Fabiano kwana
and look at that Hikaru is still shaking
his head he needs to leave behind what
has just happened and that is often the
most difficult thing to do for a player
but he needs to focus only on the next
move when we are going to be underway in
just a few seconds and there we go it's
the handshake we're off Fabiano opens
with his Kings Pawn Nakamura he's been
playing a sicilian uh loyally in recent
times and Fabiano does not copy Abdu
sator strategy from earlier today it's
the Rosal limo Sicilian white brings a
bishop out more strategic nature to
these positions uh to this early stage
and uh Robert do you think Nakamura is
just going to be setting up shop trying
to hold the first game strike with white
or how does he even approach this one I
think he is taking this cmer approach
because of his emotions going wild and
that was a roller coaster match against
nir Becca buar winning with black losing
with white in a position that looked
like it was close to being a draw and
then losing in the Armageddon when
speaking of close to a draw that end
game it objectively was holdable but
without time in the clock he was unable
to do so this takes me back to my
childhood to Fabiano's childhood we had
the same coach growing up grandmas Miran
Sher and he taught us both these lines
so for Fabby I think that he's in
familiar territory something that goes
decades back what were you taught to
play in this position Robert well it's a
moment for Fabby because he moved his
Rook to E1 so he can slide his Bishop
back to a number of squares some people
slide it back to the D3 Square which
looks odd because you're in front of
that pawn and you're stopping your own
development but you're are going to
slowly unravel you can drop it all the
way back next to your king or you can in
fact take this Knight on C6 and then
strike in the center with D4 so all of
these are viable growing up I actually
was told to play different lines because
uh my coach he was saying like you know
it's okay as long as you have your
foundation set you can then choose what
to do next Choose Your Own Adventure but
Fab he's really investing quite a bit of
time here yeah and Hikaru off to a fast
start in this game yeah to me it feels
like he's provoking slightly he's saying
okay take my knight please yes you're
ahead in development yes white will open
up the center but um at least then he
would have the bishop
Fabby just choosing his Adventure this
time uh pausing it's the stylistic
choice that's where these top players
tend to invest the most time uh when
it's tactics they see it so quickly so
sharply but uh they're trying to peer as
deeply into the future as possible right
now and for hikaro I do think it's a
good approach playing a more solid line
because against Fabiano he's a machine
he's a calculating machine you don't
want to just throw tactics just because
you want to win chess is an objective
game you can't just play for a win you
need to play the position and right now
I think hiar has done the right thing
it's a solid start to this one Fabby
will strike in the center with D4 at the
moment but yeah he's playing this
gingerly as Fabby yep uh we'll see a
trade of Pawns now Hikaru frowning what
face number is that Robert oh I don't
want to get into this Danny already
criticized me yesterday I'm sitting this
one out all right well one thing he
can't hit out of is a decision in the
center and he does take it so we see
some trades and now there is pressure on
that C6 Bishop the Knight centralized
Fabby will continue with developing his
Queen side pieces meanwhile Hikaru has
to focus on taking out the king side
pieces and getting his King to safety
are we expecting him to take out the
dark Squad Bishop for Hikaru with a fan
on the king side G6 Bishop G7 or do you
expect the pawn in front of the king to
move forward tough call I've played
Hikaru a few times including actually in
this uh opening not the exact Branch uh
the exact variation but he tends to
favor putting a porn on E6 and a bishop
on E7 uh just staying flexible at least
from my experience um yet to be seen
though of course there's no right or
wrong in this uh type of situation it's
very much a matter of taste and maybe a
matter of his kind of mindset uh in the
m in the tournament situation I'm not
sure which the most ambitious would be
there it depends whether Nakamura is
feeling ambitious or he whether he just
wants to stem the bleeding having lost
two games in a row chess is a complex
game with different approaches and we're
going to find out which one Hikaru
chooses but I think the most important
thing for this particular game with the
black past say for Hikaru would be just
to keep it under control because he does
get white in the final rapid game and
can think about creating his chances in
that one but not to let Fabby get an
advantage a sizable Advantage out of the
opening but the problem is if you play
too solidly then Fabby can get a bit of
a bind like even in a position like this
Fabby can decide and he I was going to
say play C4 and you have this bind in
the center this is actually a pawn
sacrifice but if the Knight takes on e4
that would be a blunder you would
actually lose a piece the bishop could
have taken on e4 but there may have been
some difficulties furthering your
development you're actually allowing
white to continue developing quite
rapidly Knight C3 Bishop G5 next and I
don't think that black king is getting
out of the center very easily so it was
a temporary Pawn sacrifice that wasn't
legitimately a pawn sacrifice because he
couldn't capture it but I think David I
mean this is such a clamp in the center
that you have to like the position from
the white side yeah it's what we call
the maroxy bind with a Pawn on e4 Pawn
on C4 it's a bind because uh you control
the B5 squares D5 squares therefore you
control and prevent Black's Big Pawn
breaks if black cannot break out with
the pawns then Nakamura will most likely
be a bit uh cramped he does have the
bishop pair long term uh he doesn't have
any real weaknesses but white has free a
play more space due to those pawns
binding in the center Bishop coming out
Queen stepping forward very easy free
play for white and uh Nakamura meanwhile
he does go for the other option uh
commentator curs I said he'd play E6
Bishop E7 of course he goes for the
other one and uh the bishop is on a nice
long diagonal here watch for that
diagonal to open up later on but uh in
the meantime this will take a slower
Pace now as Fabiano decides on a plan of
development and Nakamura does
likewise yes a dynamic way to develop
the pieces places the bishop on the long
diagonal and that's not really what a
player chooses when you're going for a
very solid approach so I think uh Hikaru
is proving at least me wrong here that
he wants to try to create a game and
create chances in this one we will check
in with this it's a slow start let's
move on to Magnus Carlson who just lost
his round five in a deadly Armageddon to
Wesley so uh he's playing against Maxim
bagra who took down alira fuja and Maxim
has managed to get a knight on D4 which
means that we can expect a lot of trades
in the center who would that favor in
this uh position well it's essential
that black clogs that D4 Square because
you see there's one Pawn on C4 if white
could actually push that pawn where that
Knight is you have such good central
control that black would not be a happy
camper so you're clogging that lane
you're making sure that that pawn push
isn't available and as Tanya was
indicating there might be a trade on
that D4 square but I like what mag is
doing trade on your own terms Knight
takes Knight on F3 will not be very
scary you can simply take back you have
this bishop that is staring down into
the black camp and eventually you will
be able to challenge for that D4 Square
so I like the start of this game for
Magnus I would prefer to have the white
this position but Maxim he's been Rock
Solid in the center yeah the one thing I
will say is that Maxim was the first to
surprise Magnus if we go back just very
briefly to the start U Maxim always or
nearly always uh fan ketto is his Bishop
he normally tries to play the gal
defense bringing KN out porn out Bishop
to G7 here we transpose to a very slow
type of position uh which normally would
favor Magnus Carlson so interesting that
Maxim maybe fearing opening preparation
switches things up but catching up with
the current position I agree with
everything Robert mentioned there now
with black you have to be really careful
this diagonal is just so strong this
white light squared Bishop if it ever
opens up will become the most valuable
piece uh so accuracy is needed at this
early stage and I've actually looked at
this position before myself a long long
time ago and I do remember that you can
take this Knight and try to plug the
square with the bishop instead um
multiple approaches of course but Maxim
needs to be careful things could spiral
quickly for Black uh not in a positive
way if he slips up just once or twice as
Magnus makes a bit of a face there
on the
camera really uh nicely explained there
it is uh all about stopping that light
squar activity uh of magnus's Bishop on
G2 and now alira fuja was a tough one
against Maxim vasher lrav and he also
along with danis lavic facing uh facing
well an early exit an early elimination
if both these players don't start
getting points and they're playing
against each other so really quite a
critical critical match for our
standings and I'm looking at the
position I first feeling Bishop on E6
it's got to be a beautiful piece Black's
King has got these holes light Square
weaknesses around it a dream to get the
knight from F3 to go to H4 land a check
on G6 it looks really nice for white
visually but I see that I albar says
that black is absolutely fine how would
you explain that yeah first of all it's
a weird position for such an early stage
um I guess it's just the fact that black
is solid black can right now regain the
pawn that he'd uh just sacrificed Den
lazic I don't see any reason not to I
don't really see any uh tempting
Alternatives and um just to highlight
the outline of the position it might be
to do with the fact that black has an
extra Central Pawn so more flexibility
later to push forward in the center but
yeah Knight takes Pawn concretely uh I
don't see any downsides to this you Pawn
down take it back and undermining this
very strong Bishop that you mentioned
Tanya if we see the bishop being traded
off for example uh then yeah I don't see
anything too wrong fundamentally um wh's
King most likely really wants to Castle
soon uh you can never Castle on the
queen side because there's a hanging
Pawn on this flank but once you Castle
it will be about whether black can
eventually organize to break out in the
center with D5 if not then white tonight
might be the best piece U but yeah just
small things to play for here roughly
level Dennis in thought yeah well if
Dennis who has picked up the pawn is
able to neutralize that Bishop on E6 he
does have more space with uh with black
in the center as well and at some point
dwn can start pushing forward as well so
it makes sense that it did look really
good visually but without the F Pawn and
the bishop on E6 Dennis lazic doing fine
with the black pieces he's not just
doing fine he won the opening battle
because he temporarily sacrificed the
pawn but he knew the line very well and
you look at the clock Ali Rea he's been
down on time in some of the matches but
then in other tournaments when he's
feeling super confident he plays at a
lightning pace and Dennis he himself has
actually struggled on the clock in many
different games it's actually been
probably his biggest failing point in
this event is that when he gets in time
trouble these little mistakes happen
against Magnus Carlson in the first
match overall he actually was still
within that drawing territory he just
didn't have enough time to calculate but
here he's done everything perfectly he's
developed he's tucked his King in the
corner he has an open line for his Rook
he's even on material I think that he's
done a really nice job with his
preparation and his play in this game
and you can see a bit of frustration
there from FIA he does trade Bishops but
Rock Solid for black right now in this
important uh yeah this important
Clash all right well we will uh keep it
eye on this one as these two players
fight to try to make their way into the
next stage of the Champions Chester
final and one other player who's trying
to do exactly that is Hikaru Nakamura
and he's playing with the black pieces
once again it looks like whites managed
to create such good Harmony pieces at
the center of the board the bishop and
the Knight on D5 eyeing the E7 pawn and
one can feel that yes Hikaru can get rid
of that centralized Knight on D5 but
these are always very difficult
decisions to take because because once
white recaptures with that E Pawn it
really opens up the Rook lined up on the
E file I'm liking Fab's position at this
point all the pieces forward Hikaru
moving back with his Knight no easy
targets yes it's not clear yet but I
would pick white here I don't like Fabby
session I love it these type of binds I
think are some of the most difficult
positions to play from the black side
because as chess players we don't like
sitting passively and doing nothing we
often want to lash out throw upon
forward but there actually are very
clear downsides to pushing Pawns in this
position you can't push your E Pawn as
black you lose your queen that's off
limits you can't push your F Pawn to
challenge that Bishop because you also
lose your queen with the Knight jumps
into E6 that Queen is trapped you can't
push your H Pawn to challenge the bishop
because the White Queen and Bishop well
they're staring at that square no can do
and so if you push on the queen side
with Pawn to B5 then that actually you
can transfer the game into a better
position for white you take on C6 you
take on B5 you just slide your Rook on
over to C1 and wh's more active pieces
it's a clear Edge for white something
that these top players dream of yeah I'm
pretty sure I've seen this position in
diagrams in books what not to do with
black just uh it's too passive I really
fear that Nakamura is on tilt here he's
kind of allowed white to achieve
everything uh kowana wants here I mean
this is a perfect Pawn formation these
pawns um on the queen side this Knight
you mentioned Tanya removing it uh this
would just allow a white Pawn to
recapture and suddenly a rook Unleashed
even more pressure now on the backward
E7 Pawn which is going to be a target
for ever and uh I just don't see any
plan what to do and like Robert said if
you cannot do anything active I mean how
do you wait I mean maybe you move this
KN around I'm not sure where it goes you
do something but in the meantime Fabiano
is going to start advancing porns
potentially uh Pawn to H4 an idea throw
the pawn up to H5 H6 you can build the
Christmas tree put a Pawn on F3 uh for
example here and uh I mean look at this
it's nearly Christmas I'm getting
excited here but Knight to C5 is on the
board from from Nakamura and
yeah it's just feels like oneway traffic
right now he needs to be creative to
break out of this horrible bind that
black faces all right Fabiano Carano
with an opening Advantage uh it might
not be much but it's much easier to play
with white than with black in little
space no clear trades to ease off the
pressure every trade would favor Fabby
in this position whether it's the dark
Squad Bishop with the central Knight or
the light Squad Bishop with the other
Central Knight and as Robert pointed out
there's no way to push your own pawns to
try to Force white species to fall
backwards uh Hikaru is he also fighting
an inner battle right now with the way
things have gone besides playing of
course one of the most informed players
yeah he wants to play his way back into
form but that's really difficult when
you're playing against Fabiano Carana in
a normal Swiss tournament where you play
people in your score group you lose a
game then you're supposed to play a
slightly easier opponent here in this
format when everybody's a killer out
there you lose lose a match a
heartbreaker of a match and then you get
to play Fabiano Carana so there are just
no easy pairings and you could see how
upset he looks I mean this position I
don't think is particularly fun but I
believe that he's more so thinking about
what could have been maybe what he
believes should have been yeah there are
no easy players because at the Champions
chest it's about crowning the Undisputed
champion of the tour and these are the
eight best performers of the Season
fighting it out in Toronto uh and
speaking about the interesting positions
wow this is Magnus Carlson with the
white pieces taking some committal
decisions with that F Pawn moving it
forward to keep the Knight on E5 solid
and in control but the downside of that
is that you've created dark Square
weaknesses I'm loving Maxim's Bishop on
C5 I see the evalar it's really inched
in magnus's favor after the that last
move is there an immediate drawback to
Queen to E7 I think potentially and it's
to do with your point Tanya black has
great grip on the central Dart squares
but you could can remove that you
mentioned especially uh Black's d square
Bishop why not just go Trade It Off
Knight to A4 you're putting pressure on
this bishop the bishop cannot move
because there's pressure on the Knight
as well once you remove this piece black
loses control might be forced back and
uh as Robert mentioned earlier if this
Knight is ever kicked away pushing a
pawn to D4 you build the Christmas tree
actually in this position it sorry it's
Christmas guys I'm just getting carried
away here it looks like you got a
Christmas tree again with white the nice
kind of formation here and Black's
problem the main problem is this uh this
naughty child uh the black sheep of the
family this bishop on CA is totally
stuck dominated by wh Bishop on this
beautiful diagonal and uh yeah I think
all of these small things add up to
something uh larger and Magnus despite
his clock time which uh maybe shows a
lack of confidence after his Armageddon
defeat I think he'll be loving his
position it's a lovely picture here
because we're often told to push our
Pawns in the center to take up space and
look another Pawn push towards the flank
he is just trying to gain even more
ground Kick That Knight out of there
maybe Knight comes to E4 rather than the
rim to kick that Bishop out of C5 and
when you f Kettle your Bishops those
Bishops stare through the board they go
on the board's longest diagonals and
those Bishops for white they're much
better than the Bishops for black yeah
if things ever open up if those
diagonals are cleared White's Bishops
will be archers assassins from afar and
uh okay Rook to d8 from Vash grav what
is he relying on magnus's plan is so
straightforward so simple okay he wants
to trade off the pride and joy of
White's position this night but uh
tonight surely is just going to land on
this magical E4 Square hitting this
bishop watch out for it sacrificing
itself later on near the black king to
blow open uh that flank I mean it looks
like oneway traffic it just feels like
Magnus uh is in his comfort zone Maxim
less familiar with the structures Maxim
hasn't developed his Queen side his Rook
on8 that's just sitting there doing
nothing the bishop on C8 it's at home
can't even move so this is not a good
position for maxim Vash lra and for
Magnus Carlson this is a nice bounceback
game it looks like he should be able to
take it Black's position looks miserable
Magnus Carlson has broken up the
Christmas tree but he's getting all the
gifts in the position already with the
Knight jumping onto the center he does
slow down a little bit trying to also
work out uh perhaps what he wants to do
with that E5 night the one thing that
you don't want to really allow are
trades which would ease off the pressure
so taking on D7 only works in Black's
favor you want to keep that Knight where
it is if black was to capture it opens
up the F line for the Rook to come into
the game I really like the suggestion
that you guys had of the Knight jumping
onto the center of the board and Magnus
reaches out he makes the move attacking
the bishop which is the defender of a
key Knight in the position in the Knight
on D4 so posing problems for um Maxim
VRA there meanwhile Fabiano Karana looks
like he's putting up some problems to
hikaru's Pawn on E6 that Knight Retreat
only retreated to go forward E6 Under
Pressure not only that a big H5 in the
air
it's all gone wrong for Nakamura just
today it started so well with a win
against Abdus Toro but two back-to-back
defeats this third game now he won't be
wanting to Castle queenside as we say
three losses in a row notated in the
same way 0 z0 H5 is coming Black's King
is so weak Black's structure is really
really feeling loose right now I mean
there are tactics in the erors well I
what you guys are looking at I'm too
pessimistic perhaps but uh yeah this
looks like Fabiano in the but there's
also a problem with every Pawn push you
leave certain squares behind so that
pawn on E6 it's a double Pawn yes but it
used to sit on F7 defending more of the
king side so right now when Fabiano he
already threw the pawn up to H4 he's
going to thrust that to H5 and there
isn't sufficient defense on that square
you can play E5 for black that is true
you can kick that Knight out of there
but look at your Bishop on G7 is that
really a bishop it's staring into its
own Pawn it's not getting out the Knight
can also go on on over to B6 you rotate
the Knight your fork a queen and Rook
you win some material but if it was that
simple right Fabby would have played H5
really quickly but I think what he's
working out is and what I'm also trying
to work out yes the move that David is
highlighting right now that actually 86
is a possibility for Hikaru and if you
fall back with the bishop the gon moves
forward actually winning material and I
saw the evalar it didn't budge after 86
which means that there is a good
response here but what is it I think we
need a helping hand from uh the engine
from stockfish here because H6 does look
like it wins a piece white can sacrifice
in various ways for example Knight takes
porn but look the evalar drops down and
I mean to me this looks dangerous white
can take back with a queen like can
maybe throw in a move like E5 it looks
like you've cut the board in half and
Black's King is in danger but yeah I
mean it's not obvious from a human point
of view H5 is a big commitment and after
H6 Nakamura would be calling the bluff
he'd say pressure is on you Fabby you
have to Checkmate me uh because you're
about to lose a piece I didn't even look
at that move H6 I'm going to be
completely honest but does threaten to
trap the bishop and fbby he's saying I
can actually hit you with a tactic first
E5 please take my Pawn it's a hanging
Pawn know it's not because there's too
much traffic down the defile there and
white will gladly trade Queens land a
rook on the seventh Rank and win a bunch
of blacks pawns yeah what happens if
Bishop takes Pawn will Fabiano unleash
uh the tactics and play Rook takes
bishop and then just side step with the
White Queen saying oh look at your queen
it's attacked but also look up your
Tower of Terror these tripled pawns I
mean they're all going to drop off one
by one by one this looks horrible for
black uh I really like this I think
maybe a more practical decision from
Fabiano here that's a really cool line
with the queen side stepping attacking
Black's Queen on D7 and the pawns are
going to All Fall one by one but Hikaru
he decides not to allow any of that and
instead goes for a flank break with B5
and we will keep an eye on that one and
jump back as black has made his decision
and meanwhile there are decisions to be
made in this one Magnus Carlson he's
decided to fall back with the knights
and not allowing any trades and there is
a big big threat on the board those two
knights are eyeing a jump on the F6 look
at the evalar is Maxim about to get
checkmated I was going to say I think
there's really one decision here and
it's when will black resign because and
look at this position a knight is about
to land on F6 there's nothing black can
do about it and it's not even just a
pece sacrifice that's unclear you could
even take back with a pawn instead of
going for checkmate and win that Bishop
on C5 so there is nothing wrong with
White's position it's a clean attack
that black king it's devastated it's
hunted and it's going to tip over it
feels like Magnus has been inspired by
Wesley so checkmating him almost in the
last game going for this kind of uh
flash attack just uh he's gone straight
for this black king now and for example
I mean there's no obvious moves here for
black if you just move a Pawn okay he
plays Bishop to A3 instead but same idea
I think you just land in a knight right
now uh maybe this concept you mentioned
Robert check if the black king moves you
can just take this uh Pawn come in with
your queen this is going to be
disastrous if you take the Knight you
pretty much have to take the Knight then
uh I think multiple ways to win this the
one you mentioned taking with a pawn
attacking the black queen forcing The
Black Queen to stay on this diagonal to
protect her Bishop but now the White
Knight can just come in threatening
Checkmate I mean this is just fatal Pawn
to H6 now you deflect the black queen
and uh she moves Checkmate incoming on
G7 H7 everything it's over yeah Magnus
has this incredible ability to just come
back from a devastating game with little
turnaround time we've seen him make
these comeback wins with his back
against the wall he lost to Wesley Stow
in a game that just felt so one-sided
then comes back plays maim Vash lrav uh
and what is this move number 18
completely winning Knight F6 is a killer
killer threat on the board um maximan
big trouble has he made the move Bishop
A3 he did Bishop A3 Magnus Carlson if he
goes Knight F6 it's game over and he's
going to do it yeah he for sure will do
it but I think what David said earlier
is true that sometimes when you lose a
game when you're not playing your best
that's when you're shaking your
confidence is no longer there but when
your opponent just crushes you like that
I think Magnus just respects Wesley I
really believe that's what happens so
he's not actually that deflated he's
like well done Wesley so he's impressed
and he's also impressing Us in this game
because this is a miniature over yeah I
loved magnus's interview with Danny
yesterday where he was like we're not
done let's talk about those predictions
you only motivated me if anything and I
think that loss to Wesley in the
previous game the first uh the first
kind of blemish on his scoreboard in
this tournament I think it's really
woken Magnus up even pushed him to
higher levels and checkmates incoming
Queen to B4 this won't change anything
at all um White's queen that pawn and F6
count to an attacker and the White
Knight joining in very shortly um
Maxim's just playing on praying for a
miracle but Magnus after a bit of
calculation will land that killer blow
and just to just to understand how do
you finish it so the Knight comes in
you're threatening a mate on 87 the only
way that Maxim has is to run mag Magnus
is showing us the way I think we can
just sit back and enjoy the beauty of
Magnus gon's chess he's not even
material down and we see a handshake
Maxim resigns miniature you called it
Robert brutal victory for Magnus gson
just what he needed after his loss
against Wesley so wraps it up and just
20 moves against the 2021 World Blitz
Champion Magnus Carlson once again on
fire and the ire break that we were
talking about it has arrived it's on the
board 86 is still an option which would
force Fabiano Carana to actually
sacrifice he's got to go all in now
we're going to see this and this is a
very forcing sequence where the White
Queen gets in there the black king tries
to escape and this isn't that simple I
don't see The Knockout just yet and for
Fabby the good news is he has four and a
half minutes but that black king only
has the bishop next to it it's the only
piece defending it it looks scary though
Magnus get out of the way of the camera
we want to see Fabiano that is the back
of the world number one and Rook
D3 wow he's playing for tactics there
was a trick there I think he was uh
playing for it but now black pieces are
kind of adopting these defensive posts
these defensive positions and no
breakthrough you need to land a check
but that Rook lift maybe mistimed and
Nakamura apologized for something there
not sure what that was he was just like
oh whoops uh but it looks like he's
defending he's still a piece up as well
Fab is all in right now he needs to back
up this attack and Fabby played that
move so quickly he barely paused before
The Rook lift and it was clear that
there was something more immediate more
direct in that position perhaps David
you can show us what was it that Fabby
missed I think he should have simply
backed up his Knight and prevented what
happened in the game Knight to F4 uh
would not allow Bishop to H6 for example
because a check would be deadly and
Black's Bishop would drop if if Rook to
G8 in this position uh then he would
have had various tempting options
including a check and maybe just moving
the queen out the way I'm not sure
exactly where but uh maybe dropping her
back for example a knight to G6 would
have been deadly uh in the near future
this is difficult to see so we can
forgive Fabby for not spotting it but
Rook to D3 was based on a nasty trap he
was hoping for Bishop to H6 and this
would have been a beautiful knockout
punch Knight to f8 check throwing the
Knight off the board with gain of time
uh because you're next Landing a queen
on G6 and this would have shortly end it
in Checkmate so he was playing for this
trick Fabiano but the problem is when
you play for tricks sometimes you miss
the opponent's resources and Rook to G8
suddenly there's no checks suddenly no
way to break through and uh pressure's
on and Bishop h86 is now a threat on the
board because the G6 square is defended
so dislodging that White Queen would put
breaks to Fabiano's attack and he goes
into a long think a minute and a half
burn the clocks are leveling out does
Hikaru sense his chances now he is a new
lease on life in this position I still
think it looks good for white because
Bishop H6 it may help save the black
king it doesn't actually threaten
anything and Fabby decides to liquid it
I'm very surprised by that decision
because I didn't see a next move for
Hikaru but we are about to see Hikaru
trade Queens the Knight Will Fork pretty
much all of Black's pieces but we'll get
two Bishops for a rook in a few pawns
it's anybody's game yeah suddenly it's
just I mean it's a crazy really
irrational position look at this black
has a massive threat of Rook takes G2
check the port in front of White's King
is undefended Fabiano has to try and
deflect that Rook he takes this one it's
important to take the correct piece
there and uh as you say Robert after
Rook takes Knight which I'm expecting
right now there we see on the board two
Bishops and it's very strong Bishops as
well who cares about the number of Pawns
White's pawns aren't breaking through
anytime soon it's anyone's game it's two
pawns for those two Bishops and until
they get rolling it's hard to imagine
Fabby having any chances here can he
start thinking about trying to dislodge
that Bishop from the center Bishop on E5
Bishop on C6 somehow try to get F4 in
that would be the dream to try to Target
the E6 Pawn Yeah he has to try I think
that would uh be the kind of final stage
of these next Maneuvers but the problem
is it might be hard to achieve anytime
you push pawns forward the white king
might come under some fire Black's Rook
will come back to the G file most likely
and just sit there and White's King
feels a bit uneasy um yeah I'm suddenly
favoring black maybe you just throw it
on the board anyway you go F4 and you
try to trade off as many pawns as you
can because to me it looks like Fabby
needs to now think about bailing out
trying to neutralize Black's pressure
and he does it yeah because if this game
goes on the way it has been then Fabby
was more likely to lose than win he
doesn't really have any winning chances
so I'm with you take this P6 get rid of
as much material as possible make sure
your king doesn't get hunted and I do
think that he should be able to hold
this but Hikaru we know how dangerous he
can be when both players have minimal
time on the clock yeah impressive from
hararo I've got to say just ice cold
defense there uh tough start to the game
the opening really was uh suboptimal but
ever since he's played uh he's played
great really resourceful chess and
Fabiano I've got to say F4 was also
commendable just Switching gears he knew
he was winning Fabiano he was on the
attack trying to Checkmate suddenly he's
on the back foot trying to defend trying
to hold this one uh but he's found the
right move so far but another threat to
deal with how do you hold your G2
Pawn there are two moves that I see you
either come back with your rook and get
all passive but what I would also be
thinking about is offering a rook trade
on the G line yes I give up one more
Pawn but I'm just trying to get closer
to the draw here he does it the engine
it's going down in Black's favor only
Hikaru has winning chances here he's got
two Bishops for a rook and just one Pawn
so that point value would seem about
level but the difference between these
Bishops and The Rook is clear The Rook
can Attack One Pawn try to but those
Bishops both defend and the white pawns
are seriously weak at this stage to be
really careful if you're fobby one thing
I'm going to note is the A1 Square is a
dark Square so if Fabby can trade his
Rook for that dark Square Bishop that
can increase his drawing chances if he
can trade off his C4 Pawn for the D6
Pawn Yeah that's instructive Robert
already thinking about how to save this
game long term because you can save it
move by move just survive survive
survive hold everything together or you
can con conceptually uh look for these
saving resources and in the meantime
he's just trying to harass Black's light
Square Bishop the A6 Pawn is really weak
for black uh so a good idea there still
feels closer to a draw than uh a win but
it is very much a two result game white
has zero winning chances here some
practical decisions there by Fab Fabiano
Karana in trying to hold this game he
gives up pawns but he wants to try and
trade off as many as possible and to
your point Hikaru is okay giving up the
a pawn but wants to keep the Central
Pawn alive that is his winning chance
once he starts moving up the board with
the D pawn it will give him way more
chances than the Aon so that's a
beneficial trade for black and what
Fabiano needs to do right now is make
sure his King and Rook team up on a
square so that even if that pawn keeps
pushing you sacrifice your Rook for that
pawn and a bishop because a lone bishop
and King cannot deliver checkm that's
what Fab's aiming for he is down under a
minute he also has Pawns of his own that
he can start pushing forward with but
he's first he moves his King forward
takes away squares from black and he's
holding nicely how confident do you
think Fabby is of this hold right now
not that confident but he is a yeah he
is a player who will calculate his way
uh he most likely um will be able to
just hold this I mentioned move by move
just as long as you avoid blundering it
should be fine but always in the back of
your mind especially when the momentum
has changed and you were winning earlier
there's a bit of doubt and uh black is
ready to start pushing that deep hor
yeah wow and now under 40 seconds for
Fabiano Carana who despite those two
passes on either flanks is actually the
one who is on the defense in this one
right now you see the clock Fabby he
continues to think he should as soon as
he sees a draw ail don't blend your Rook
here if that Bishop slides back one
square delivers a check and hits the
rook in the corner so Fabby he needs to
make sure his Rook is on a safe square
and he needs to keep his King away from
those Bishop's checks yeah he's reaching
for his Rook Fabiano took the hand back
a bit of indecision there but he does
eventually move it to a safe Square just
keep them on opposite diagonals just as
far away as possible from each other the
king and Rook maybe one King on a light
Square Rook on a dark Square something
like that so you avoid blundering into
any double attacks but uh he's doing the
right thing White's pawns should be
enough of a distraction here check
always a good idea just probe kind of
find out the uh intentions of the
opponent's
king G has to show some incredible
technique here to create chances he also
has to be a little careful of the gon
moving forward because white king is so
close to the central passer D2 not
possible anymore at least Hikaru can
start giving checks now you put your
check on C5 he does it if the king moves
back to D2 give another check from B4 he
does it King goes back now if he pushes
the pawn your idea of The Rook sliding
behind the king giving a check
immediately pick up the D2 Pawn that
would end the game on the spot and that
maybe what hiar should do right now
because if he keeps playing on white has
this Advanced G Pawn of his own it's not
that far away from promoting so Hikaru
needs to be careful he's down under a
minute himself I think he's just take
the draw get white pieces in game two it
reminds me of that one draw that he did
not take against Wesley so in game one
where he could have repeated the
position bailed out immediately uh he
played for more and it backfired if
Hikaru plays d do it is a draw on the
spot he pushes the pawn a check by
Fabiano Carana give up the rook and I
think he's going to go for it because I
also don't see an alternative here David
yeah it would be a logical conclusion to
this game the draw here push a pawn
white gives up The Rook for um that dewn
and a bishop and you can see he's coming
to terms with it himself he knows
there's no realistic uh way of kind of
pushing this game further he's reaching
vo Bishop second time we've seen this
position he could just repeat as well
give a couple of checks and uh a draw
imminent any second now there we see it
Nakamura under 10 seconds he needs to
take the draw Bank it and move on to the
next one that's it and he repeats oh he
doesn't wow that is brave Bishop D6 he's
allowing the white Pawn to push wow and
aaru also had that expression that he's
just resigning himself to the draw what
is happening here do you see his face
though after the pawn push he's like
what is happening what am I doing when
he's getting in time trouble he hasn't
been his usual self and look at him he's
trying to bounce back he's trying to
dance to whatever music's in his head
but that g Pawn is very dangerous and if
you play Bishop E5 check that rook and
sacrifice oh he's pushing his own pawn
and now we will see this draw that we've
been talking about as play Fizzles out
he's still has to be slightly careful he
played that move with two seconds and a
head shake can can white actually just
push the G7 Pawn he can but he'll put
his Bishop back with Sheck and that's
why the King goes over here now Rook
takes D2 will be a draw it is a draw
indeed
and finally it does happen and Hikaru
relieved after that draw he tried for
more but Fabiano just keeps it all under
hold and Hikaru seems to not be able to
believe what's happening in his game
right now how how these chances are
slipping and he's got to be relieved
that in the end there was a draw
meanwhile Oliva fuja and Dennis lavic
also ends in a draw but we've got one
game remaining and this one it's a bit
of a race a rook is going to sacrifice
itself for the black pawn black
sacrifices itself for the other Pawn
we're going to have a king versus King
and this one ends in a draw as well wow
peaceful result in this one but uh yeah
it's been anything but peaceful this
round Magnus with the quick win and uh
the other games eventually fizzling out
some really high class end game play
there still some ups and downs and uh a
lot to play for in this second game of
the round Maxim VRA has to catch up with
Magnus Carlson that was quite a
miniature nbec Abdu satro Wes liso ends
in a draw a peaceful end to a long
marathon and of course the Fight
Continues and I think for notc also he
can be pleased with this he's playing
against the player who's just taken down
Magnus Carlson Wesley hasn't lost a
single match he's undefeated not a back
starting with a draw a good result no he
had the white pieces no he is not afraid
of anybody so he drew that game with the
white pieces we see two other draws
Magnus the only winner of the round but
I'm going to circle Dennis lasic drawing
with black that's a big result for him a
big result for Magnus Carlson who took
down Maxim bashra with the white pieces
needs only a draw in the next run and
we've got Ka with Magnus
Carlson brutal comeback there from
Magnus Carlson how relieved are you that
you do come back with a win after what
happened with Wesley uh yeah I me the
job is not done but it feels good to to
win and besides my games so far I've
been kind of uh very dull and Technical
so it was uh really good to get um you
know proper attacking attacking win yeah
how much of what happened against Wesley
decided the way you entered uh this game
against Mel uh no nothing uh but um I
mean I didn't have like extremely uh
aggressive intentions I was just playing
and then the way it happened he just
allowed me to to Checkmate him basically
so uh um you know uh yeah he was just
shaking his head in disbelief afterwards
cuz he uh he really didn't play so well
but um I'll I'll take it of course um
it's it's a much needed uh win is brutal
the right way to describe this game uh
yeah I think um he made a mistake early
on um by playing Bishop D6 allowing me
to get the setup with the with a strong
Knight on E5 and um after that I'm sure
he has better options but um um I think
psychologically he already felt that he
was in he was in big trouble so next
game is it more the same or is that more
about being solid I haven't thought
about it yet but um you
know yeah we we'll see um finding it
hard to be completely solid so so um
we'll see all right well thanks for the
brutal entertainment Magnus good luck in
next one thank you all right it's a
comeback from Magnus Carlson one game to
go against
maim Magnus Carlson with a proper attack
and a brutal finish David what impressed
you the most about that game well it was
just how Magnus seized the opportunity
he pounced and out of the blue came this
checkmating attack it was emphatic in
the end but let's show how he built it
up and crowned it it was here we were
talking about white having an advantage
in multiple ways we were thinking mostly
strategically but he went straight
forward the black king he sensed that
the black king doesn't have too many
defensive pieces around it and he
started throwing pawns forward first a
pawn storm it kicked away Black's main
Defender the only real defender of the
black king and now another Knight jumped
in and this is the final mistake from
FAS legra he needed to trade off pieces
get rid of the attacking ammunition
instead retreating a poor decision back
with his Knight and now Queen out and
the Knight dropping back simply one
Knight is coming in combined with the
queen that will be a deadly Duo and no
way to survive if we fast forward to the
current and to the final position sorry
the queen did eventually break through
Black's King is powerless and Checkmate
was imminent and it was just Magnus
showcasing his versatility in the
pre-tournament interviews when asked
about style he said um Universal I
prefer technical he's showing that he
can also play a beautiful tactical game
he crushed Maxim that one yeah he got to
deliver that Checkmate on the board a
beautiful miniature the only decisive
game of game one of round six
we' of course got a big game two coming
up and Maxim VRA has to make his
comeback against the world number one he
has to win on Demand with the white
pieces that solid game is not coming up
between these two but there's more chess
coming subscribers stay with us with
some special footage just for
[Music]
you
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things and then we have ma B he did beat
you in the Grand Final in the most
recent tournament so yeah not only um
did he beat me he actually beat me in
consecutive matches um
that seems that he's sort of regained
his confidence which is really good to
see he'll be like top three tough
opponent for sure uh I really like Max I
like his chess he has like clear
weaknesses and strengths but his
strengths are are things that he does
better than anyone else he was my
teammate in European Championship we
cannot really tell each other everything
but we try to be as much as friend as
possible very Dynamic player very T
Tactical tactically
and you never get boring positions
against him I I think he's changed his
openings and he seems to have a little
bit of momentum behind him in the last
few events so I think he's a he's sort
of a bit of a wild card if he plays well
he's a very dangerous player if he
doesn't it could be a short event for
him but um again I think the form will
matter a
[Music]
lot
that music is just the chill we need to
all the crazy action that we've been
watching so that check out that playlist
uh the chess.com Loi playlist that we've
got on for you and if you need more
incentive to watch chess then all you
got to do is watch 4 hours and you
unlock 2 weeks of free Diamond
membership on chess.com watch 4 hours of
Chess enjoy the game and grow the game
by getting your free 14 days of diamond
me membership all you got got to do is
go on god.com SLC connect and we are
heading back to beautiful Toronto and
we're heading back to some beautiful
chess as game two of round six is about
to begin in this stunning stunning City
and we are being treated to some
stunning chest right now the one player
who's got to make it back is Maxim vagra
he starts with the white pieces how does
he create his chances he's proven he can
come back storm back against Magnus
Carlson he did not just once but twice
at the AI cup that's the reason he's
here today so Maxim he knows that he can
do it but I think Magnus might have
learned a lesson or two and won't let
him Magnus was happy with the way things
went in that game and who wouldn't be
exactly Magnus was thrilled he did joke
that he doesn't know how to play solid
or he hasn't been able to keep things
solid so I'm expecting Magnus to try and
fight fire with fire in this one and
Maxim it can't get much worse that last
game was uh yeah not his finest moment
so I am expecting him to bring a better
uh showing now and uh yeah who knows he
might be able to bounce back it was
three solid results on the other three
boards are we expecting more Armageddon
coming up oh we definitely will have
more Armageddon Dennis lazic has the
white pieces he doesn't really lose with
white and he's taking on Ali Rea fua I
do think that one at a minimum will head
Armageddon wow Ali Rea fuja Dennis laik
both need a win to stay in the race to
make it to the survival stage of the
champ Chester finals and it is Dennis
lavic who arrives first and meticulously
adjusting his pieces there he's got the
nights turn sideways it's always
interesting to see how the players want
to play but it's one night on the side
and one facing forward W I'm yeah I must
admit every chess player has their
ritual but this is making me a bit
anxious uh the way he's placed his
Knights here uh also the Bishops facing
back towards himself with the The
Bishop's uh slits there facing himself
that looks odd I must admit maybe it's
bushka the cats you know the way that
bushka enjoys the pieces so let's just
do it for bushka and uh ala he's got
that red hot hoodie on he's got to play
some Red Hot chess as well but he starts
with the black pieces will lazic get his
solid structures or will ala be able to
be creative the other very creative
player is Maxim VRA uh we are expecting
him to start with the Kings spawn
opening that's what he usually employs
is Magnus going to try to shut it down
with a potential Berlin o ma Maxim is
known as a Berlin killer though he often
goes straight for the end game and he
has so many ideas there his feel for
those end games is extremely strong I've
lost to Maxi myself in the Berlin more
than once uh so it's not going to be
easy Magnus has been employing the
Sicilian Defense we saw it in that
Armageddon against Wesley even though
just he just needed a draw he's been
playing ambitiously and he's clearly
choosing his opening now Magnus Carson I
was just about to say that these early
early moments just before the start of
the round what is going on in them I
what do you think they're thinking about
is it the opening are they still
thinking about the last game it depends
on the player it depends on the
performance because for Magnus he was
choosing his opening for Hikaru there
was disgust at the previous game for
nirc it's like why are all these cameras
on me can you leave me alone for a
second stop talking about me but look at
these two they've been in great form and
I'm going to be interested to see how
aggressive Wesley is with the white
pieces because he has nothing really to
lose he's five out of five he's sailing
through the semis no matter what the one
player everyone's been talking about is
Wesley so he has uh taken down Magnus
Carlson in the round robin stage he's
looking confident and what's always
amazing about wesle is how he downplays
his own play yeah at this point I think
it might just be a ploy throw us off
throw the opponents off take the
pressure off himself Wesley he's uh too
modest if anything and no one's buying
it yeah nobody's buying it anymore
especially after that game against
Magnus Carlson he is bang in form in
Toronto pretty much on home territory at
this point it feels like and uh yeah I
would love to see him approach this game
the same way he has been approaching his
white games throughout the event but he
may seem Invincible but if there's
anybody that can take him down and is
narbeck and I'm realizing now that with
two match wins and if Wesley loses
against nck in tomorrow that n can catch
him so Fabiano is another player who can
catch Wesley if Wesley is to lose this
match and the next but Fabby just like
Wesley is feeling quite good about his
chances to move on to the survival stage
but who is not is the player who's not
on the screen yet and we see him walking
in Hikaru Nakamura after a roller
coaster for game one could have gone
either way eventually ended in a draw in
that end game where perhaps Hikaru was
pushing just a little bit and now he has
to push all out he goes with the white
pieces and uh we're going to have the
moves the openings in just a few seconds
it's clock time it's go time it's the
queen Pawn opening it's the queen Pawn
opening and uh just backstage here at
the studio I heard a cheer from some
Gran from others I think they might be
having bets on first moves and wow the
Arbiters had to step in here is not
happy I think the clocks there might
have been a bit of a malfunction a bit
of a uh false start there uh shout out
to Judi our Arbiter who's sorting out
those Tech issues and now we're off and
now we're really off one D4 Fabby to
play and he brings out the Knight okay
and a trpovski attack yet again from
Nakamura he was playing this throughout
the first day or two
of the Champions chest finals but it
won't be a surprise now for the first
time I just thought about this these two
will square off in the candit tournament
several months from now so it's kind of
awkward where you want to beat them in
this match but you also want to save
some of your killer preparation for that
tournament which decides who gets to
play dingly Ren for the world
championship so there is that Dynamic at
play here and for hiar makes even more
sense that he keeps playing these
offbeat lines I don't really expect him
to play them in classical chess yeah I
think we'd all be shocked if Hikaru
started experimenting with the trpovski
uh in an event like the candidates
Fabiano meanwhile has sacrificed a pawn
Black's structure has been slightly
compromised as well after that trade
Bishop for Knight we saw this position
yesterday with Nakamura playing this
slow move A3 how much homework has
Fabiano done uh in the evenings after
the games has he prepared this position
he pushes his Pawn just one square I
think we saw Pawn to E5 as well earlier
in the event and some quick moves as uh
Nakamura he had this against vasher lra
if I remember correctly uh he gives back
the pawn but now he will land a check
with his Bishop oh no this time with the
queen so a new move for the event
forcing the Black Knight back level
material Bishop to B5 he's playing
actively to compensate the fact that
White's Double T pawns are extremely
weak long term this looks very strange
to me I trust Hikaru in these situations
but when I look at this susp like how
could black be worse but that's where
deep preparation comes in handy and I'm
looking at that Queen on A4 because it
can go from this side all the way over
to the king side and if that black king
thinks it's going to be safe castling uh
in that direction well think again you
might not even get there so white
lacking development Black's kings in the
center as well both sides with the
compromised Pawn structure I would think
that black should be doing well in
Fabiano he's responding quite quickly I
think he knows that he's doing just
fine and as Hikaru thinks about how
continue after the developing move by
Fabby we will jump back to Magnus
Carlson here and Maxim VRA again just
reminding everyone he has to win this
game to take it into Armageddon and
that's said when this position crops up
the first thing that we would notice is
that white has actually provoked black
to push the B Pawn all the way to B4 and
that leaves a really really juicy post
on C4 for the Knight to land on and I
personally love that for white to just
have this longterm spot hot on C4 you
could land with your queen there which
could be a big threat the Knight can
come there find itself to arrive on the
central squares D5 F5 wire E3 it's not
much but I think Maxim should be pleased
with the opening outcome yeah uh Maxim
this is his bread and butter he's been
an expert in the Royal Lopez the Spanish
opening which this has stemmed from uh
he's been an expert his entire career U
so he knows where to put the pieces that
square you mentioned has just been
occupied Tanya By the Light squared
Bishop also reminding black that the A6
porn is a bit weak if you touch it maybe
more weaknesses uh strategically white
is on top but black dynamically is doing
okay here it's still a very well-known
position as far as I'm aware still
opening Theory so it might depend on
who's done uh the better home cooking
here who's researched this position
better and in the past there was some
homework done for Magnus Carlson by
Maxim V lrav in a previous world
championship match there was a very
funny opening and people like where did
that come from how did mags learned that
and they looked at the database and it
was a game from Maxim V gra but this
game it reminds me of a famous Magnus
win against leavon Ronan he only needed
a draw in the sinkfield cup and instead
of just agreeing to a draw he won with
the black pieces in this variation uh
there were some subtle differences but
it seems like Magnus he feels at home in
this kind of line it is uh the anti-
Marshal I believe that has been played
by Maxim Vel gra uh and perhaps if
you've got a moment we can show everyone
what uh that is and how and where this
stems from the position that we're
talking about and the preparation that
Robert was refering to yeah so uh this
current position uh roughly level but
maybe we slightly prefer white due to a
nice Outpost that this white light
Square Bishop sits on but to show how we
got here let's backtrack just a few
moves uh where in this position one of
the uh main positions of the Spanish
opening black Castle's kingside and that
is a big hint it's a big clue that black
is actually going to break out in the
center if white for example plays Pawn
to C3 one of the most popular moose then
the Marshall Gambit uh stems from Pawn
to D5 and uh I've had this against
Magnus myself this year even uh he's a
big proponent of this one he's played it
in World Championship matches yes it's a
pawn sacrifice white can take on E5 but
there's a lot of theory attached and
black is known to be doing uh pretty
well Black's in good shape theoretically
so uh why go for such forcing lines when
you can play a slower type of position
normally a good idea keeping tension in
a mwin situation like Maxim is in here
PA A4 is the uh anti- Marshal avoiding
that Gambit due to the pressure on the a
file uh White NOW threatening to capture
on B5 m magnus's favorite move in recent
times has been to shuffle with his Rook
to B8 but instead playing B4 as Robert
mentioned he's done this before and uh
after the pawns get traded off in the
center we see as we catch up uh this
position and a new move uh or at least
uh since we were last here night to A5
attacking this bishop I don't think
white wants to part with a pride and joy
anytime you play the Spanish opening the
Italian game any E4 uh E5 openings you
never want to let your light squared
Bishop be traded off so I'm expecting it
to take a step back and retrieve
in one of these two directions um an
interesting move there from Magnus he's
just fighting for squares I like it he's
not allowing white to get a clamp on all
the light squares over there on the
queen side so I think is a very good
choice from him he's somebody familiar
with the intricacies of this variation
so Maxim he is kind of deep in thought
for the first time in this game but he
knows that he does not really want to
give up that Bishop y it will Retreat
most likely in this direction I feel
just to keep some uh pressure here maybe
you want to push a pawn kind of activate
this poor piece that's still fast asleep
on C1 and uh yeah the game will go on it
will become about maneuvering who
controls the squares better who uh kind
of finds better post for their pieces
but um yeah good start I think promising
start for Vash gra to this game early
stages Maxim taking his first fix H so
perhaps a new move there by Magnus
jumping with that Knight to A5 making
sure that white spawn still stays on A4
and can't move forward really clumping
down that A6 weakness that we were ref
referring to earlier and now Maxim
having his thing does he keep the bishop
there allow the trade or does he fall
back with the bishop this is the only
game where a decisive result is required
while the other games did end in a draw
and we will go on to Wesley so playing
with the white pieces Who currently is
also in the think and once again uh the
last move we can see by nbec who pushed
the pawn defending the B5 pawn and
decisions here required by Wesley when
it comes to pawn structures and those
are critical moments structural changes
do you keep the tension on the queen
side or what I would prefer to push the
a pawn all the way to A5 and the reason
for that is not particularly space but I
just want to stop the black knight from
D7 to bouncing up to B6 and bouncing up
further to C4 uh I like this position
for white white has got these long-term
plans slide The Rook from F1 to C1 start
targeting the C6 Pawn the knight from F3
can fall back to E1 to D3 just feels
that White's Knights are finding itself
easier to to learn land on the outposts
while Black's Knight doesn't have enough
squares and also one last idea I want to
point out the bishop and the queen can
actually line up on the light squares on
the b187 diagonal start to provoke more
weaknesses on the king side I think
Wesley's done well out of the opening in
this one yeah this is the infamous cbad
structure um I can tell you've played it
a few times yourself T bit of an expert
there and it did stem from a Queen's
Gambit declined um it comes from various
openings and just to backtrack just a
few moves and to show how we got the
structure um white in this position
played Pawn to B4 we sometimes refer
this uh to this as a minority attack
black has more pawns on this flank but
White's Duo here the A and B pawns
aiming to clamp down or create
weaknesses or isolate pawns and uh if we
catch up with the current position
castling and a big decision Pawn to B5
looks like it's uh yeah I mean looks
like it's going to backfire for this
bishop this is the worst piece by mile
but it's more about fixing the structure
and Wesley does he go for the move you
mentioned no I'm really surprised he
didn't play A5 taking away the Square
from the Black Knight slowing down
Black's play instead Bishop to D3 uh
sorry in this position and what is the
idea Knight to B6 is coming in yeah I
think that he just wants to keep his
options open because if he plays A5
there is no Pawn breaks over on the
queen side it gives black play a free
Freer hand I should say over on the king
side yeah interesting decision and for
example if white does push forward the
question would be if black jumps in to
take or not to take is the Knight strong
enough to part with a beautiful Bishop
for um really interesting position again
this is all strategic it's very few
forcing lines very few tricks tactics
but uh yeah it's just again about who
understands this structure better and uh
Wesley he's spent a bit of time maybe
abdor of he's saying I don't want you to
Checkmate me like you almost did to
Magnus I'm going to make this a far
slower type of game yeah it's a it's a
different approach from the one that I
was discussing with pushing the Aon but
I still feel that this gives nbec
chances to actually activate his pieces
that Bishop could have come to D3 one
move later but you just take away a key
activating Square from black that B6
Square so Wesley deciding to actually
keep the tension on the queen side a
potential long-term opening up of the
aile always in the cards uh but A5 just
seemed like a more chill move and
speaking about chill moves there's also
been a lot of chill music that you guys
have been listening to on our stream at
the start at the end and it is the very
cool ch.com Loi girl playlist that's
been on and we've got some big news for
you guys because you can get your self a
sign signed by the Champions chestar
winner uh a Loi girl vyl for yourself by
entering our giveaway and it's all on
the information is all on our social
media channels so definitely check that
out for all the chill music and this
position has no chill suddenly because
the Aon did move forward a move later
forcing the Knight to jump to C4 and we
see a big break in the center we will
come back to this to see the decisions
that nck takes but meanwhile Hikaru
Nakamura deep in to wow A lot has
happened in this game yeah this one has
evolved and I'm not sure who it favors
if we look at the evaluation bar we Peak
uh we cheat we see its level but in
terms of ease of play I think I would
pick white um it feels like the black
kings slightly more loose Queen and
Knight often do Thrive against Queen and
Bishop Black's B7 Pawn a bit weak that
being said feels like Fabiano has enough
control here um what do you make of the
uh the position the body language rob it
yeah I do agree with you that it should
be easier to play for white because a
bishop is inherently limited to its own
color complex that Knight could take it
all the way to the king side to a score
like H5 we could be telling a different
tune but here in this position not
enough pieces of remaining I think that
with uh just Five Pawns per side one
Rook a minor piece and a queen it it
looks like both players they know that
the draw is relatively near but aaru he
looks focused he looks like he really
wants to push yeah he will want to push
uh I'm not sure what Fabiano should be
doing here if Queens come off I think
that would favor Black it would remove
pretty much all of the danger of having
a weak King I was going to say if Rooks
come off it's unclear maybe that would
favor white if anything minor pieces
coming off would favor white because he
has the safer King and Nakamura widens
his eyes slightly as the bishop drops
back I must admit this was not on my
radar at all it looks like you've only
exposed the black king to checks uh to
these checks along the G line and uh
maybe no kind of concrete way of taking
advantage of that but slightly negative
decision taken by Fabiana he just wants
to eliminate white cwn but that didn't
look like the top priority no but
liquidation is the name of the game for
Fabby he just wants to secure that half
Point send this to Armageddon and he's
aiming directly at that C5 Pawn I'm With
You the King looks more exposed if that
Rook on B1 were just a bit more active
we would be talking about an attack
against the black king but for now it's
just a queen the queen cannot Checkmate
A King by itself in a position like this
so I do think the Fab has everything
under control and uh Hikaru does put his
Rook on an open file hitting thin air
for now but a bit of a threat of lifting
The Rook up to A7 seventh rank seventh
heaven uh lots of targets there and uh
the big question is can Fabiano take
this white porn that he's been looking
at I would be a bit scared but that is
the first one to look at first we always
looks look at the checks captures and
threats first and hikara saying do it
take me please and uh okay maybe we show
the reason Hikaru is so relaxed in his
chair right now he's saying okay after
Rook to A1 trying to come into A7
attacking this weakness Bishop takes
Pawn would be met by a simple capture
and uh I guess he's going to take this
Pawn rather than the B7 Pawn I don't
think um well both of them are weak both
are going to drop off but I don't think
he actually cares too much about B7 it's
more about the weakness of the black
king and Robert you mentioned one idea
of getting this Rook into the attack
later you can't do it now but later
maybe a rook lift uh the one of the
themes of the tournament and a black
king severely exposed right now uh so I
I would hesitate I must admit from
Bishop takes Pawn but Fabiano he knows
better than me what else can he
play that is the big question and he
answers it he is going for the trade
that you pointed out and Hikaru
immediately snatches the bishop are we
going to see him pick up the F4 pawn and
Black's King safety that is the only
thing if white can bring the Rook into
the attack that would give some serious
serious chances to Hikaru but it doesn't
look like it's going to be so easy
especially with the black queen on C5
controlling the A3 Square are we
expecting uh that armagedon is the most
likely in this position well hikaro has
his lips pursed a bit I think he's
looking for a winning chance and you see
the evaluation bar going up right the
exposed black king you look at the pawn
structure in front of each person's King
white has those three pawns the standard
Pawns in front of it you got your moat
in front of your castle and for black
there's no G Pawn so there will be some
checks this is a big moment where if
Hikaru wants to win he should keep those
Queens on the board
it's a big decision for Hikaru Nakamura
right now he will make his intentions
clear if he trades the queens that means
he's ready for the fight in the
Armageddon if he keeps them on the board
Hikaru wants more in the rapid meanwhile
Maxim has only one shot he has to keep
the game going uh there is no Armageddon
if this one ends in a draw so for maxim
he has to find his Advantage the one
thing that I do not is in this position
David is that with the Rook on C1 and
the tension between the C3 and the B4
pawn it looks like long term White's
going to have the better Pond structure
once the C file opens up there is
pressure along and a C7 weakness is that
going to give something to Maxim to play
for definitely uh it looks like a
serious long-term Advantage here for
maxim Vash gra I must admit I'm more
used to seeing Magnus on the white side
of these positions where he's squeezing
his opponents taking the long-term
advantages and turning them into
something bigger later on um let's just
highlight that uh that kind of theme you
mentioned Tanya because it's just
weaknesses for black weak pornno SE D7
weak Pawn on A6 right now B4 is being
undermined and uh beautiful piece the
best piece by far in this position is
this Knight Magnus meanwhile going for
uh White pawns if he had traded off
instead then the White Knight would
simply move out the way this is an
isolated pawn and will likely drop off
in the next few turns uh so instead he
does Counterattack against B3 and uh now
two ways to defend this either you play
Pawn takes Pawn or you maybe move your
knight to the edge of the board threaten
a sneaky Fork I mean I still like white
I must admit it's a pawn sacrifice
though because if white does take the
pawn on B4 Magnus actually can't take
back if he does take back then the
sneaky Knight A5 it not only threatens
that fork on C6 it just directly puts
pressure on the Knight on C5 so either
you lose your knight or you are going to
lose this Rook because of the Knight
Fork so Magnus sacrifices a pawn after
Pawn digs B4 that must mean he's going
go Knight E6 and I would not have had
the courage to sacrifice a pawn like
this and mag says why not my Knight's
going go to F4 that pawn on B4 is a
goner anyway I really like this plan for
Magnus wow that is really creative uh
that shows deep vision from Magnus
Carson just giving up a pawn it still
looks scary after Knight to A5 coming in
but you simply protect this square and
uh suddenly this Black Knight is
beautiful on E6 you've gained time to
control the weakness and as you said
Robert maybe comeing towards the white
king later on given the opportunity it's
actually impossible to hold this Pawn
which is attacked twice so uh you're
liquidating you're simplifying into a
holdable position still looks pretty
nice for but uh Magnus in control enough
there to hold the balance Knight A5
therefore maybe immediately but Maxim
maybe frustrated maybe he missed this
one I certainly would have missed it
myself KN C5 Big Move great move and
take on B4 so 96 very quickly played
there by Magnus and for maxim he might
be looking this with yeah some confusion
I just won a pawn I have an open C file
my pieces are good but Magnus he's doing
enough to hold everything together and
that B4 Pawn it should not be long for
the board this is an amazing way to hold
a balance for Magnus agreed Robert but I
think also credit to Maxim right just
the way that he's created his chances
he's got that extra Pawn right now the
C7 weakness and you're talking about
black SNS jumping Maxim's also got
threats of his own so when you've got to
fight for a win against a player like
Magnus this is the most that you can
hope for from an opening the problem is
it's the most you can hope for and you
look at the eval bar and it's very
little to uh my eyes I have four of them
I wear glasses you look at this well
white must be better such active pieces
and the engine just laughs and says well
Magnus Carlson played it I'm approving
of it Robert you're wrong and hey Magnus
is right so you're right that as well
that Maxim has played a great opening a
great start to this game now what where
does he play for the win from here and
so much is on the line for maxim and
some of the other players who are
fighting it out with only two rounds
remaining of the round robin six players
will make it to the next stage of the
Champions Chester final the survival
stage and two will be at eliminated and
we are being joined by Danny to talk
about all the different scenarios and
who's facing the danger Danny tell us
who makes it who doesn't what do you
think is going to
happen yeah I'm going to do my best to
work through all the possible scenarios
here and talk a little bit about the
math and the stats you guys are doing a
great job describing the drama on the
board so here's what I can tell you is
if Wesley wins not only does he make it
to the semi-finals he's guaranteed first
pick he is the top seed if Magnus wins
he's guaranteed a spot in the
semi-finals if both those things happen
we know who the top two seeds are but
make no mistake Hikaru lavic oi Resa
peruja and MBL all basically have equal
chances at this point to go home but I
think one of the biggest storylines to
talk about is the fact that Hikaru plays
lavic tomorrow neither of them want to
still be on one point when that match
happens and fuia gets Magnus tomorrow so
if anyone maybe needs to win now more
than ever it might be Ali Resa fuia so
I'll take whatever questions you have if
I missed an angle you think but um you
guys are doing an incredible job drama
on the board and that's the drama off
the board I hope everyone's on the edge
of their seat Well Danny you're there
live do you think the players are aware
of all this of course they know their
next pairing but do you think they're
aware of how they're jockeying for
position compared to people who may be
in the same score
group I think at this point all four of
the players in bottom know that
borderline win or go home at this point
I would doubt that either of them or any
of the four I mentioned really
understand the full Stakes or or
scenarios um I don't believe that
anyone's fate is fully secured even if
they lose here because of the
awkwardness of the fact that two of them
play each other tomorrow of course in
hikaro and lavic fuia playing Magnus so
I think because of that they're probably
in that that typical athletes mindset of
focus on what you can control now but
I'm sure that they're that they're aware
that it's um it's big trouble right now
and Danny the two players who can kind
of feel safe is Wesley and Magnus right
now now if they finish in top two yes
they've made it through to the
semi-finals but there's still a little
difference in finishing first and second
talk to us about that what is at stake
when you finish first is there an
advantage what
happens yeah the the person who finishes
first gets to pick their opponent based
on what happens in the survival stage so
at this point I don't know that you're
um you know really thrilled with whoever
you're picking so I don't really know
what the advantage is there in fact I'll
even be honest that we heard some behind
the scenes from the players all the top
seats have been given white at every one
of these round robin matches I've heard
feedback that the players don't even
necessarily feel like that was an
advantage in fact maybe some top seeds
in the future would rather have the
right to choose their color just being
transparent about feedback we get from
the players who knows maybe that'll be
something we change in the future so
it's hard when you have eight of the
world's best players to really say
there's an advantage of other than you
pretty much have to win every match you
play but I think from a confidence
perspective knowing who Wesley is and
knowing that when he's in that zone he
seems to be on another level so I feel
like it matters more that Wesley holds
on and wins this match against Notre
Beck and takes that top seed than it
even does to
Magnus all right Danny well we'll uh
we'll keep checking in with you on the
updates because this is really the most
important critical moment here for the
round robin stages and this game could
mean so much like you said for alira as
well if alza wins it is Big pressure on
Hikaru Nakamura though Hikaru does play
against Dennis lazic tomorrow on paper
Hikaru will be a big favorite but for
alza he'll play Magnus Golson tomorrow
and it's a fight between alza tnis and
Hikaru right now who have a one match
Victory and two of them will be
eliminated so everything to play for
here and this one is an end game a
critical game for these two who does
this end game favor I like White's
position but I like Black's clock this
is not an easy end game the evaluation
bar is slightly in White's favor I do
prefer Dennis's chances because black
has those Double B pawns those can
become a Target and White's controlling
some of the pawn breaks on the king side
watch out for a capture on F5 at the
right moment or the bishop capturing
that Knight on C4 the pawn on B2 it's
hanging but you're opening up the B file
a rook will slide over and that could be
dangerous so I do like Dennis's position
I think he's controlling both sides of
the board and I'm still thinking about
what Danny just mentioned about all the
qualification spots and right now
Hikaru oh something very big has just
happened I'm just going to and it slides
back but Hikaru fuja and Dennis at the
bottom of the table is there a scenario
that two out of these three players
actually make it a survival stage it's
possible I think it's all possible at
this point but uh it would very much
depend on uh the tie breaks then it
would be head-to heads it would be uh
other things that are out of the players
hands in order to keep their fate in
their own hands right now their destiny
they need to Simply win this game these
two especially for f who plays Magnus
tomorrow yeah I think that's the most
important thing right now for Ali Resa
he plays Magnus he has to get the full
point in this one and it looks like
Dennis has kept everything under control
are we likely to go into an Armageddon
because then it's just chaotic it's just
anyone's uh match then I still like
Dennis's position here I mean the way
he's been playing he sacrificed a Pawn
on B2 to open up a file you lose a pawn
you open a file The Rook slides behind
that Knight is aiming through it all the
way down to the black pwn on B6 I really
am looking at this with an eye that
Dennis is better and maybe he can
actually outplay Ali reaa who's much
higher rated but in some trouble and
we've seen Dennis SC some big points
against the players here the underdog if
you love The Underdog Story then the
player playing with white he's been very
impressive the 17-year-old Dennis laic
we will I did see the evaluation bar
there it did a big jump on the Wesley so
B nbec Abdu satro what magic has nbec
created here with the black pieces his
Queen is hanging but that H4 Pawn which
actually hits the queen can be picked up
yeah I think he was just slightly
careless Wesley so in what was earlier a
risk-free position or almost risk-free
he was even a porn up Suddenly he's lost
control the black queen black Rook black
Bishop all pointing towards this white
king and okay he's had to throw a pawn
back I'm fighting the urge to sneeze
right now but Pawn to H4 and we got you
David thank you White Knight has found a
safe square but it feels again almost
like that Nakamura game earlier where
abdar had all these kind of sacrifices
these attacking ideas feels like
something is brewing but he just rushed
that decision because that pawn on H4
give me that thank you for the material
but he actually didn't have to take it
right away I saw the evalar go right
back towards the center which gave me
the clue I needed because I would have
stolen a pawn as well just a move ago
instead of going Queen takes H4
apparently Queen F4 must be better
because the Knight instead of jumping
back to E3 Central Square to challenge
that lovely Bishop on D5 it has to get a
bit more passive F2 or H2 H2 is an ugly
Square so F2 it is and now H4 is hanging
that Rook on E6 has an open line to the
E2 square or E3 as you're highlighting
it looks like this would have given
black some good chances it's such a
human move to just uh capture a free
Pawn close to your opponent's king and
he does it and sometimes the most
natural moves are not the best ones yeah
the problem for Abdu zorov now is that
Wesley is going to be able to trade off
this Bishop that beautiful Bishop on an
outpost which was controlling both sides
of the board and once that Bishop
disappears Bo captured I think he should
be safe in the end game what black
simply will not be able to whip up and
attack with only a queen and Rook
combined the problem is for example if
you drop back this end game is likely to
end in a draw white will just put a rook
on C1 actually they're following this uh
route play and uh White will sooner
rather than later be able to trade off
Queens head into a drawish rook end game
Wesley survived the worst a bit of a
storm there he did let things slide but
Nock unable to take advantage and you
made that video on nck in his end games
I actually think he needs to be a bit
careful here if those Queens come off
white does have an advantage with some
Advanced pawns on the queen side black
may have to be a bit passive I do think
it should be a draw but you say should
and Rapid chess and then they laugh at
you because when you get low on time
that's when the mistakes
happen yes and uh this one level but uh
other action happening elsewhere big
action happening uh especially on the
Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano board and we've
been talking about this with Danny as
well and the possible scenarios Hikaru
currently in a queen Pawn end game he's
got an extra Pawn on the board if the
Queens get traded the King's Pawn inning
is completely winning for white here and
Hikaru for his uh his path to the next
stage of the Champions Chester final
this is so critical he converts this one
yeah he needs to grind this out the good
thing is he can play Forever literally
forever you play 49 moves with a queen
then you push a pawn you play 49 more
moves you push a pawn Black's problem is
that the F5 Pawn is so weak if you put
Black's F5 Pawn back on F7 I think it's
a pretty straightforward draw uh no real
way to make progress but uh White can
combine some checks maybe pushing the H
Pawn forward to add an extra attacking
piece uh with threats against that uh
that weakling on F5 it's one of these
positions that I wonder when you are the
number two rated player in the world
challenging for a world championship
title do you study end games just like
this I believe the answer is yes whether
you remember them that's something
completely different but Fabiano he
centralized his Queen he needs to make
sure he doesn't drop a second pawn and
then the question for hikaro is what
pawns can you actually trade you trade
too much then even a queen TR at the end
may result in a drawn King and pawn end
game so we have seen a check the Eva bar
is actually quite close to uh the center
which means that black should with
optimal play hold the things about the
thing about these positions is that even
if there's no direct path for Hikaru to
force a tradeoff of the Queens uh or a
clear plan of improvement it's just so
much harder as black to defend because
you have to keep watching out for these
threats and Hikaru is not only playing
against uh blacks forces on the board
but even Fab's time he's down to less
than a minute and a half on the clock a
huge three minute advantage to to Hikaru
right now I think that's exactly what he
needs I think aaru is going to convert
this one playing on the clock always
eyeing those Queen trades one pair of
one set of Pawns gets traded off but the
F Pawn can start marching down at some
point I must say I'm shocked by hikaru's
decision I think an inform Hikaru would
have maybe refrained from touching this
uh G Pawn he's traded off the weakness
that I highlighted suddenly Black's
Queen is perfectly poised as well he's
banking on some tricks here maybe to
force the Queens off or I'm not sure
quite what he's trying to do but he has
created a past F Pawn this was the idea
to evict the black queen and start
pushing forward but it feels rushed now
it's easier less material uh Black's
task has been uh yeah eased here and at
some point not now black could consider
playing the move H5 and initiating a
pawn trade because without those pawns
with just a queen for black and then
Queen and pawn for white with the black
king sitting where it is there's no
winning chance there so if H and G pawns
are off the board this should be a draw
but that's why hikaro needs to keep more
pawns on the board and I share your
surprise that he decided to play G4 that
early is it time to now push the F Pawn
as well with the check on the board go
F4 that was the idea for Hikaru but he
reaches for the king he's going up right
now H5 is not that easy to achieve
because there's a check on
E8 yeah Fabian is doing the right thing
though he doesn't even need to touch any
pawns he can just threaten to come
behind black queen threatening to come
into the corner to H1 deliver some nasty
uh checks he's just trying to harass
this white king and uh I think he's
actually a favorite to hold despite
having only one minute on the clock
because Black's moves are relatively
straightforward as long as you don't
blunder it's going to be hard for white
to make progress some of these end games
even without a black H Pawn are often
drawn uh so this one still a long long
way to go I think we'll see an over 100
move game here w so you're saying a Hold
by Fabby what about you I was initially
saying a hold but I'm looking at Fab's
invest all the time right now and that
would make me believe in a car's chances
because Fab's down to 45 seconds this is
actually going to be a tricky end game I
do believe he can hold it but he needs
to make a move in the near future we are
predicting an over a 100 move game in
this one I think Hikaru is going to
grind this one out it's so hard to
defend this with 40 seconds on the clock
the queen jumping around potential
trades with a check coming in uh we're
going to keep an eye on this one on that
game but meanwhile Maxim VRA he's down
upon and he needs a win that ain't
happening bad news for Maxine Vash de
gra for French fans here because this is
one-sided it might end in a draw there's
not that much material left but it's
very much Maxim trying to fight for that
result trying to save his himself here
Magnus has done a great job he's
eradicated all risk Queens off oh really
sad retreating move there and uh at the
very least Magnus can trade a set of
Rooks push the pawn to E3 trade
everything off a draw is the very
minimum does ma Magnus only have 5
seconds left though like he really got
low on time at that moment the good
thing is it's such an easy play for
black you can make a draw whenever you
want so Magnus you know he will secure
this match victory yeah and uh we see
another set of Pawns being traded off
Magnus up a pawn the only thing he
shouldn't get flagged or make a blunder
uh on second especially there's a knight
so you've got to be you've got to watch
CH for checks there's always a good
advice keep your king and Rook as far
away from each other as possible to not
walk into a fork that's what he's doing
here Tanya good advice good practical
wisdom there uh the problem now for
black is that white can give a flurry of
checks white has protected everything
his own porn Max's not even trying David
a draw and that's it he repeats the
moves and Magnus Carlson takes it in the
rapid no Armageddon in this
one and we will go back back to Hikaru
Nakamura against Fabiano Karana if it
ends in a draw we go into Armageddon but
right now Hikaru pushing for the win and
Gucci Raza definitely in front of the
camera that's a red sweatshirt if I've
ever seen one Ali Raza he managed to
draw against Dennis lazuk but he was in
some serious trouble this position it
looks like it's trouble for Fabby those
pawns are storming forward but the
engine is not caring it says it's equal
and the reason why is the white king is
very exposed it's hard to leave that
King it's going to be susceptible to so
many checks from the black queen that's
some grandm level chess analysis I just
feel for most of us seeing those two
pawns move down the board Fabby with 35
seconds on the clock the king's moving
forward still practically unless it's a
draw on the spot and White's King can't
hide I think aaru will have a real
chance but can he actually save himself
from all the checks that are coming in
immediately well David you know how to
grind like a grand master do you know
how to defend like one here oh that is
tough sometimes groaning out the half
point is the hardest thing and no more
checks no more checks black needs to go
passive now you need to just make make
sure there's no knockout white is
threatening to come in with some checks
push some pawns I like it centralization
in Queen end games always good wisdom
and uh again the threat the ghost of
this idea bringing the black queen into
the corner with some checks I think it's
just going to stop Nakamura making any
real progress um I have looked at a lot
of Queen end games I still realize that
uh the more I look at them the more I
realize there's more to know it's just
impossible to make generalizations but
uh Fabiano he's done everything right so
far he's kept his King as safe as
possible centralized his looking for
counterplay looking for checks still
pressure on Hikaru to actually do
something to break through it's another
example how a lone Queen can't deliver a
Checkmate because you can give a check
with the White Queen but you also need a
pawn but as soon as you push your Pawn
that gives the black king some squares
to run to for example the pawn pushes
now the black king will step up and
there are no more checks available to
White so this looks like a hold from
Fabiano Carana and yeah you see that
Hikaru he's just moving his King back
and forth o I actually think they've
repeated the position po potentially a
third time but uh I'm not 100% sure
clearly Fabiano isn't sure because he
did not claim anything there and uh
Hikaru still unable to make progress
this is a nice move pinning White's F
Pawn still so tough to actually make
progress to do anything substantial to
POS problems to Fabiano it's as if
hikaru's just done everything he's moved
his pawns All the Way Forward uh and
it's maximum maximum that he can achieve
with the white pieces he keeps the game
going but Fabby just playing confidently
where he does fall under the 202 Mark
now a little hesitancy there by Fabby
and he falls back with the Kings so the
position is changing a little bit right
now that was a great move by Fabiano
because with that White Queen on e4 Pawn
F6 check would also hit the black Pawn
on H7 so a really nice Retreat for him
not allowing any sort of discovered
check well a check wasn't discovered but
it would be discovered attack against
the pawn H7 and you see that hiar is
doing everything he can Fabby fending
him off perfectly yeah white has
centralization now but that doesn't
count for too much as long as the black
Queen's able to deliver some checks the
white king would love to somehow Advance
up the board but it will always get
kicked back and okay first iaru is going
to test Fabiano here still low on time
actually both now low on time under the
one minute Mark and all the checks in
the world and you can pick up on 87
let's just point that out because of a
check on H2 so that was never possible
it just looks like Fabby has just been
so resilient and just finding these
confident moves with the queen knows
where to place his King his Queen the
coordination it's amazing defense I
think most of us would have fallen by
now and I think Fabiano yesterday would
have fallen he it was not his best day
he was not in great form but today is a
new day he won his earlier match against
Hikaru he hasn't played perfectly he's
made some slip UPS especially
considering the advantage he had in game
one but there has not been a mistake
since we've been in this queen and two
versus queen and one end game yeah
exhaling there Hikaru slight Shake of
the head he knows that he's not making
any progress he knows this is still a
draw objectively he's unable to land any
tricks and and the white king is just so
bare that uh eventually some checks will
start to turn things around okay he
brings the White Queen to a passive
Square defend or does he still hand on
his Queen indecision he doesn't even
know where his Queen was that's the
problem he didn't know where his Queen
was so then he gave a check CU it
obviously wasn't in that square but AAR
giving this check we've seen this
position before I'm not sure how many
times and oh F's trying to make a claim
Fabby does make a claim and hikaru's got
seven seconds on the clock and Hikaru
Fabby says that if he moves the king
back to f8 this position has happened
three times that's Fab's claim and I'm
just doing a quick check here it's
happened once twice o I'm not so sure I
think it might just be twice the White
Queen has checked from
B7 and only on A7 twice as far as I can
see and we can let everybody in on a
conversation that we had just yesterday
we're talking about making a claim is so
tricky because if your claim is proven
incorrect your opponent actually gets
more time now and maybe in this position
Fabio is not so worried that the extra
time will help hikaro much because he
knows he has what should be a drawn
position and it does give Fabio time to
sit and think and breathe a little bit
it does with that extra minute I think
hikaro would be happy to get that extra
minute if the claim is rejected and
David you're telling us that it looks
like it hasn't happened twice I think
it's twice I think it's only two times
and uh wow this is a really tense Moment
The Arbiter will be the Arbiter will be
checking just like I'm doing my head has
gone a bit fuzzy it's been a long day a
lot of games a lot of moves but I can
only see this position twice with the
White Queen on A7 and we've already
confirmed ourselves two armagedon as
nbec wesle so go into one and it will
also be between ala and Dennis lazowick
is this going to be the third Armageddon
the Orbiter comes in Hikaru steps out to
check to confirm I think Hikaru wants to
play onar does want to play on it will
only be the second time for those you
unfamiliar with some of the rules of
Chess if the same position is reached
three times then the game ends in a draw
so the Arbiter is ruling right now that
this is not the third time the position
has happened as David did mention and
it's happened twice but what what
happens when he makes a claim that he
wrong uh you get two minutes oh it's not
one minute he gets two extra minutes on
the clock Nakamura with more
time yeah and actually we were talking
Robert about fabiana's track record two
of
course of course so this is
one this is two right yeah yeah it's
it's two two times
two only twice David you were right
about that and the Orbiter confirms the
wrong wrong claim Hikaru Nakamura gets
awarded two extra minutes Fabby has to
fight this out and keep it together the
position is a draw he's been doing
everything right but do you think this
claim and the rejection can that throw
you off psychologically it certainly can
because now hikaro gets more time while
they're talking about this I would also
ask what move number was the last Pawn
push because for Fabiano there are two
options to make a draw either there's a
three-time repetition which didn't just
happened or there are 50 moves made
without a piece capture or a pawn push
and I think we're about 20 moves into
that cycle hikaro plenty of time to
think and try to give Fabiano the
biggest challenge ahead yeah you're
right Robert the last pawn p P the last
capture or Pawn push was move 57 so the
magical number is 107 if the move
counter ticks to 107 and white hasn't
pushed the pawn or made a capture the
game will be drawn if Faby claims which
he might be reluctant to do now and uh I
was saying to you just yesterday
actually Fabiano in a queen end game
against me exactly 10 years ago uh
actually in December 2013 as well this
is a bit odd uh he also falsely claimed
after only twice um so he's got a bit of
a mixed record there how did that end uh
it was a draw I was
I was two pawns up and uh yeah he
managed to save it but uh this one
tricky Queen end game and now he will be
2 minutes down this it's going to be
tough and it's still a far way off to
reach the 50 move Rule and I think
they're still waiting for the obiter to
come and adjust the clocks uh before
they start making a move Hikaru
meanwhile does give a check so we are
off but she needs to add two minutes to
hi car and they might have already been
added 2 minutes added of course we'll
keep everyone updated with the clocks
but
Fabiano he knows that this should be a
draw he doesn't need an engine he
doesn't need an evaluation bar or a
table base he is going to make this draw
if he finds every single best move which
he seems capable of and it was confirmed
that the time was added Hikaru Nakamura
with those extra two minutes and they
continue to play so the queen comes back
to H3 and David what's going on que H3
he's allowing some checks this is a bit
odd it feels uh really strange this set
up for white but I think the idea is to
push the king up on the H file the white
king going up to H5 H6 um he's just
trying to guard against checks from
behind but why break the formation
Fabiano doesn't need to do anything
special King to G7 a nice solid move
there and Hikaru sooner or later he'll
have to push the F Pawn he just needs to
figure out the right moment but that
problem with pushing the F Pawn it
always gives the king that forward
Square so what Fabiano is doing very
intelligently he's taking away a queen
check once that pawn pushes so now the
pawn push the king steps up the White
Queen can't check the king so he's
keeping everything under control keeping
checks in the his Queen's eyes and well
that's why Hikaru he want to give a
check for himself he paused he's not
sure where to go and those extra two
minutes have disappeared Hikaru now
reaching the 22nd Mark no progress has
been made yeah nothing at all uh the
position is barely changed and you can
sense the frustration we even heard the
frustration there from Hikaru simply no
way to break what is pretty much a
fortress an Alp for black and queen back
to
H3 the black king can come back where it
came from you can give some checks I
think Fabian is holding this one calmly
perfectly he's even moving his King
right like that was not necessary I
would have been tempted to move my queen
but he's trying to make sure that the
white king can't march forward and wow
that was a slap of the clock hikaru's
got nine seconds now he goes forward
with the King he's tried everything what
a defense by Fabiano yeah Perfect
Defense he's done everything right he
centralized The Black Queen that's the
main thing and no way forward I think
we'll see a handshake soon as Hikaru
tries one or two final more moves don't
trade no way to avoid the checks no way
to run yeah nowhere to hide anymore and
Hikaru with a shake of his head
reflecting the position on the board
Fabiano with a fantastic save and he
really kept his cool despite the whole
Fiasco of the rejection of the claim y
just uh great nerves there from fab not
flinched uh yeah he's just and now we
see the handshake he's just defended
superbly superb defense which means
three armag Gs one more time as this one
also goes down to the wire Hikaru tried
to push it till the very end but Fabby
on top of his game keeping it together
really the the key of the whole end game
was an active Queen in the center for
Fabby delivering the needed checks and
for hikaro we see he's upset as the
players are there writing their times
down he did play a pretty complete game
he was never winning so for hikaro he
should feel a little bit better about
that game than some of his other if you
put it with unless you're putting 15
minutes there's no
point we are waiting for them to write
down their Armageddon bids and also
Circle the color that they'd like to go
for with the winning
bcle yeah unless you're super prepared
there are some rules being discussed and
there we see now Fabby is standing up
writing his
bit three three Armageddon coming up
next the action just doesn't stop I have
a feeling David we've been calling uh
calling the Champions Chester from the
start these are the most number of
Armageddon that we've seen happen by far
uh throughout the season we've had
longer matches maybe four games uh being
the norm where
there's nice to hear the players
laughing
now did they see each other's bids did
they make the same bid yeah same number
same number number I think they went 959
how do you bid 959 and both of them get
959 oh my God and they've got a bid
again always bid 58 that's the key but
then you know you think your opponent's
going to do that so you should be 57 and
keep going lower but I am curious to see
what the new bids will be what are the
what are the chances of them getting it
the same bid twice I'm not a
mathematician I don't know how to do
those odds very very very very very low
jud's checking that they're at least
different bids good we are good sounds
good you just I Haven done it with yeah
R meet uh meet M there and I'll be
following you right there okay thank you
oh wow the bids have been accepted by
our Arbiter and we will be revealing
them soon what a round this was as hiar
Nakamura Fabby there getting a bit of a
stretch in after that long Marathon game
they are getting ready for their
Armageddon and that means we've got
three
coming up uh as Magnus Carlson is the
only player who took it in the rapid
taking down Maxim VRA with that first
game win and a second comfortable draw
the other three go into fighting
fighting Armageddon and we will be
revealing the bids David what was the
standout moment for you from this round
yeah in a round in a round of all draws
I have to pick out the one which I feel
should maybe not have been a draw and it
was young Dennis lazic against Alara fua
the two tail Enders both needing to win
this match to keep their hopes alive of
staying in the tournament and Dennis
lazovic I feel agreed a draw prematurely
in this final position white has
fantastic chances of grinding out a
victory it's a two- result game white
has no risk white has a better structure
because Black's isolated porn here is a
big Target Black's Rooks as well very
passive and for example putting a bishop
on B4 bringing it into C5 maybe later
repurposing REM maneuvering this night
would have given him a big bind and
great chances Alara fua sneaking in a
draw offer I don't think lazic should
have accepted I don't blame the players
when it's within the rules it's within
your right but I say don't allow draw
offers never ban the draw offer I've
said it so many times now we would have
seen a conclusion to that game that
perhaps made more sense well that one
goes down to armagon the only one that
didn't saw Magnus Carlson win a stunning
miniature in game one against Maxim VRA
Kaa caught up with Magnus after his win
here with Magnus Carlson ready for
semi-finals so first of all how does
that feel yeah it feels reallyy good um
obviously I knew even after I lost the
match to Wesley that I still had about
four chances to to get to the semi-final
uh but it's h yeah it feels really good
to have taken this chance today was a um
was a tough day uh I could feel from the
start that I wasn't really I wasn't
really on it to today I was just feeling
sluggish so um yeah to get through this
day is feels really good five out of six
matches one is also is also good so now
I'll uh play tomorrow um play one match
without much pressure and then I'll get
some U get some rest the rest of the day
and enjoy the enjoy the other guys
fighting it out yeah tomorrow we will
have a a short day tomorrow so do you
think that is a big Advantage heading
into some intense days
I think it's a slight Advantage
um but um yeah I mean probably not too
big a deal but it always feels it always
feels good to um not go into the last
round with
um um with a lot of pressure you will
have sort of something to say in terms
of who's knocked out tomorrow you play
ala fua who is fighting for his life in
the tournament what can he expect when
he plays you tomorrow uh no I'm as I
said I'll I'll play uh without too much
pressure I'll probably need a lot of
help as well to get uh to get
first um so yeah let's um let's see but
um yeah I
mean like I'm not going to I'm not going
to focus too much on the tournament
situations situation obviously you know
there are people that I consider more
dangerous than others that I that might
want to uh to knock out but it's it's
not going to it's not going to be on my
mind and in terms of choosing semi-final
opponent uh how much does it matter to
be first to be second and to be able to
well at least be second in in your
choice there um yeah I mean it's it's
good to be second but as second you
don't really get the choice
um but um no no
I would say that yeah after after I lost
the match to Wesley like all those
thoughts are kind of out the window
obviously it's a slight advantage to be
able to to choose uh but now that I know
that I most likely won't have that
opportunity and that's also fine now mag
we've been and especially you have been
looking at the drama happening with
Hikaru and Fabby they're still playing
so there wasn't uh the repetition there
yeah
um it's typically quite a risk-free
strategy to claim a draw in such
situations cuz your opponent gets more
time and you get a little bit time to to
calm down and and um think about the
position uh so yeah it's a bit of a I
think he thought it was a draw so I
don't think he it's um it was any
trickery involved but um it it's uh yeah
it's it the way the rules are is just a
good strategy um and I think he will he
will hold it Karo also obviously
fighting for his life in the tournament
would you be disappointed to see him
knocked out
no all right Magnus thank you
congratulations on a great day thank you
thank you for joining us back to you
guys and these are the stats after his
fantastic win against Maxim V look at
that that accuracy 97% almost and uh
what a game that was and we also see
some brilliancies there by Magnus
Carlson what stands out to you the most
uh from those stats par for the course
from Magnus Carlson he keeps 96.6%
accuracy he's been like that throughout
the tournament I know he lost to Wesley
so earlier today but that was because of
Wesley's Brilliance not because of mag's
blunders yeah Magnus it feels like he's
working up the gears he's traditionally
known as a slow starter but he's burst
out other traps in this tournament and I
mean he's looking like more of a
favorite than ever right now yeah what a
game that was and Magnus also said that
he's not going to be too disappointed to
see hikaru's early exit well Hikaru is
going to be fighting out in the armagen
a very critical one and that's not the
only one there's also of course Wesley
and nbec playing and we've got uh Kaa
with the players revealing their
bids ah Wesley peeking again it's going
to be armag get on drama coming up so
we're going to reveal the bids for these
two players go ahead you guys turn your
boards I'm going to peek this way first
10 is that 0 10 z0 okay and we have let
me see Wesley a so sneaky 928 that means
you're 38 938 that's need glasses
definitely means you're going to play
with the black pieces you hard to take
away 10
seconds that's very important is
important so what is the what is the
thought behind this bit well I thought I
saw n BS been bidding almost always over
10 minutes so I was pretty confident I'd
win with 938 but it's not clear whether
it's better to be white or black so it's
going to be like I call not break Fast
and Furious oh the Fast and the Furious
with the white pieces are you happy with
how this turned
out okay I would like I would love to
have more time like more lower but
okay that's what what it is so yeah
we'll see awesome awesome that you guys
are are uh did I a Tai one one um you
know what I have uh been in this
interview so I don't know did they D the
first game because they do the second
game okay so there also another so there
there's another armagon coming up well
you guys go get ready best of luck and
thank you for doing your bids here thank
you thank You Ah that's Wesley and Order
Beck coming up back to you
guys there where be another Armageddon
coming up uh and of course uh Wesley so
with the black pieces he starts with 9
minutes and 38 seconds he's got his eyes
out on the Ali Resa match as well really
fun to see them revealing their bids and
their mind games and if you want to have
some fun doing up your house decorating
your walls we've got some brilliant
ideas for you check out these very very
cool lightweight metal displates they
are awesome I've been told to hang up on
your walls they look really cool my
favorite one is the duck chess Roberts
picked up his favorite and there's a
very cool
33% discount uh going on on them and
this one is prob we will show it next
time but right now we've got armag gens
coming up and of course these two will
be fighting it out as well Ali Resa
versus Dennis lavic we will reveal their
bids once we're back with all the action
on the other
[Music]
side we are ready for the CCT finals in
Toronto here with one of the big
favorites Hikaru Nakamura so everything
taken into account these eight fantastic
players that we have here at the format
what are the fans in for this week uh I
think they're in for exciting chess I
think uh there there a couple players
who everyone's uh looking to see how how
they they play Magnus myself Fabby MBL
and Wesley I think are I I would say one
of the five of us should win the event
um if I'm being honest I think it's
going to be very exciting probably a lot
of very close matches most importantly
and um I think another thing is
everyone's so used to seeing us play
online and playing over the board it
should make for a very different
experience and what would it mean to you
hiard to be the winner of the Champions
chess tour 2023 I mean it would be it'
be nice to win I think um it would mean
more probably than say last year when I
came fairly close I losing to Wesley in
the semi simply because I feel like the
field is A Little Bit Stronger this year
um so it' mean quite a bit but at the
end of the day I'll just try to play
good chess and and see what happens now
if we do have some new FS watching I
could ask you to describe your playing
style rapid and Rapid chess and
classical chess are a little bit
different than Blitz uh I think the main
thing that probably be strange to fans
who have watched a lot of my online
streams is that the openings I play
online are are vastly different in in 30
Blitz than they are in Rapid chest and
so I think for people who are watching
they might be a little bit surprised to
see me playing a little bit differently
in terms of style in terms of style that
that I have um but you know I'll just
try to do my best and hopefully uh
hopefully good things happen and
hopefully the fans enjoy the show
awesome well you we wish you best of
luck here in the CCT finals thank you
for being here thank
you Fabiano caruana started his journey
from division 2 and his climb through
the ranks has been formidable winning
division 2 in the air things Masters
qualified him for division 1 in the
chesal Masters where he beat Hikaru
Nakamura on the way to his first of two
back-to-back Grand finals Fabiano can
lose this game he's a pawn up 10 seconds
David yeah two pawns up wow but a
horrible Pawn structure yeah but it's
all about the white DN if he keeps the
central porn alive he
might oh my God you said they a blunder
shate and one and hiar immediately does
you commentator's curse a one Checkmate
and that is going to cause Hikaru the
whole match there we go does it
immediately he finds it there is no
square for the queen they have to be
traded off and he jumps in with the
Knight but it's too late the C3 Pawn is
super strong and this black pawn is
going to completely paralyze the white
pieces and I think he's had enough he
winsa is the winner of the cheser
Masters Fabiano Karana resigns Queen D2
is that the winning move and that's it
we have a winner not a be ABD wins the
chess kid cup but playing division one
in another two events has banked him a
to of 325 tour points to secure second
place on the standings and a
well-deserved ticket to
Toronto a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
chess at displate.com
[Music]
and we are back the action is happening
in Toronto and what action we have been
treated to including three big armag
guts coming up to wrap up today and it's
going to be a lot of fun we've had the
bids coming in from West and nbec and
now joining Kaa danis lazic and ala fuja
with their bids it's uh attention you
guys we're going to get to see the armag
get on bids between ala and Dennis so
you guys go ahead turn your boards
towards the camera 940 for
Dennis 9920 Aliva that means you will be
playing with the black pieces are you
happy with the result here yeah I mean
um either way it was going to be so um
I'm happy at least I won the beat yeah
um will be tough be tough it means it's
going to be must win for you with the
white pieces Dennis how do you feel
about
that the same as yesterday okay we'll
see we will see you guys armagedon
coming up best of luck and thanks for
placing your bits back to
you Den is so calm there 22nd bid win by
Ala fuja must-win match situation given
their tournament situ situation for
these two players and this is not the
only armag we've also got Hikaru and
Fabiano and we're going to reveal their
bids right now this will be super
excited the first bids were equal so
let's see what the second bids are you
guys turn your boards and we do have
909 and 952 that means black for you
Hikari what was the thought behind this
second bit well I get black every game
so let's see if I can do something okay
Bobby how do you feel about this yeah I
thought we would be closer on the second
so okay it's uh it's it's all right
we'll see see how it goes see how it
goes it will be exciting thank you for
joining us wow these Armageddon games
will be so exciting back to you
guys wow very different nerves there
with Hikaru Nakamura and Fabian Karana
and the games will be underway right now
Hikaru has the result odds Fabby has to
win and we've got the Sicilian I'm a bit
surprised because I did think that hiar
was in huge trouble the first time
around in this opening so Fabiano he's
probably happy that there's been a
repetition of opening lines wow and uh
hikara is the first to switch things up
we see a trade uh this is a really
well-known variation where black is
solid but has parted with the bishop
pair uh look at Whit's pieces all back
on the first rank uh Retreat town here
and uh wow the speed shows the
preparation levels but by both players
here but long-term Advantage for white
you have a pair of Bishops even though
you've retreated back to your starting
row those Bishops their power is going
to happen later in the game so I do
think that hikaro maybe he's playing a
little bit on his emotions he just wants
to forcefully get that draw get a win a
much deer win because t as you said the
survival stage he needs to win to get
there he really does such a critical
critical match for Hikaru and in his
interview with Ka while they were
revealing the bids he said I just end up
with black every time let's see if I can
win finally or not what do you make of
that he's choosing to get black he's
bidding some low numbers 909 their first
bid I believe was 959 so they had a tie
there and he went very low he clearly
woned the black pieces so he needs to
prove that he can hold the draw so he's
happy getting the result odds in this
one which puts the pressure on Fabby to
try and create something we see a lot of
Pawn trades happening which also open
UPS opens up uh sorry hikaru's Bishop on
G7 gives it a Target on the diagonal who
is uh who's more pleased out of this
opening outcome I think Fabi
Fabiano hasn't had to do anything
special you mentioned Tanya the onus in
a musn situation is normally on white to
try and maneuver to try and eventually
take risks break through attack but here
look at White's light squared Bishop you
mentioned Black's dark Square Bishop
White's Bishop there is uncontested it's
on a beautiful Outpost putting some
pressure on and uh also with this
massive time Advantage I think
everything great for Fabiano Carana
right now all right well he uh Fab's got
the kind of position he needs to try to
play for that must win result and
meanwhile this Armageddon is ready to
get underway and nbec shakes hands it's
go time what will be his first move he
decides to go with the Queen spawn
opening okay it's D4 and hesitation from
Wesley so and uh eventually Pawn to D5
we see a Queen's Gambit will it be
accepted yes it will and Wesley has
played this the highest level in
classical chess as well this is a tried
and true opening for Wesley he loves
these kind of closed position
solid positional battles but will Nock
be able to break free and try to play
for a win out of the three armor guns
that we've got going on these two are
probably the safest just relatively well
Wesley I think he's made it through nbec
with his couple of match wictor is also
looking good to go into survival stage
but it's really the the pressure has to
be on on the other two Armageddon it's
hanging by a thread in those ones yeah
and you can tell with the opening Choice
here Wesley so he knows he's banked it
he knows he's going to be in the
semi-finals he's happy to play solid and
put the pressure on Abdu satov who will
be feeling ambitious who still wants to
maybe maintain a small chance of
qualifying for the semi-finals if he
wins this one but um yeah either way as
you mentioned Tanya the stakes are
higher in the other games uh but two
informed players this one will be fun to
watch as well yeah let's remind everyone
the top two finishers after the round
robin go straight to the uh semi-finals
those who finish from third to 6th they
go into survival stage which will be
fought tomorrow uh to make it two will
only survive and two players tomorrow
will get eliminated and we see right now
those players fuja and lavic they're
facing each other right now in an
Armageddon so that's actually a huge
matchup to shake up the standings and we
look at the current standings right now
if if the round robin stage was to end
ala fuja Dennis lavic would be out
Hikaru and Maxim would make it up to the
survival stage right now nbec Abdus
satov in a good good position here at
number three looking safe in his fight
to survival stage yeah the good news for
Nakamura Fu and lazic is they are still
playing Armageddon right now fash gra in
fifth he's done for this round so people
will catch him he's not entirely safe
either let's check in with fuja and
disis lazic who's uh who are actually
playing against each other so really
quite the most important game to
determine the standings after this one
and give chances and hope to whoever
whoever makes it through white has made
the move Bishop C are wanting to get the
king to safety on the next one is there
a way that actually fuja can make sure
that white king doesn't get to see
safety there is a check on the board
Advantage lavic though because even if
you give a single check over there white
has a bishop pair and if I'm counting
correctly currently white is up a pawn
so Al is trying to figure out can I take
the Central Pawn on D4 do I throw in
this check which he has successfully
done and that B2 Pawn it's also one that
you can pick up but now it's like that
game where La was W against Fabiano he
has this Pawn in the center it's
isolated but it's a passer and I'm
looking at the evaluation bar right
there something dramatic has happened on
the fabbi board against Hikaru Nakamura
if Hikaru doesn't win his Armageddon
that will really jeopardize his chances
but right now Bishop trades on the board
in this one you want to try to
neutralize the bishop pair that white
has here any way for lavic to still keep
it on the board well at some point lvic
has to Castle before it's too late uh I
see two options two most tempting
options right now now one would be just
get the king to safety and kind of work
out the complications later yes it might
come at the cost of your extra porn but
it's more important to prioritize your
king safety not to take too much risk at
this early stage or the second option
keep your Pawn at least for now play a
move like Pawn to B3 allow the trade of
light squ Bishops on your own terms
maintain your material advantage but it
does feel risky from a human point of
view uh to keep your king in the center
too much longer as the forces start to
amass uh black ahead in development here
black ahead in development Dennis lazic
with the bishop air he's not the only
player who's got the bishop air going
for himself uh check this out Fabiano
Carana with the white pieces also
fighting for Advantage he's got the
control over the open B file the two
Bishops looking good the bishop on C2
defends the E4 Pawn the bishop on F4
targets the D6 Pawn meanwhile hikaru's
Bishop kind of staring at a brick wall
there is a threat on the C3 Pawn right
now but that can be easily guarded if
anyone's better here it's got to be
white it's always been Fabiano since the
opening stage he was given handed the
bishop pair early on that's the nature
of this opening he has that still but
that Bishop want C2 it's not the best
piece at the moment so while white has
some long-term potential there's also
some pressure into Black's position how
do you actually crash through that's
really the big question here and Fabiano
plays the quiet move to start he is 5
minutes ahead in the clock and that's
going to be really important okay Queen
to D2 the most natural move keep the
pace keep the status quo here if you're
white you have the pawn Center you have
the bishop air all of these things
should add up I'm hating Black's Knight
as well the Black Knight on d8 just
really stuck on the edge of the board
there but Nakamura at the moment has
everything covered and uh turning
transforming the advantage into small
kind of theoretical strategic things uh
turning that into something like a po
porn Advantage material advantage that's
going to be a big big challenge so
Nakamura for now relatively happy and
breaks out he's the one to actually uh
change the structure in the center kicks
back white Dart squared bishop and now
Retreats rotates his Knight um I still
love Fab's position I still like white
but it feels like he's a bit in
undecided about what to do next well I
think that Fabby should probably bring
his Rook forward I did at least when his
Queen was on D2 and his Rooks were
connected because I thought he could
double on the B file instead he's just
keeping the center fully under control
stepping out of a pin but that light
Square Bishop but doesn't really have
the brightest diagonal to work with so
hikaro he's I think defending quite
nicely and there is Big tension on the
center and at some point Fab will have
to take a call Hikaru keeping up the
speed he's under 6 minutes right now
doubled up on the a file so right now
The Rook on B1 can't move ahead cuz
Black's Rook will find itself on the
first rank uh attacks the C3 Pawn white
never really wants to close the center
with a move like D5 because that gives a
really nice post to the blacks uh Knight
to jump all the way to C5 yeah this
one's turning though and it's only in
nakamura's favor in the last half dozen
moves the last six seven moves black has
made huge strides blacks blocked the
center blacks got that knight from d8
that I mentioned uh to a beautiful
Square blacks doubled up Rooks on open
on an open file what's white done in the
meantime Fabiano's just just waited too
long and suddenly okay a trade of pieces
White's uh Bishop pair has gone its
opposite color Bishops this means black
is much safer than ever before Nakamura
he's working things in his favor one
player who's not safe at all is nbec
Abdus satra we saw the evalar go in in
wait whose favor Wesley's favor here
Wesley Wesley's got what's going on why
is Wesley so much better because he
looks like no dearbeck is playing what I
how I did as a kid and has dentist
described in the interview you play for
checkmate very early there is no
Checkmate black fended it off look at
White's Queen side completely
undeveloped and there's going to be a
problem down the sea line there's a
black Rook sitting there there are loose
pieces in fact Pawn takes D4 you would
hope for a tactical response for White
Queen takes D4 but this is actually not
going to work out because at the very
least Bishop takes H2 check King takes H
let's trade these Queens off the board
then I'll pick up your Bishop on C2
Black's up a pawn and all you need is a
draw but you're probably just winning
yeah just winning that is uh basically
the correct evaluation of this position
and uh Robert he starts with H5 equally
good um all of these I mean black has so
much choice you can drop a bishop back
just to pin this KN as well but uh just
simply Pawn takes paor unleashing an
attack loose pieces drop off as we keep
saying and this is a loose Bishop you
win a pawn it's not just that but how
does white even cling on
uh this bishop if you drop it back you
walk into a nasty double attack a uh
Knight Fork if you drop back the other
way maybe maybe you have to you keep the
game alive but okay we are seeing the
Game Change slightly but same theme it's
all about this loose piece black has
everything covered white it's down
material and uh in a world of pain yeah
was so his King is in the center but
everything else playing and Robert as
you and David just explained that this
position close to bust for white uh with
that Bishop on C2 hanging the pawn on E3
weak the Knight on G5 pinned there is no
attack anymore The Rook on A1 isn't
participating not backck in big big
trouble early on in the game it was
artificial right you just threw all your
pieces forward hoped you'd get an attack
and it was parried quite easily I might
add so Wesley his solid style is
actually perfect for Armageddon getting
the black pieces and he proved that when
he gets the white pieces well he can get
the job done as he did against Magnus
but not your backck I think he's bitten
off more than he can chew he's
backtracking now he's down a very
important pass pawn and yeah this looks
over already and you can see the lack of
coordination in white pieces you've got
the two Bishops on the first ranks the
Rooks don't have any open file the
Knight on G5 pin look at Wesley's
beautiful Pawn on D3 he's up material as
well uh and it just looks like it's
going from bad to worst nbec hopes to
put the Bishop from C1 to B2 to try and
get some activity here but it looks like
it's not going to be enough perhaps he
can also go Bishop F6 and just keep the
diagonal under control yeah Bishop F6
put a black Bishop on the beautiful C3
Square paralyzed the entire white Army
um yeah this is just a demonstration of
control Wesley so he's likely to go six
for six right now wow just bang in form
and Abdu satov he shot his shot just too
early unfortunately it's backfired so
quickly Armageddon there's so many
different strategies it's the hardest
thing in chess Armageddon uh but this is
the downfall by attacking too soon and
let's go back to to this Clash the
allamerican battle kowana wow suddenly
he's winning look at the clocks as well
Nakamura is down three four minutes and
wh's just pocketed a Pawn Yeah down upon
Pawn is hikaro he traded his Knight for
that dark Square Bishop but he ended up
losing a pawn in the process I thought
that was a risky decision and now we're
here white has pawns that can keep going
up the board Fabiano still with a
healthy lead on the clock and those are
connected pawns can you keep pushing
them pushing baby why not uh you can so
take Black's Pawn on C4 I guess go two
pawns up uh in the position yeah push
the D pawn it looks so wow what a classy
move even better from kowana block the
diagonal Black's only chance was a pin
The Black Queen White King on the same
diagonal block the diagonal and you're
ready to push again he's going for
checkm instead of pushing the D Pawn he
wants to push that E Pawn had that
diagonal been exposed Knight to D7 could
have created some threats but Knight D7
will now be met by that E5 Pawn pushing
up to E6 and the black king is in
horrible shape and look at at Hikaru I
mean he just cannot believe it not a
single match is really going his way he
got that one win over fuja but besides
that it's been all his opponents just
taking full points against him it's been
an absolute nightmare for Hikaru and it
does continue now Fabiano up two pawns
on the board those Central pawns
marching down the board E6 coming up D6
coming up if Hikaru goes down here I
really don't see him being able to make
uh a comeback into the survival stage he
does play lazic but he would need
results to go his way tomorrow I think
he needs Dennis lavic to win right now
so that when he beats Dennis lazic he
catches up and then he can get ahead of
Ali Raa so you need some other results
to go your way he's now trying to save
his game but also rooting for Dennis
lazic across the way and it's not only
the E Pawn that's moved forward both of
them are breaking through in Black's
position Fabiano Karana is in a form
Hikaru can believe it everything has
been a disaster yeah he's in cruise
control Fabiano and this one I mean it
wasn't just two porn Advantage it was
the most beautiful pawns you'll ever see
and Fabiano he's going for checkmate as
Robert says it feels like there's going
to be a killer blow any moment that
black king hiding in plain sight is
three pawns temporarily the advantage
white can just move the queen to any
safe Square Park it on E6 looking for
Queen sacrifices here to cash in and
mate ending style but uh Carana he's got
so much time I love that idea go in with
your queen to E6 but the F7 Pawn can be
picked up he does it and if Rook F7 I
think the Knight Chumps in as well
hikaro is almost giving up already you
can take Rook takes Pawn but the knight
from F3 lands on G5 or on E5 and one
more piece into the attack it will be
game over I'm imagining a smothered mate
put the white Bishop on B3 bring the
white knight to G5 go Queen G8 check
meate and uh okay he's bringing his
Knight in adding a piece uh adding extra
flavors to this party right now can't
stop it no that there might be a
smothered Checkmate and he stops the
Bishop from going to B3 or anyway yeah
you can't even take the bishop cuz Queen
F7 would be Checkmate this might be
smother Checkmate Queen G8 Knight takes
H7 and oh Bishop h8 the only way to
saave off the Checkmate threat but it
won't survive much longer black is
totally tied up black can barely move
and look at Hikaru he is so disappointed
right now just everything has gone wrong
for him from the start of this event
this is a crushing position Fabiano
Carana just has to put the finishing
touches he attacks the Rook which is
tied down to stay on the second rank the
seventh rank for black here otherwise
Queen F7 will be Checkmate it's a
hopeless position for Hikaru yeah he
just needs to add the white Rook to the
mix the other three pieces are perfectly
ideally placed I mean there's so many
flashy ways of trying to Checkmate here
Rook A2 looks good Bishop C6 he's moving
in for the kill he's getting ready to
sacrifice his Queen again in certain
variations or to just push the white D
Pawn this is beyond hopeless right now
Hikaru it's just been a heartbreaking
day tough tough day for him running into
inspired opponents you're supposed to
celebrate your birthday he came here had
his first matches on his birthday and
it's been the worst possible present I
mean it's just been really unfortunate
play for aari so many fans out there I'm
sure you're watching right now but this
is what happens when you go toe-to-toe
with all the best players even Hikaru
can have this kind of event where he's
losing match after match he still
somehow will have a chance to get to the
survival stage but uh today is not his
day he will have to he has to win
tomorrow he gives up he resigns shake
hands and Fabiano Carana gets another
win in the bag and for Hikaru Nakamura
now it's not only about winning his last
round robin game tomorrow but he will be
hoping for results to go his way he
needs some miracles to go into survival
stage and it comes down to this match it
comes down to this fight between alira
fuja and Dennis lavic Hikaru plays
Dennis tomorrow Ali Resa plays Magnus
tomorrow yeah as Robert said Hikaru will
be cheering uh for Dennis lazovic in
that one because he's the player he can
catch with a superior head-to-head with
a win tomorrow this one meanwhile still
nothing too much has changed other than
Black's Advantage growing and uh still
winning for Wesley so here okay at least
a thread on the board White's Queen
threatening to come into B8 with a nasty
check Black's King not entirely safe
where is the killer blow what is the
most professional way to end this one
black with a three-point Advantage
currently needs to turn it into
something bigger so close to touchdown
Queen back to D5 I'm struggling because
actually Black's rook in the corner as
well not entirely safe yeah it's a weird
position where I can't even calculate
how many pawns black is ahead if I'm not
mistaken black has seven white has four
so three extra pawns it doesn't look
like the material imbalance and the
queen B8 check that is a bit scary black
has a pawn one square away from
promotion but that Bishop covers it is
actually not nearly as clear as you
would think it should be and Wesley
could go wrong I'm going to eat my words
the advantage hasn't grown it's just
changed still winning but uh far less
easy or straightforward he drops the
queen back the whole way uh to her
starting Square this is based on the
fact that the black Rook on the corner
is edible you can go and take it wh's
Bishop on B2 can go take that black Rook
but black makes a new queen as well
white Bishop kind of stuck controlling
the promotion square of the C Pawn okay
Wesley keeping control with that move
but not a happy one uh he's still one
and a half minutes down on the clock as
well but it's a good defensive move cuz
you just stop any checks on B8 and the
bishop was hanging if a check did arrive
so still keeping everything under
control that C2 Pawn still a power power
Pawn there The Rook steps out of any uh
captures on h8 lines itself LC he does
SNAP up one Pawn the bishop on B7 is
hanging is it time to go Queen D5 he
does it there's a mate in one threatened
on G2 well Pawn E4 is a good way to stop
that Checkmate idea but that would
invite a queen trade and I think a queen
trade should definitely be favorable for
Wesley we to remember he doesn't need to
win this game it may be completely
winning he may know that the evaluation
Bar says as much but all he needs is a
draw so if he could force Queens off the
board make sure he has zero losing
chances that is probably the best way to
go let's just show that very quickly
Robert big big threat on the board
Checkmate on G2 and the move you want to
play Pawn to E4 yeah Wesley will not
even consider taking this Pawn when
there might be tricks on the F7 Square
he will immediately instantly get those
Queens off the board check and uh once
they're off yeah no matter how many
pawns you drop now here as black you can
pretty much guar guantee a draw you're
still a few pawns to the good and uh
therefore how else to defend this Square
you might just have to play a move like
Rook F2 as he has done allowing a queen
and uh we see Wesley now up a piece
that's a big piece as well that Knight
on C1 is hopping up to D3 to win some
more material nbak attacks the queen on
D5 he's still fighting do you just jump
back with your knight to D3 I think that
might be the safest uh if you drop black
back with the queen maybe safe to but
yeah why not block and the problem is
white will never even be able to take
this uh this pinned piece because
there's always ideas on the G2 square at
the right time black can also play a
move like F6 okay Queen to C3 he's still
fighting really hard here uh nck and
Wesley's just trying to get into an
advantageous end game and I think if you
do trade Queens after taking that Knight
the point is that black pushes the F
Pawn to F6 and there is this weakness on
the G2 Square you can't fall back to F3
the Knight will be picked up up so Queen
takes Knight is not even hanging in the
current position Wesley just up a full
piece tactically it fails for not backck
and for Wesley just reminder everybody
he has draw so if he draws this game it
counts as a win he wins the match so he
doesn't even need to Checkmate he
doesn't need to just scoop up all the
pawns he is doing everything just just
so so well in Toronto it's been a
magical place for him yeah getting those
Queens off by any means necessary comes
at the cost of most of his material
advantage but still a pawn up uh the
superior minor piece threats against the
G2 Square it's all adding up right now
and Wesley so just so calm I just I
can't remember one time he's even been
worse in this entire tournament and he's
just playing flawlessly now he's going
for the pawn on the other side of the
board he's going to pick up that a pawn
with an outside passer completely
winning and if he does get this in the
back that will be his sixth match
victory yeah this level this is over
pretty much I can't see any come back
any fight back and uh also he's up on
the clock 30 seconds with black this is
just greedy he's got everything Wesley
so and here comes the Aon oh my gosh
just keep pushing it right as long as
you don't walk into a night Fork that
loses you material you have this game in
the bag and Bishop to B3 is coming he
can move his King up and he can always
repeat moves if he makes a draw he wins
the match I know I've said that often
wow King in the center he's just going
to Checkmate the other king with his I
mean he's playing with that pawn on A3
the king marching up to E4 to F3 uh just
everything but the pawn on A3 it can be
picked up right now there is no
defending that one bit of a slip up
there from Wesley he could probably have
taken that with the black rook and
pushed the black pawn to A2 with a
winning end game but uh okay he's going
for White's kingside pawns instead and
no tricks if that King took the pawn
there would have been a pawn push with
check now the king can successfully
still not just one but two pawns over
there there's limited material so not's
is gone along with his pawns and that H
Pawn will March down the board Wesley so
on the brink of getting his sixth match
Victory he's going to just simply move
forward with the King and start pushing
pawns he's just going to keep checking
now with the black rook and force a draw
with some repetition wow and nck doesn't
have an option but to somehow keep the
game going because a draw is as bad as a
loss for nck here I was thinking might
Rook C2 check I was thinking can you get
away with that you shouldn't do that uh
that's playing play with fire but if
Wesley can trade off all of the pieces
and use his pass pawns then that could
end the game but I would just move my
king into the position free up the pass
Pawn that's going to rumble to the other
side the carpet is rolled out for it
he's reaching out he's not reaching look
at that calculation that's going on
there like a conductor with his
orchestra just choosing where to put the
pieces he was I think looking at all the
checks is he going to give a check from
B1 forc the white king to the edge of
the board and now he goes for the third
remaining Pawn forcing White's Rook to
passive position or lose the pawn yeah
so professional just removing any risk
every time Wes Le so three pawns to the
good now all Pawns in no hope for white
and will we even see a repetition Wesley
still going for the draw and so
professional Wesley so gets the job done
he takes it in the Armageddon that is a
six out of six performance by Wesley
he's Unstoppable and unfortunately for
Dennis lazik here in this game it looks
like he can't get past ala fuja it's a
bishop and two pawns against Knight and
two pawns he usually favors the bishop
when they're pawns on both sides of the
board but there's not enough material
remaining so if black can trade those
two pawns that you see on the king side
for just that one white Pawn the Knight
can sacrifice for the other a lone
Bishop with a king can't deliver
Checkmate against an enemy King so that
should be an easy Trek to a draw yeah
and the bad news for lazic as well is
that increment has kicked in we're past
move 60 we see on the Move counter move
60 now that means ala fuia gets 1 second
after every move and 11 seconds
therefore is Oceans of time this is a
really nice controlling move as well uh
in kind of contrast to that Bishop
versus knight we saw earlier today with
Abdu satov and Nakamura here black has
stability Black's Knight and pawns and
King block the dark squares uh by
sitting on light squares themselves no
way through the white king cannot step
forward and therefore no progress to be
seen and sad Retreat there Black's King
can even start coming towards wh BS he's
actually going for your uh your idea
that Robert he's just going to trade off
the king side eliminate it all and this
one will be a draw very soon no risk
whatsoever in order to win a game you
need to actually cause some problems and
at this stage of the game it's very
simple the king can just move back and
forth Black's pawns are defended and
there's nowhere for white to
go yeah another check literally nothing
to do here and fuja he knows exactly uh
what what he's aiming for he's got rid
of one of White's remaining pawns the
elimination of the other will spell the
draw handshake imminent and fuia is
going to take this onagon and that's it
and he does it he gets the draw in the
bag and with that a much needed match
win for alira fuja to keep him in the
race to make it to the survival stage
what a round this was desperately needed
but from Ala fua he was down in the
cellar now suddenly he stays afloat he's
ahead of two people hiar Nakamura and
Dennis lvic so if the tournament had
ended today alza would survive and
Hikaru would not Hikaru and disis
lazovic would be out but there is one
more game to be played tomorrow David
three incredible armag gadens once again
so much excitement on the board what was
your big highlight well it was uh that
all American battle between Carana and
Nakamura it might be decisive for the
standings and for Nakamura it was just
uh simp a atic of his unfortunate poor
form he actually got a good position
he'd outplayed Carana somewhat in the
middle game and here was where he
started to go wrong as black he's H done
a great job putting his two Rooks on an
open file and now adding pressure for
example with Queen to A5 to White's
backward C Pawn would have given black a
very healthy position forcing white
passive now black could for example just
sit and block and white is doing nothing
white is a bit stuck here with no
clearcut plan instead Nakamura actually
helped his opponent by jumping forward
with a knight to F4 and after a
trade-off whites could bring the queen
forward to D2 and yes it's opposite
color Bishops but a big weakness
appeared and uh if we fast forward just
a few more moves this Pawn dropped
another Pawn dropped and Fabiano was
able to convert his material advantage
it's one of those moments where you see
a pawn or a piece in enemy territory
that's good when you're attacking but
here there was no attack in fact that
pawn was too close to White's piece a
simple Queen slide hit it and won it and
then one more material so Fabiano maybe
he was shaky for a bit there but then he
capitalized and didn't look back and it
all comes down to tomorrow Hikaru
Nakamura will play Dennis lazic fuja
will play against Magnus Carlson David
high stakes so much tension what are you
expecting from all of this I've leared
to expect the unexpected at this point
and I mean it just feels like everyone's
given their all everyone's given their
best it's just the nerves kicking in in
these Armageddon especially and I'm
expecting more Armageddon tomorrow but
who knows the results
it's going to be a big day of Chess
tomorrow Robert what are you expecting
from the players who are fighting for
survival well Hikaru and Dennis they
know they need to win and for Ali Raza
you're looking down at hikaro like okay
if he beats Dennis I can't afford to
lose to Magnus so that clash between
Magnus and ala Magnus he's already
heading towards the semi-finals but for
ala there he needs to beat the world
number one to get through that's pretty
tough ala fua cannot be too happy with
the last round match up that's coming up
and it all comes down to the action
tomorrow as the players will be ready to
play in the final game of the round
robin and to talk more of Chess and all
of that happening in Toronto guys what a
day it's been all the aragats and the
drama that we built up to last round
tomorrow it's a goodbye from us but take
it away what's the scene like where all
the action is
happening thanks Tanya Robert and David
what is the scene like where all the
action is happening like chaos it's hard
to even explain Magnus was out there
watching the show with everyone as we
saw multiple Armageddon games go down
just now of course the biggest story of
the day continues to be the the fans
wondering wondering will hikaro be able
to turn it around but with fuia getting
that win who knows it's getting even
harder to imagine a world where hikaro
Nakamura is still here look at those
standings as you can see Carlson got the
job done in regulation everyone else had
to do it in Armageddon fashion Wesley so
took his match with abusa turov fua took
his match with lvic and Carana beat
Nakamura in the Armageddon
so wow candy your thoughts you were
watching it with Magnus out there we
were getting live commentary from the
goat that was pretty fun it's always fun
getting a live commentary from the goat
and he's like yeah this this in game's
winning I'm like oh perfect you just
learned something around these guys all
the time it just rubs off on you all the
time there but yeah definitely was not
rubbing off is uh you know it's not
working for Caro this just hurt this
hurts does even see that's my guy you
know what I mean like it hurts
Danny
hurts going to beat you're right there
man I know it must hurt you too huh I I
didn't know that it hurt that bad but
sorry I got a throat tickle there you go
that's what happens on on live TV but um
no it's it it was wild to watch and um
great job Magnus and Wesley do great job
great job and uh we know that Kaa caught
up with Fabiano so we'll see what he had
to say after his epic Armageddon victory
over
Hikaru here with Fabiano Carano who's
now definitely secured a spot on the
winners bracket in the survival stage
tomorrow so how do you feel about that
yeah that's good this was a tough match
of course I I was uh in danger in the
second game and after yesterday I'm of
course I was a bit worried because
losing two matches in a row and not
playing very well I was rather worried
but today went quite well and to get uh
a win in a must-win situation there with
white pieces against Hikaru uh how good
does that feel well you know I really
like Armageddon it's probably one of my
most successful um uh time I don't know
if you call it time control or formats
for chess yeah it's one of my most
successful so I I have a very very good
score overall playing in Norway chess I
have a good good score in Armageddon and
also in most of these online events I've
had a good score so um and also I played
some other tournaments with Armageddon
so I'm usually doing quite well I'm I
just like it because it's like it's very
clear what you have to achieve um while
in a game like sometimes especially with
the white pieces you don't know you want
to play for a win uh but then you maybe
push too hard and and I I even lost
three games with white pieces here in
like normal games against Magnus against
um Notre Beck uh and
against Ali Resa so I'm I'm losing all
my games with white but in Armageddon I
feel better well what does that tell us
about you the fact that you are able to
keep calm then maybe in those uh must
win or must not lose situations uh what
is it about you that you you do so well
in that situation I don't know I think I
just enjoy it but I have to say Hikaru
was definitely not in form today it's it
was very clear to me in this Armageddon
game that a lot of his decisions were uh
were not the best he he isn't playing at
his uh at his best level now I didn't
get to talk to you after that final uh
rapid game there was some situation uh
there where you did uh ask the Arbiter
if it if it was a draw can you take us
or what happened there yeah I thought
that it was a draw because I remembered
that he gave a check and I thought on A7
and I played King f8 but one time it was
he played Queen B7 and twice he played
Queen A7 so um yeah then it was wrong
and luckily the position doesn't hold
many ideas for him I believe so even
with two extra minutes that he got for
this incorrect claim um he wasn't able
to create any any serious ideas there we
had Magnus here when when that stuff was
going on and he said it's never really a
disadvantage to to ask the Arbiter um to
call a draw do you agree with that well
I I made this mistake against Notre Beck
because I I didn't even realize that it
was close to 50 moves by without making
any progress and excuse me if I had
known that then I would have um I would
have maybe uh you know tried to avoid
losing a pawn which is what happened or
getting checkmated and uh and claimed a
draw at some point so um it was actually
Maxim after that game that told me that
I was actually close to 50 moves R it
was like I think it was 48 moves U but I
had no no awareness of that and then
when I make a draw claim it was
incorrect as well so it seems like I
can't ever get yes I have to ask you as
well because they were wondering in the
studio at your level do you still study
those Queen end games um I yeah Queen
end games are a bit tough because you
can know everything that you want about
them but in practice they're very
difficult so you can study all types of
Queen end games but uh like there's all
sorts of structures they're all going to
be a little bit different and I don't
think that study will necessarily help
so much like usually these things end
because of a blunder not because of lack
of understanding I should study them
though now getting back to just the
tournament situation we know now
definitely you are in the winnner
braacket in the survival stage but you
you play Wesley so in your final game
round seven tomorrow so what do you
think about that but I think this match
is not very consequential because I
guess he's he's winning now against
Notre Beck uh like completely winning I
I mean I'm looking at right over there
and and so even if I beat him it doesn't
mean like top two are secured I think
Magnus Notre Beck right so or I sorry
Magnus Wesley yeah probably Wesley will
get first and Magnus will get second and
so I don't know um I mean I'll still
still try to do my best in the match but
it doesn't seem it's a strange situation
like if I win or if I lose the match it
maybe doesn't make a huge difference so
you two just G to enjoy that uh match
tomorrow and play some fun chess yeah it
seems like I can just enjoy it well
thank you uh for stopping by congrats on
securing a spot in the wi's bracket and
good luck tomorrow thanks going to have
some fun tomorrow Fabiano car on back to
you
guys it must be nice to just be able to
enjoy yeah the match tomorrow cuz we
know not everyone is going to be in that
chair including the man who Fabiano just
defeated in Armageddon 93% accuracy to
91 we know it came down to the wire it
was super close but you could see
Fabiano talking about that uh mistake in
claiming the draw KY he's now done it a
couple times your thoughts on that ever
happened to you that's hard to do you
know what's funny I mean we reach in
games but I'm a very aggressive player
so usually we get M it either me or them
usually but it's hard to do that claim
thing and I'm glad they have the thing
the little things there now the what is
those the move counter the move counters
yeah those are nice to have now cuz now
I you know oh let me just check it but
he was wrong but they would had it
yesterday maybe he may have knew you
know maybe be able to claim against the
tour off there I do tend to agree with
David's advice though obviously we're
giving a little bit of advanced chess
content for those who played tournament
chess that overall I think you're more
likely to regret not making a claim CU
if you think you can hold a draw giving
a little bit of time to your opponent
not the end of the world so Fabio was
beating himself up but I don't really
know that it's that necessary so all
right well we're going to take a quick
look at the uh the standings here real
quick again to remind you on Fab's
comments that he is safe that is true
both Wesley so and Magnus Carlson I
believe have clinched the fact that they
are the top two seeds at this point I
hate saying stats on screen if I end up
being wrong but I'm pretty sure they've
clinched and I'm pretty sure Fabiano and
Notre Beck are completely safe
and maybe even Max steam but of course a
ton is coming down to the fact that
Hikaru and Dennis laic as fate would
have it are actually paired to play WoW
and Ali Resa fuia gets Magnus Carlson
speaking of which fuia is with Kaa right
now Ali Resa finishing the day with such
an important match win how are you
feeling right now yeah it is it was must
win so was a lot of pressure but yeah
I'm happy to win this and I don't expect
much anyway from this tournament because
it has to go really tomorrow I have to
win so it's a tough day it will be
tomorrow you do have two players below
you on the table hiar Nakamura and
Dennis lovik you do play Magnus Carlson
tomorrow for a chance to go through to
the survival stage so what are your
thoughts on that crucial match yeah I
think it's a most win for me um and he
doesn't have pressure so it will be a
tough day but yeah I have to try and um
we'll see but yeah my game my play was
not very good in this tournament so um
we'll see but okay Hikaru also didn't
play good so we both don't deserve to
qualify so we'll see how I disagree I
think you deserve to go through good
luck to marel Resa that's going to be so
exciting thank you thank you for joining
us wow back to you guys in the
[Music]
studio post match as you can see right
there really strange when someone wins
playing less accurate chess but from
time to time that can happen and you see
all he res he said it himself he's like
I don't really think I played that well
but I got away with it and here you are
sitting in a much better spot than
Dennis loic is to move on all right well
we've looked at so much we've made so
many predictions we all missed Levy this
whole time and you know I think we're
going to have to continue to do things
without Levy if he was here I might even
put the glasses right
on oh he's here what's up guys what's up
guys where did you come from what's up
guys what's up baby we don't anymore how
we doing great to see you
gentlemen there is here it's great to be
here with the guy here with the guys
Levy Rosman Levy
um we've missed you yeah yeah what the
hell is this you don't want do that I
mean get it later guys great job uh
honestly thank you for holding it down
amazing studio have really enjoyed
watching it in in the house uh but it's
great to be here and I came on such an
epic day you did so much wild chess oh
my goodness I'm going to let you take it
away then because you're here with the
guy who maybe had the most epic game of
the day we'll let you ask him his first
question obviously the match with Magnus
Carlson was all the talk yeah uh wow I I
mean I don't even know where to start I
I hate asking this I really don't like
when interviewers ask this we always do
like how does it how are you feeling
right now I just talked to you a little
bit over there off camera I said is it
what's inspiring you to play so well
here Wesley well it's uh it's incredible
as I said I was honest when I said
before the tournament started I just
want to finish in the top six and then
TR to make it like doesn't matter to me
whether it's losers or winners bracket
but uh yeah I don't know I say I give it
to God prise Jesus for giving me the
wins because I didn't do anything like
different or specific like uh I came I
came uh from I played two tourament St
Louis then I had uh maybe three days to
prepare three days to work like I work a
little bit and then no nothing too
nothing too hard and then I came in very
relaxed very happy like last year I
thought I told myself I'll just do the
same routine as I did exactly last year
you know same place and just do the same
exact thing like get some exercise in
the morning uh not to prepare too much
uh arrive an hour or an hour and a half
like just hang out just chill relax
listen to some music and uh and play
hard make use of my chances and
surprisingly work very well like never
in my wildest dreams would have I've
ever imagined million years I would win
my first six matches especially with
Magnus you know Magnus hikaro Fabby for
terman I thought Magnus hiar Fab are the
clear
favorites uh but uh yeah something went
wrong with iaro clearly did you hear
that he said exercise this is flex so
here what you been what you been eating
what you doing every day what's you're
the one working out I just do cardio
man but you probably bench like what 300
yeah probably all three of y'all at the
same time yeah a lot of that but what's
what's actually exercise wise and like
you said preparing so what kind of
preparation is going into like what are
you doing it's definitely working for
you Wesley yeah well well you can say
that but actually had a pretty difficult
year like I lost uh 6 rating points in
the World Cup okay so that made my
candidate qualification I got a pretty
bad tournament there and uh you know I
don't think I've ever won I don't think
I've won a tournament this year so I
really want to give my all for for this
uh for this last one you definitely are
doing that and know Danny is here to
cheer me up I mean I rarely get to feed
Danny oh Danny by the way you have we
can't spoil we can't spoil the video
hasn't played yet but at some point I'll
let you cash in what you won party
exactly yeah my
Danny date actually I'll just keep
it now now you're spoiling it but I
can't wait for people to see you're good
um but I thought oh you haven't
published the video yeah it's coming out
when are you planning to publish it
should be out ASAP right A lot of people
want to know what we got up to in our
little Christmas holiday party so it'll
be fun but no no spoilers I'll jump in
here and then we'll and then we'll we'll
rotate again but because I was actually
planning to like uh thr Anish but then I
I guess I can't spoil it so I got to
wait for a video to come out first like
like what's the best Christmas present
you ever had in your life or the most
memorable and the answer
is well but I can't spoil it yet I
Wesley I know I know uh you know you're
obviously you're in a great space right
now so I'm not going to mess with your
mindset more than anybody else would
obviously you need to stay right there
and I just want to say that seeing you
confident obviously focusing on on
having the right the right habits the
right approach to the game is clearly
paying off and uh you know and again I
just want to come back to the comments
you made post interview with with with
Ka after you beat Magnus you said that
you decided to just throw caution to the
Wi you knew that was your best hope yeah
is that something you're going to kind
of put in your pocket for future
opportunities where you really put the
kind of pressure on Magnus that frankly
nobody ever puts that kind of pressure
on Magnus maybe people should do it more
often and what are your thoughts about
what happened with that yeah yeah I hope
so I mean I hope so I mean it depends
who your opponent is but I think against
Magnus I I direct attack is the best
because uh he's as he said himself he he
probably memorized like 10,000 games I
think that's what he said once so he
knows like a lot of different structures
like I was worried he'd play like one E4
E5 and just outplay me n Lopez so I I
figured I got to go all in well depends
who your opponent like against not Beck
for example he's a very aggressive
player so maybe the other way around but
uh would be a better approach but yeah I
was thinking about the interview we did
uh before the first day and uh yeah
people have been saying my style has
been too dry uh and
uh yeah a change you know to to keep
your to keep your chess career strong
and going I think you need to include
flexibility you need to learn new things
learn new openings I remember Co no said
that uh yeah if you want to improve in
your chest you need to learn new
openings also I've been watching like
obviously follow all the games of my
rivals like in all the tournaments they
play and I noticed like Hikaru has also
been tring out all kinds of Sicilians
Fabby can play any opening Magnus can
play any opening so uh that's uh that's
clearly one of the secret you got to be
playx fo and you've been watching Gotham
chess videos that's what you listen I
hope so but I also hope not all right
he's playing here I can definitely take
some credit but uh but Wesley I was
going to ask you um I think a lot of the
time when we say a chess player is
struggling during the year we we really
focus on the classical tournaments like
you mentioned the World Cup right that's
a lot of chess players play in the World
Cup uh the event here is 15 minute with
like a three it's a very different time
format yeah it's not Blitz which I think
a lot of people find too casual too
relaxed too fun it's also not classical
which I think when strong players get
out of form it can really spiral like
they can lose 20 30 points or something
like that so how do you find that
balance to play 15minute chess really
well because it's not you don't you're
not spending time practicing 15-minute
chess online you know like hikaro
streams three minute Blitz right so is
it just kind of like a blank slate do
you just just kind of comes naturally to
you to play rapid so well well I think
experience and learning from your past
mistakes like obviously I had uh I also
had terrible rapid tournaments like in
uh St Louis R Bliss I lost I lost three
games and W1
so uh you kind of learn from your
experience learn as you go learning from
your past mistakes what you did wrong
think what you did right you know
anything you can share specifically like
without giving away any secrets just is
it is it a mindset thing is it certain
openings is it just forcing yourself to
move a little faster at critical moments
yeah it's a combination of all the
little details but uh I believe you know
it's still chess but I believe Blitz
rapid compared to classical it's all
psychological so all about mindset like
for as you say forcing yourself to just
move like you're never going to
calculate perfectly so sometimes just
got to trust your intuition and just
make a move and be practical be smart uh
obviously I'm not the best at this but
be practical um you
know you're you're going to make
mistakes in in a Speed game so it just
got to uh also understand that uh it's
not just a tactical battle also it's a
positional battle and also I figured
it's not a good idea to spend too much
time preparing for for Speed EV rapid
Blitz yeah because you can have you can
get Advantage out the opening but uh if
you're not in good form you're not going
to convert it and also I figured like if
you just arrive very relaxed very happy
play with nothing to lose you know and
just uh give your all and maybe also
it's you know it's like for me it works
well but maybe also if you stick to the
openings that you know uh stick to the
openings that you're very familiar with
because then they doesn't matter who has
the advantage it's about who's got more
comfortable position and uh also getting
your opponents to positions or openings
that they don't know very well you can
get a big Advantage with that uh I know
many people many coaches who say that uh
maybe not you but many coaches say that
uh in order to improve you gotta keep
solving you know because that's the way
to improve like your brain is thinking
you're solving
uh but I like rep playing like top level
games like you know I like ancing my
rivals games like I've been following
all the big tournaments and you know you
learn from them you learn from them and
you learn how to play chess well I'm
sure a lot of them are learning from you
right now Wesley and wondering what they
can do to get a piece of that Toronto
vibe that you're bringing so we're going
to let you go yes congratulations you're
crushing it congrats on already securing
the top seed I I secured up first yeah
I'm okay don't take my word for it maybe
if you lose Magnus wins but you have
secured a spot in the semi-finals for
sure yes I believe you've secured the
top seed yeah the thigh breaks yeah you
already be yeah so you have and uh and
either way so they have to show up
tomorrow you do have to show up for do
not do that to me that is not good
content good content is showing up
although maybe yeah show up for tomorrow
have a great night tonight I might see
you later we'll cash that coupon yes
thanks d all right we're we're going to
take a look at who's playing but Wesley
you're awesome and uh thank you and all
right oh and and uh I mentioned if we
ever do this again next year make sure
to hold in Toronto okay I will I mean I
know how you feel about Toronto at this
point and there it is Wesley so he will
show up versus Fabi Carana don't worry
fans tune in for that but you've got
Carlson versus fuia as you know a huge
matchup and Nakamura versus lvic not
taking anything away from Medusa turov
and Vash lrav uh obviously both those
guys have secured their spots though so
really coming down just some interesting
stuff there and Levy I guess I got to
ask you which match ups you're most
excited to see probably know the obvious
two but your thoughts on on what's going
into the the mindset there from these
players yeah so that obviously the two
matchups that I guess matter let's say
are Hikaru versus lavic which was a
matchup that at the beginning of the
event was supposed to be Hikaru gets
it's like a round one equivalent of
let's say a US Open in tennis but l has
been a beast he's drawing basically
everybody Karu is in a musn situation
and how about this Magnus could lose to
fuja right still make the semis probably
and fuja winning means that match
doesn't even matter ridiculous how do
you feel about that cuz that's that's
nuts it is nuts in
fact let's let's take a look at the
standings it it it is interesting
because I I think one risk of that
actually no I mean obviously if Magnus
loses even if Fabiano car wins I think
Magnus still has the direct seed to the
semis of course I don't think I don't
think any of these players are playing
subterfuge but it is really interesting
meta when it comes to considering that
if you're Magnus you kind of hold the
keys to hakar nakamura's Destiny right
now yeah this is like in the in the in
the playoffs right like in the
basketball playoffs or something where
you could lose to secure a better
matchup or to affect the standings I
never believe that stuff but we're
watching it play out in real time I mean
again I think Magnus is gonna obviously
show up and play his best and cuz he
wants to win and he's probably unhappy
that he didn't beat Wesley today he
wants to win as many matches as possible
but that that is pretty goofy I'm shock
I'm in disbelief at hikaru's performance
I like I I I'm rooting for the guy in
all these events right like but I don't
know what to say I'm Blown Away it hurts
it really hurts you know because I rock
with Caro very hard so when it when it
hurts I'm like I'm out there like oh I
feel it just as he does right so it
really hurts to maybe tomorrow you pick
loc okay you're right you picked Boys
Boys Boys I've been sitting in my living
room shocked at the
unmitigated G of y'all talking about
these players in front of their face we
know how sensitive chess players are
like this is a CR can you imagine
sitting here being told I think he's
going to L he's going to crush him every
game 100% here's the deal here's the
deal so there was a lot of discussion
last night after what happened with Ali
Reza and obviously Magnus gave it an
interview where he's like frankly I like
it like like but okay he's got a
different mindset but just for the
record we talk to all the players and
surprisingly pretty much all of them
were like yeah I don't mind it I
actually think it's kind of cool that
said I didn't want to continue if a
single player was no longer comfortable
with it we made a change we're not going
to do it for the rest of the event we
will pre-match predict as much as we can
in the other room that said I also think
it's interesting because I think overall
in other sports people are aware of what
the experts are saying and doing all the
time this is a very intimate setting I
acknowledge and uh and we'll see what
the future holds so I didn't mean to cut
you off like I I was watching Eagles
Cowboys right like they go through every
every I root for the Cowboys I like you
got eight pcks for the Cowboys two for
the like you got to choose I mean you
got to choose and and I I respect what
you said it's important that the fans
know you guys are talking to the PO
about every decision you make this is
not like a production decision this is
not cuz we're growing this all together
we're growing it with them I really
appreciate you saying that we talked
about that at the open ceremony dinner
you're talking about I think a
generation of people who are very much
feel like we're all in this together
even if from time to time something
happens that someone doesn't like we
talk it out y you know we've got DMS
with a hard emojis after you validate
and hear the other person's side and
that's where we're at it's really true
in the end I feel pretty good about
where we're going here I feel pretty
good that you're here L's here guys
Lev's here you're sticking with us
tomorrow your event got can so you'll be
here that that was good I did not he had
the hands class he could have just oh my
this why there's weight classes man
taking you down he
keep each other not chess when are you
chess boxing when's that it's coming up
it's coming up we are working on that no
you were going to be in the chess boxing
that got canceled can I reveal that uh
yeah you can okay he cany was going to
be in the chess boxing that got canceled
for the record so we actually didn't
have an opponent for him you know why
because no one wanted to fight the man
so that was a different problem that
Ludwick had but again we won we won't
say more I mean if they get to his size
they still got to be like 2,300 fet a
like they got like it's ridiculous I
mean you you got the size but you could
be 11100 100 maybe I mean C's going to
Checkmate you in 10 moves listen we SED
all the people up out there we're like
2700 huh how would you think I don't
think anybody wants to fight candy or
Levy actually if you look at social
media these days all right I think I
think we've uh We've crushed it for
those of you who don't know tomorrow is
going to be the most epic day in
Champions chess tour history of every
year we've ever had you start off with
the last round of the round robin and we
move right to the survival Gauntlet
we're talking about a four match
tomorrow if they go to Armageddon we're
going to be here all night boys so
everyone get some rest stick with us
we're going to let everyone have a great
night thank you to the whole crew from
Oslo to Toronto this is chess.com this
has been the 2023 Champions chess tour
make sure you tune in bright and early
we'll see you for the round robin
conclusion and the survival stage see
you
then he should be very happy with what
he's got out of the opening what on
Earth is that bang night sacrifice Maxim
V GRA with a dark Square Bishop has been
a holy beast but you have to beat him in
every move and Wesley saw has done it
Magnus Carson resigns oh andar Nakamura
he gets up he resigns n Abdul satov he
reacts he knows he's done it he gives up
he resigns shake hands and Fabiano
Carana gets another win in the
bag
[Music]
oh